Oh Mann, Podcast Marathon,
Hallo, hier ist die Nummer zweihundertsechzehn zweihundertsechzehn, zweihundertsechzehn. Was welcher Film fällt da bei euch welcher Film? Gott, ich berede schon seit zehn Stunden heute. Welcher Film fällt euch da ein.
Zweihundertsechzehn.
Muss man nicht wissen.
Aber gibt's noch eine Einheit dazu vielleicht oder irgendsowas.
Drei Komma eins vier eins zwo neun fünf sieben.
Das wäre Pi oder zumindest eine Annäherung daran.
Ja, weil das war nicht Pi.
Zahl, die in dem nee, das ist der Film P.
Wo ich keine Ahnung habe.
Zweihundertsechzehn.
Weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber die 2hundert16 Spiele auf jeden Fall 'ne Rolle.
Fängt ja schon mal gut an.
Ich bin total durch. Ich habe gerade irgendwie kurz vor dieser Sendung eine andere Sendung beendet und vorher irgendwie stundenlang Planung gemacht für, kann man hier gleich auch nochmal ankündigen, Lochbuch-Netzpolitik zweihundertsechsundfünfzig,
Unsere äh unser achtes Bit.
Das sagt man, das hatte schon mal irgendwo, aber ich kann mir jetzt auch nicht erinnern.
Jeder. Ja, das ist ja einfach. Ich weiß nicht, so diese bieten ja Potenzen. Findet man auch Leute, die beeindruckt sind, wenn man mühelos Zweierpotenzen runterbeten kann.
Er kommt drauf an, bis zu welchem Bit, ne. Also,
Ich glaube also die die 16 Bitch schaffe ich. Siebzehnten da muss ich dann.
Muss man ich würde sagen bis 16 ist bis 16 komme ich auch.
Also oben ist halt fünfundsechzig fünf sechsunddreißig, zweiunddreißig 7 68 und dann weiter unten und so weiter, also sechzehn drei vierundachtzig acht eins zwo neunzig und ja dann kennt man den Rest schon.
Diese 13tausend irgendwas, da komme ich immer ins ins Dings und die zwohundert, keine Ahnung was, komme ich auch ins Dingsding. Ja, das ist dann, das hat man dann nicht so oft.
Kommst du ins Dingsen? Ja da kann man da kann man schon mal ins Dingsen kommen.
Also so ab siebzehnten Bit wird's dann da schwächel ich dann.
Ja, ne, deswegen acht bitte ist natürlich für jeden noch irgendwie total.
Ist ja nun wirklich, dass er Grundschule.
Wobei ich jetzt äh grad vor ein paar Tagen meinem Sohn äh so kilobyt und Megabyte äh erklärt habe und immer wieder feststellen muss, dass ich empört bin. Empört bin,
Empört über diese Unsitte mit diesem Miwi Bites und Kiwi Bites. Erstmal klingt das scheiße,
finde ich ist das äh so ein bisschen auch äh wie sagt man,
nicht Angst vorm Feind, sondern.
Schwanz eingezogen.
Nein, Scheitern, wie heißt das vom Feind? Was hat man das darf der Soldat nicht haben vom Feind,
Nein. Oh Gott, Hirn ist leer.
Wir kennen uns mit Soldaten noch nicht so aus, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ja, ja. Feigheit, genau,
vom Feind. Ist denn ist dir das überhaupt bewusst, diese Mibite und Kipi-Bike.
Klar, Apple macht das ja.
Ja, schlimm genug, aber.
Nee, Apple macht's eben nicht, sondern nutzen weiter mega und Kilo, aber eben als Tausend, so wie es sich's gehört.
Nee, Sie haben's irgendwann.
Na ja so ich finde ja nicht, dass ich das so gehört.
Nee, haben sie nicht. Nein, haben sie nicht.
Doch, haben sie umgestellt. Weil alle Festplattenhersteller das so angeben.
Ja. Die machen's fürs Dateisystem, aber sie machen's nicht für Ramm. Weil bei Ramm macht's keinen Sinn. Bei Ramm wirst du niemals in tausender Einheiten zählen.
Ja, aber bei Dateien machen sie's oder.
Machen sie.
Nutzen Sie Kilo wie Kilo man halt kennt und keine.
Das Kilo Bite ist einfach faktisch entwertet der Begriff ist tot, weil er halt nicht einheitlich verwendet wird.
Ja Kiwi bald sagen.
Nee, das werde ich niemals sagen. Ich werde nicht Kiwi bald sagen.
Ja, ich auch nicht. Macht auch niemand.
Nein, es macht niemand genau deswegen.
Der Standard ist jetzt halt nun mal da und wird immerhin schriftlich kann man's jetzt halt unterscheiden und damit ist es exakt, weil bei manchen Dokumenten keine Ahnung, wenn sie wissenschaftlich irgendwie wichtig ist, dann dann kann man halt wenigstens unterscheiden. Der sagt Kilo oder er sagt Kibi.
Ja, aber das ist doch scheiße, weil wenn du von Ramm redest und und Kilobyte und Megabyte in die Hand nimmst, dann meinst du ja nicht zur Basis tausend. Sondern.
Klar, aber da musst du Kiwi sagen.
Kein Mensch.
Aber dann kann man's schriftlich unterscheiden und dann ist es exakt, sonst ist es halt falsch.
Aber äh aber es ist doch es äh äh es ist doch.
Was Tim eigentlich sagen will, welcher Trottel ist auf die Idee gekommen.
Ja, es hat doch 30 Jahre auch funktioniert. Das ist doch wie deutsche Rechtschreibreform,
Ja, wir machen das jetzt mal einfacher und dabei diesen ganzen Prozess verzetteln sie sich so dermaßen, dass keiner mehr weiß, wo oben und unten ist. Es weiß doch heutzutage keiner, keiner mehr wer Deutsch schreibt richtig, also.
Da grätscht man auch gleich mal ein. Ich finde, wir haben einen Sendungstitel gefunden, wie einer im Chat grad sagt, Mimi bald.
Ja, ich höre auch die ganze Zeit Mimi, also.
Aber das Mimimi kommt ja nicht von mir, das.
Nein, doch.
Von den anderen. Nein, das ist ja viel zu schwer zu.
Weißt schon, dass das.
Leute wissen doch nicht, wo ist denn da bitte die Notwendigkeit? Ich meine, warum braucht man denn das? Wofür.
Weil Kilo eine wissenschaftliche also eine eine Einheit ist, die.
Scheiß drauf. Du weißt doch sowieso nicht, wie viel scheiß Bikes deine deine Datei auf der Festplatte belegt, weil da so viele Meterdaten dabei sind, dass die Zahl, die Zahl der der Zeichen in dieser Datei.
Man muss die Kinder austoben lassen, damit sie abends dann ordentlich einschlafen.
Es ist schlimm. Es hört einfach auf.
Bitte lasse niemals den Tim so gefrustet uns hinterher also als Hinterlassenschaft hier, nämlich.
Ich ich prangere.
Dachte du bist müde und bist den ganzen Tag, du bist.
Langsam wach. Ich.
Ist erstmal ein Keks.
Tim, äh ich habe glaube ich dann Probleme immer noch nicht verstanden.
Na ja mit mit Vollmond spricht man nicht hin. Wir haben ihn wir haben ihn reingelegt.
Du hast das Pole nicht verstanden, ich erklär's dir ganz einfach. 30 Jahre lang hat dieser Begriff wunderbar funktioniert und alle wussten Bescheid.
Für alles, was C noch zwei.
Dann kommen irgendwelche na ja ist halt ein anderes Cha.
Zwei hoch zehn.
Großes Kleiska. Kleines Kater ausm 24 großes K. Ja, beim M haben sie ein bisschen gepatzt.
Ja weil Millibite gibt's nicht.
Aber Kiwi Balt, ich bitte dich, wieder schon klingt, Kiwi, worauf nimmt denn das überhaupt kulturelle kulturelle Referenz,
Da gibt's doch nix. Kiwi. Kannst du die Situation vorstellen, wo Leute in einem Raum besitzen und darüber grübeln, wie sie das nennen? Oder nennen sie's Kiwi Bite.
Kirschspinale.
So sieht's doch aus,
das an. Ich finde das nicht gut. Das trennt mich, das trennt mich auch von meiner Jugend. Ich äh.
Äh äh.
Weißt du wie's der CSU geht? Wenn da jemand mal Veränderung vorschlägt,
weißt du, das ist die Reaktion.
Wissen noch nicht mal, worüber ich rede. Ihr denkt nämlich wahrscheinlich, Kilo-Beite sind einfach tausendvierundzwanzig. Guckt mal, guckt mal unter weiß nicht, was ist das äh was,
Ein Kilobyte sind natürlich 124 Bikes,
zwo vier acht sechzehn zweiunddreißig vierundsechzig hundertachtundzwanzig zweihundertsechsundfünfzig.
Aber ist doch unlogisch.
Zwei hoch zehn, sagte ich aber.
Ist daran unlogisch.
Weil Kilo Nummer tausend ist.
Mann, das ist doch scheißegal. Es gibt halt zwei Welten, es gibt die Dezimalwelt und es gibt die Binärwelt und in der binär.
Und wurde ruhig unterscheidet man die.
Das ist doch konnte aus, das wird doch aus dem Kontext vollkommen klar. Du redest über Computer und dann ist es einfach tausendvierundzwanzig.
Ich sehe das nicht ganz so ein.
Also breit, halt.
Aha, so wie viel, wie viel Megabyte hat denn dein Computer,
Na? Kannste.
Hat er übrigens Gigabyte.
Ja Gigabyte Megabyte ist doch geht doch da alles komplett aus der Spur. Das kann man nicht zur Basis zehn machen.
Das hört Gigi bald.
Welt ist, einfach mal zur Basis zwei. Und das wird sich auch nicht ändern.
Was auch bei vielen Sachen, die auch so ein bisschen Computerwelt sind, wo das eben nicht mit der Basis 2 ist, also zum Beispiel
dein dein Netzwerk hier, dein dein DSL oder sowas, die geben das auch nicht mit der Basis zu 2 an, wenn die davon von ähm.
Ja, Megabit ist, glaube ich, auch nicht in der Zweier-Potenz. Und.
Das liegt aber an ISDN.
Ist schon sehr verwaschen und durcheinander, deswegen ich verstehe schon, dass Sie das äh auch dokumentarisch und textlich und so ein bisschen, dass man das trennen will,
Damit Leute nicht erst wissen müssen, ja okay, es ist Rahmen okay, dann ist es tausendvierundzwanzig, sondern dass man's gleich alle Einheiten erkennen kann. Man will schon eine Einheit, die sehr klar ist. Wir wollen nicht, dass die NASA wieder was hochschickt und die wieder zwischen zwischen äh.
Klar ist, aber es ist nicht klar.
Meilen und Kilometern was falsch machen.
Ist aber nicht klar. Schon auf deinem ist es nicht klar. Ramm steht auch nur Megabyte und auf der Festplatte steht auch Megabite, aber es meint beides mal was anderes. Da steht ja nicht.
Ja dann haben die das halt noch falsch, weil sie nicht Mibi hingeschrieben haben.
Keiner will, weil sogar bei Apple die Ästhetikpore aufgeht und irgendwie Tonnen von Talg ausschüttet, weil es nicht zu ertragen ist.
Ja das hatten sie lange nicht.
Dann hätten sie damit nicht anfangen sollen.
Prangere das an. Gut. Wollen wir nochmal anfangen.
Amen.
Schneiden das raus.
Ich hätte ja eher gefragt, haben wir noch Themen, aber.
2hundert16 jetzt bin ich aber auch auf.
Und was war jetzt mit den zweihundertsechzehn.
Äh dass die Sendungen, die wir gerade haben. Ja, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas bei P, habe ich vergessen. War auf jeden Fall cool. Ich glaube, es war irgendeine Aufzählung, wo er ihm irgendwie vorwirft, dass er gerade total durchdreht oder so. Der große, der alte.
Ich habe da grad so ein Déj-vu.
Dreht durch.
Also Tims Anfang war schon so ein kleines Durchdrehen.
Das war ein ganz normaler Rand. Kommen wir zur zum Team. Rody ist da.
Äh guten Abend.
Abend, Dennis ist da. Ja und Letti ist da,
ist nicht da, der äh lässt sich nach wie vor entschuldigen.
Stimme der Jugend ist heiser.
Ja ist heißer, genau. Clemens ist da, aber nicht da, aber dafür haben wir einen Gast und zwar den Sebastian.
Ja, grüß Gott.
Hallo, grüß Gott. Sag mal, bist du aus dem Süden.
Nee in Norddeutschland sagt man das, wenn man Menschen einfach verwirren will. Das ist so eine Art Witz da zu sagen grüß Gott.
In welchem Norddeutschland.
Nein, Schleswig-Holstein, wo ich so herkomme. Ja ja, also ist recht in Ordnung.
Also richtiges Norddeutschland. Verstehe. Da bist du also her. Also Sebastian Jabusch. Ein paar Leute kennen dich ja vielleicht.
Zu befürchten.
Ja, muss sein Mikro ein bisschen noch ein bisschen näher ran. Du musst nicht so Angst vorm Wäldern haben. Noch schlimmer ist, nicht gehört zu werden. Da muss ja der.
Okay. Aber vielleicht kann man den Kopfhörer einen Tick leiser machen. Ist mir.
Äh ist alles im Preis enthalten, ja. Lasst mich kurz schauen. So, jetzt ist es besser. Du hörst.
Preis wurde nicht ja, jetzt schließ los. Ja, ich höre es.
Du hörst also noch gut. Das ist gut. Ähm ja,
Ich habe dich mal eingeladen, weil ich äh dachte, dass du äh was zu erzählen hast. Nee, ich weiß, dass du was zu erzählen hast.
Ganz schön viel zu erzählen, ne.
Du bist ja in den äh in den digitalen Gefilden auch ganz gut unterwegs,
Aber das ist ja auch eine ganz interessante äh Vorgeschichte, die ich jetzt gar nicht so im Detail kenne, ähm nur so zwei, drei äh Dinge, die mir jetzt gerade so vorne noch in irgendeinem Hirnlappen herumschweben,
Unter anderem bist du einen ähm anders, heute ist mit einem Begriffen wirklich ein bisschen schwierig äh ein Unruhestifter.
Ja, freiberuflich sozusagen.
Das finde ich ja eigentlich immer ganz gut. Unter anderem hast du deine äh Universität äh zur Weißglut gebracht.
Äh die Universität äh und die Stadt drumrum und den Landkreis, genau.
Genau, alle. Oh, du hättest doch auch einfach studieren können. Was hast du denn da überhaupt studieren? Äh ich also wir reden von der Universität in Greifswald.
Ich hab Politik Geschichte Greifswald genau.
Wir gleich noch mal. Ja? Ja und da da bist du.
Ja und äh Geschichte öffentliches Recht und Politik habe ich studiert. Okay. Noch so ganz klassisch auf Magista. Alter Tümlich, noch nicht Bachelor, Master, diese Todgeburt der nein. Hm.
Der Bildungsreform. Ja ja, ganz schlimm. Und ähm du schätzt ja auch einfach machen können und gut ist.
War war auch der Vorschlag meiner Mutter. Ich hätte das auch lieber so gesehen und ähm ich habe mir auch ganz viel Mühe gegeben am Anfang und erstmal so dieses Grundstudium fertig gemacht und dann habe ich gesagt, so jetzt geht's aber los,
Jetzt jetzt muss man ein bisschen Spaß sein. Und nee, ich
wollte halt ne wie wenn man so ist, ne, man will halt Dinge tun ähm du hast ja hier gerade das Tuward Shirt an und
Und dann war ich halt, ich bin eigentlich mehr so journalistisch als aus Kindheitstagen noch unterwegs gewesen und war so beim Studentenmagazin und Studentenfernsehen und was man so alles so so machen kann,
Und da ist äh da gab's in der Zeitung äh diese Studentenzeitung gab es ein eine eine regelmäßige Kolosse sozusagen über den Namensgeber unserer Universität,
den Abend des Monats und da haben wir dann immer oder hat jemand einen Redakteur immer ein Zitat von dem Namenspatron äh der Universität, der heißt Ernst Moritz Arndt äh rausgesucht,
Und ähm das war oft sehr äh erschreckend, antisemitisch, rassistisch, äh menschenverachtend,
Und ähm genau und äh das haben wir, das habe ich über drei, vier Jahre schon im Grundstudium beobachtet gehabt und irgendwann habe ich mich angefragt,
Wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass unsere Universität.
Sozusagen so ein so ein Namenspatronen hat, der so viele unmöglichste Zitate hat, ne und äh und dann haben wir mich mit diesen Menschen beschäftigt und es stellte sich heraus, dass das eben ein Dichter und Denker aus dem frühen 19. Jahrhundert ist,
der eben für die äh Vereinigung Deutschlands stand, das ist die positive Version, aber eben seine Version, also Deutschland wäre ursprünglich mal viele kleine Staaten und seine Version, wie man Deutschland vereinen könnte, war eben,
Abgrenzung von allen anderen. Also das waren in dem Fall die,
Franzosen, die dumm äh Slava Slaven,
doofen, noch hässlicheren Nordvölker und alle anderen und natürlich so und und er hat sozusagen versucht ähm,
Einigung durch Hass gegen andere zu kreieren sozusagen,
Das war ein sehr erfolgreiches äh Motiv und das hat sozusagen Ernst Moritz Arndt berühmt gemacht, indem er seine Hetzschriften
sozusagen in vielen deutschen Staaten verbreitet hat und er wird dann eben in diese in diese Bewegung äh sich sich hoch eine große Bedeutung gehabt, die dann eben
Deutsche Vereinigung vorangetrieben hat, bevor sie dann, genau, das ist Ernst, aber ist eben auf der einen Seite zwar dieser Denker, der eben.
Diese Hetzschriften und Gedichte veröffentlicht habe, aber eben gleichzeitig auch dann später von den Nazis 1933 als Vorbild und als,
Ausrede benutzt worden, um ihren ähm ja ihren Antisemitismus in die Tat umzusetzen sozusagen und,
haben dann eben 1933 als erste fast erste Akt sozusagen erstmal die Universität Greifswald eben nach Ernst Moritz Arndt benannt. Und da war der gute äh,
Hermann Göring persönlich anwesend als Propagandaminister an der Universität Christel hat den den der Universität den Namen gegeben und all das erfuhr ich dann weil in den deutschen Schulbüchern,
Ist Ernst-Moritz Ant überall gestrichen worden nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg und deswegen kennt man in Deutschland Ernst Ahnen kommen noch,
Frankreich ist es zum Beispiel anders. Da ist so ein so ein,
erkennt den jeder, weil der die Inkarnation des Franzosenhasses ist,
In Israel kennen sie den auch, weil er halt der Erfinder des modernen Antisemitismus ist, also im Gegensatz zum,
Judaismus, der sozusagen christlich bedingt war, weil ja die Juden angeblich Jesus getötet hätten äh und er hat sozusagen eine Blutbegründung gegeben, also,
Das ist sozusagen Ensbritan und der war der Namenspatron meiner Uni.
Und das fandste dann nicht so geil und hast äh Welle gemacht.
Ja, also ich gar nicht alleine, sondern ganz viele Studenten hatten Welle gemacht. Ähm ich war nur der, der gesagt hat, lass uns mal richtig, richtig, richtig dolle Welle machen, weil es gab so eine kleine Antrag eigentlich in der im Studierendenparlament, äh dass man mal
Anregung, Umbenennung anregen soll oder so und ich habe gesagt, na ja, das wird ja nix,
Schon irgendwie dreimal diskutiert worden. Das steht ja jetzt auch schon seit fünf Jahren und im Studentenmagazin, dass der Typ irgendwie durchgeknallte Rassist ist,
So so verändern wir das nicht und ich habe gesagt, wir brauchen eine Kampagne und wir brauchen auch sozusagen ein Symbol, ein ein ein,
etwas damit das sozusagen sichtbar wird, weil eben keiner ernst Moritz ankennt,
Um das zu lösen, haben wir dann, habe ich dann ähm mich damals als vorgeschlagen als Ernst Moritz Arn zu verkleiden. Also ich habe mir so von der Studententheatergruppe habe ich mir so einen so einen komischen Hut geholt und ein Kostüm und so,
Habe ich mich einfach mit den anderen Leuten zusammen vor die Mensa gestellt. Wir hatten ich habe mir dann so ein so ein Mikrofon geholt und so ein Desk äh so einen Redetisch,
Mikro äh fette Boxen davor und habe dann einfach Ernst Moritz Arndt original vorgelesen,
So und das haben wir dann 30 Minuten gemacht und dann kam die Polizei und hat uns sozusagen wegen äh Volksverhetzung und äh,
Rassismus, Verbreitung im öffentlichen Rassismus ist äh von der Straße gefegt.
All right.
Am nächsten wir hatten natürlich vor der Lokalzeitung schon hatten wir sozusagen die Titelseite, die wir wollten, die brauchten sozusagen, also,
wenn du Ernst Moritz Arndt in der Öffentlichkeit vorliest, bist du, machst du dich strafbar sozusagen. Ne, also.
Also wenn man seine Hochschule vertritt, indem man vorliest, kommt in den Knast. Und hat funktioniert.
Das hat äh es hat erstmal Riesenwelle gemacht und dann haben wir noch noch eine einjährige Kampagne hinten ran gezogen, mit Seit äh mit Prominenten Unterstützern, mit Historikern, mit Veranstaltungen, mit Partys und allem, was man so macht, ne,
Und ähm es hat erstmal dann leider am Ende nicht funktioniert. Zweitausenddrei, wo wir wo ich das damals gemacht hatte, haben wir erstmal gescheitert sozusagen am Ende und der Senat hat das nicht zugestimmt, aber in diesem Jahr.
Also der Senat der Uni.
Genau, der Senat der Universität ist sozusagen das höchste Gremium einer Universität ähm hat das abgelehnt am Ende. Trotzdem äh,
mit ganz prominenter Unterstützung auch. Also es gab zum Beispiel so eloquente Organisationen wie die NPD äh ihr Stahlheim Deutschland,
rechtsnationalen Burschenschaften aus Österreich, die waren auch alle dagegen und eben die Universität Greifswald. Ach so und die CDU Greifswald war auch dagegen, aber,
Naja oder auf jeden Fall ähm nee äh wir haben die Avelle gemacht. Es hat leider nicht funktioniert, aber ähm zum Glück war ich ja nicht die einzige Studentengeneration, die das gestört hat. So hat das dann drei Jahre später kam das nochmal auf und,
Im letzten Jahr kam es dann nochmal auf und es gab wieder eine neue Kampagne und die hatten dann jetzt sozusagen,
ausreichend Unterstützung, sodass jetzt der Name tatsächlich in diesem Jahr abgelegt wurde und glaube ich vor eineinhalb Wochen hat auch das Bildungsministerium die Ablegung des Namens,
quasi ins Amtsblatt geschrieben, womit das jetzt abgeschlossen ist. Universität Greifswald.
Und wann wird das äh wann wird das.
So hieß sie vorher auch, über 500 Jahre lang, bevor die Nazis sie umbenannt haben. Also es ist jetzt nur eine also sozusagen die Adolf Hitlerplätze hat man halt gleich 33 entfernt, aber Ernst Moritz Arndt hat auch ein bisschen länger gedauer.
Vergessen und aber wann kümmert sich man mal um diesen Martin Luther? War das nicht auch so ultrakrasse Antisemit.
Martin Luther es ist ein,
klarer Antisemit das Problem, bei dem ist, dass er nicht gefeiert wurde oder die Namensverleihung war nicht wegen seinem Antisemitismus wie bei Arndt, sondern eben wegen seiner anderen erzeugten, ne, sozusagen da kann man noch eventuell argumentieren, dass ja eben die Namensverleihung nicht unbedingt wegen,
Antisemitismus. Bei Arndt gibt's halt außer Antisemitismus, Rassismus und Volksverhetzung nicht viel anderes. Das ist das Problem. Na gut, er hat ein paar Kirchenlieder geschrieben.
Dann beschäftigen sich aber die Franzosen so viel damit, weil er einfach nur einen Franzosenhasser ist und sonst gar nichts Gutes gebracht hat. Also ich meine also.
Die beschäftigen sich ja mit dem sozusagen mit dem Streit zwischen Deutschland und äh Frankreich, ne? Sozusagen, wie konnte es eigentlich entstehen, dass wir zwei Weltkriege gegeneinander geführt haben,
und dazu das ist halt nicht erklärbar ohne sozusagen Ernst-Moritz Arndt und andere äh die eben diese Hetze betrieben haben, ne.
Sie sehen dann so ein bisschen als Schlüsselfigur auch darin in diesem ja.
Also ähm in und andere Hetzschriften schreibe,
Man muss sich's wirklich einfach irgendwie nahe durchlesen. Das ist halt krass. Wie kann man also,
man heutzutage sowas liest, wie irgendwie äh Menschen jetzt zum Beispiel über Muslime äh aktuell äh,
hetzen, ne? Das kannst du eins zu eins übersetzen äh wie damals äh Abende über die Franzosen gesprochen hat. Also der dann gleichgesetzt mit Ratten und mit irgendwie Ungeziefer und die verseuchen das deutsche Blut und all so einen Krimskrams so, wo du dich fragst so,
Woher kommt sowas, ne? Aber es ist halt und ich glaube noch nicht mal das ahnt, also es gab ein bisschen historischer Hintergrund wegen äh Napoleon, der ja tatsächlich dann ich mache jetzt so ein volles historisches Seminar hier
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, das war schon absurd, ähm aber,
Ja, es sind die Parallelen sind gleichzeitig auch wiederum sichtbar heutzutage, ne? Die die gesellschaftlichen Debatten, die damals geführt wurden, kann man heute äh da gibt's Parallelen auf jeden Fall,
Ich bin extrem froh und ehrlich gesagt, also ich habe so gefeiert, als das
endlich beschlossen wurde, ja, weil es natürlich so ein Ding ist, wofür ich so lange gekämpft habe und ich mit vielen anderen und wir haben da so viel Herzblut investiert, so einen jahrelangen Kampf geführt. Also ich habe einen bestimmten Jahr länger studiert, nur wegen diesem wegen dieser Kampagne, also in dem Jahr habe ich nicht viel anders gemacht,
Es ist äh es ist ein Riesending und ähm ich freue mich natürlich und ähm.
Ab wann heißt sie denn jetzt offiziell so.
Sie heißt so ab äh für Erkundungen im Amtsblatt, also jetzt das ist sozusagen nur, dass jetzt natürlich diese gesamte Umbenennungsprozess jetzt nicht so über Nacht stimmt, die müssen jetzt natürlich die ganzen Schilder ändern.
Aber ich lese hier gerade 19. April, also vor einer Woche ist es bestätigt vom Ministerium, jetzt muss es aber noch veröffentlicht werden und wenn's im Amtsplatz steht, dann ist es sozusagen offiziell.
Sie haben als einen Kompromiss, weil es gab ja eben im Lokal, wie viel wir schon darf man, also Professorinnen und Studenten dürfen den Namen noch nennen, aber der offizielle Name der Universität ist jetzt Universität Karlsfeld.
Hura.
Das heißt, die Wikipedia könnte jetzt auch mal den Artikel umbenennen.
Ja, ist eigentlich eine gute Anlass. Können wir gleich editieren hier, aber ich.
Vielleicht geschieht das auch schon.
Sie sind schon dabei.
Das wäre jetzt mal was.
Wenn die Belege da sind, ne? Genau, es gibt ja hier schon einen Link.
Schon scheinbar ganz gut äh editiert wurden. Hier schon sehr aktuell da die,
Nee, aber das ist einfach, man und es ist eigentlich für jemand, der aus wenn man so in Berlin lebt, dann kann man sich das gar nicht vorstellen, dass eben in so einem,
Halt das Land, ne? Das ist halt wirklich Countryside und in Vorpommern muss man halt wissen, hat halt noch nie jemand die äh Bundestagswahl wurden, außer die CDU,
und äh die NPD kommt halt im gesamten Vorpommern so im im zwischen 15 bis 30 Prozent äh Wahlerfolge und jetzt ist die NPD ersetzt worden durch die AfD. Also,
hat die gleichen Wahlergebnisse sozusagen, aber nur wenn man das weiß, kann man verstehen, dass sozusagen so ein äh so eine Person,
überhaupt streitbar ist für zehn Jahre. Das ist halt,
Wenn du hier du schackkerst mit dem Kopf, wenn du wenn du das in Berlin bist, ne und dann denkst du Gott was machen die da? Ah ja, das Schöne ist, dieses Kapitel Geschichte ist. Also das, wenn ich nichts gemacht habe in meinem Leben, denn das.
Noch ein paar andere Sachen, dem politischen Aktivismus bisher auch äh treu geblieben.
Jein, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mich zurückgehalten die letzten Jahre. Ich bin doch ähm wenn man äh nicht mehr Student ist, dann muss man ja plötzlich Geld verdien,
sagen einem zumindest alle.
Ja, aber ich habe ich habe ja äh noch ein anderes äh Produkt von dir hier schon in einigen Podcast äh
eingespielt und äh regelmäßig wieder abgefeiert. Äh weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mal gesehen habt, diese wirklich
großartige ähm dieses großartige reanacment von äh was äh,
hat Rom jemals für uns getan, aus Leben des Brian so und das ist natürlich auch so eine Vorlage, die schon oft,
ne, jeder hat schon mal so einen entsprechenden Witz, ne, was hat Apple jemals für uns getan? Und so und das äh hast du damals zur Europawahl, vorletzten Europawahl, glaube ich, ne,
irgendwie ziemlichen Aufwand neu gemacht.
Wir hatten halt ähm es war ein Wettbewerb, an dem ich teilgenommen hatte und ähm,
In dem Moment hatte ich dann halt Kohle dafür bekommen, also hatten wir dann halt ein bisschen Geld und konnten richtige Schauspieler einstellen, richtige Location suchen und mit mit richtig viel
drum Bum sozusagen mal so eine richtig schöne Variante davon machen, sozusagen was hat die UE für uns getan, war dann unsere Frage, ne? Und.
Zum Brexit oder wie.
Nee, das war damals die Europawahl einfach. Und unsere Kernidee war irgendwie, dass wir selber nicht wussten, warum man eigentlich,
Wahl machen sollte und irgendwie so über die ganze Tag lang da gesessen gesagt so, was eigentlich gut an Europa, ne.
Was hat die EU uns eigentlich gebracht.
Ja, dürfen wir dann am Ende genau das, wo wir gesagt haben, ja, was hat die EU eigentlich hier für uns getan und wir waren halt selbst nicht überzeugt. Aber dann sozusagen dann, na ja, aber die haben doch dieses, also der Erasmusaustausch ist schon ganz gut,
Ja und diese Umweltprogramme sind auch schon ganz gut und dann saßen wir sozusagen wirklich da und haben genau dieses für uns selber nachgespielt und haben gesagt, dann können wir.
Äh das wollte ich eigentlich wieso ich habe doch hier ein scheiß Autoplay aus. Wieso wird das nicht berücksichtigt, wenn ich das nicht will? Frechheit. Äh mach mal deinen Satz zu Ende, dann nehme uns das nochmal kurz an.
Also genau, das ist ähm wir haben einfach das durchgespielt und dann irgendwann äh saß sie auf Toilette abends zu Hause kennt ihr und dann war die Idee so, ja jetzt das das ist doch genau diese Szene eigentlich, was wir heute gemacht haben und dann habe ich gesagt, das könnte man doch einfach mal machen,
und ist dann eben auch entsprechend gut gelaufen kann.
Was sind denn das für Leute, mit denen du's gemacht hast? Sind das richtig gute Schauspieler oder.
Sind richtig professionelle Schauspieler. Ich habe ein richtiges Casting auch veranstaltet. Also dafür, wir hatten ja auch ein Castingstudio dafür uns geholt. Also ich hatte Geld in dem Fall mal, also
durch den Wettbewerb warten wir bisschen Kohle bekommen und dann konnten wir richtig Schauspieler holen und so ein paar Laienschauspieler sind auch dabei, also die die du hier vorne sitzen sind echte Schauspieler, die die hinten sitzen, sind sozusagen meine Kollegen gewesen und Kolleginnen aus meiner Agentur, wo ich damals.
Ich glaube, die Frau links kenne ich auch irgendwo her, aber.
Ja, die ist, glaube ich, die hat einen ganz guten Auftrag, irgendwas bei RTL hat die dann.
Dann kenne ich sie doch nicht.
Er ist eine deutsche Schauspielerin, was willst du,
Kopf nicht nach Hollywood.
Kurz anspielen.
Grandios.
Ja, das Vorbild ist grandios, ne? Das.
Hätte man jemals in England mal machen sollen.
Gemacht? Mit.
Das hat wer war das gemacht? Genau, der hat das äh.
War wohl nicht so gut.
So geile Variante, muss ich sagen. Die haben das noch mehr abgeändert und zwar noch mehr vom Original weg, also nicht.
Ja. Ja und dann ging's tief mit dem,
PK ist schuld.
Auf Platz zwei, sage ich mal. Na ja.
Es war witzig, hat mich jemand damit angeschrieben, hey, die haben dein Sketch geklaut, ich so,
das kann jeder andere, die kennen doch mein Sketch nicht. Also als ob dir das von mir geklaut hätten. War nicht gut, ja.
Auch nicht schlecht. Aber interessant ist es auf Leute auch dann noch interessant wirkt, wenn sie eigentlich das Original gar nicht kennen, ne? So episch. Na ja gut,
Und jetzt machst du Inseo.
So und hier geht mal Beliebtheit.
War das grad ein Tiefschlag.
Nee, er hat im Moment nicht Social Media Manager gesagt. Das ist so das Schlimmere, was man sagen kann oder.
Du denn selber über dich.
Kommunikations- und Politikberater. Also das ist so manchmal sage ich auch einfach so Schmiedeberater können die Leute mit anfangen.
Was hast du gesagt? Du meinst,
SEO, was ist dein Essen.
Er macht in SEO. Ach Dennis, du bist so süß.
Engine Optimization. Ja das,
Das ist das finde ich echt schön.
Mal ehrlich, wisst ihr was? SEO ist? Ja. Ja.
Weil ich diese Webkacke halt mache.
Ja
Das finde ich echt schön, weil ich habe.
Falsch, Jungs. Also der Fehler ist ja nicht bei mir, sondern bei euch.
Ich keine Ahnung habe und dass dass du jetzt mal was nicht weißt, das fände ich sehr beruhigend.
Das ist geil. Das ehrt dich auch irgendwie. Also.
Ich hoffe. Bei euch nicht.
Search Enginet Optimization heißt das.
Ich habe das vor 20 Jahren mal mit dem Vater von einem Kumpel gemacht, der wollte seine seine Suchergebnisse auch optimiert haben, aber.
Vor 20 Jahren. Vor Google.
Oder na ist schon.
Also jetzt kommt's raus.
Lange her. Also.
Eigentlich hat Google bei Dennis geklaut.
Jeden Fall vor zwei.
Genau, die haben Ärzte, erste.
Dennis hat zuerst erfunden.
Dennis war das schon out, also wie alle anderen das aufgenommen haben. Das ist gut. Vielleicht hätte ich mit Podcast jetzt aufhören. Jetzt so aufgenommen wird. Meine das war ja kein Angriff. Ich meine.
Vielleicht noch mal zu meiner Verteidigung, also ich mache nicht dieses nee doch schon. Das ist auch okay, ist auch okay.
Doch schon. Aber ich dachte, du bist keiner. SEO.
SEO mache ich tatsächlich ganz wenig, ich muss die Grundkenntnisse haben, also du musst sozusagen,
Nee, du musst halt irgendjemand sagt, ich werde nicht gefunden oder ich habe zu wenig Likes, ich habe zu wenig Klicks, ich möchte, dass meine politische Meinung bekannt wird. Das ist das Hauptziel, ja? Egal ob NGOs, äh Parteien, Regierung, äh,
Behörden. Das sind so diese ganzen und die sagen irgendwie, ich habe eine Agenda und die möchte ich in die Öffentlichkeit bringen und dazu gehört,
SEO, SEM, äh Social Media, äh.
Und SEM kennt ihr auch alle.
Da bin ich jetzt raus.
Ich bin auch raus.
Search Marketing äh Somesingen. Also das da geht's um das Einkauf.
Aber nicht SM, das ist.
Ja
SM heißt das.
Um die ähm Suchmarketing sozusagen, also einfach das Einkaufen von kurz gesagt. Ähm und das Optimisieren.
Muss jetzt mal grätschen, du kennst das ja aus der letzten Sendung. Benutz, benutzt du AdBlocker? Ja. Okay. Das war's schon.
Ich bin auch äh ich bin der große Feind sowieso von Werbung auch äh ich ich finde das gar nicht gut. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass Werbung äh ein gutes Mittel ist, um unbedingt um,
politische Agenda rüberzubringen, ne. Aber was ich sagen wollte ist, also ich bin deshalb nicht so gerne Social-Media-Heine genannt werden, weil das immer so eine sehr stark verkleidet. Was ich eigentlich mache, ist sozusagen insgesamt politische Kommunikation und ich helfe Menschen, die eine politische Agenda haben, diese umzusetzen,
Egal ob das sozusagen aus dem NGO-Bereich ist oder eben aus der politischen Behörden.
Das mit der Uni schon gemacht hast eigentlich.
Genau und das ist so mein Verkaufsding, das ich halt unter anderem sage aber es ist wohl auch tatsächlich so, dass ich eben so ein Händchen habe dafür, Geschichten zu mir auszudenken,
die du erzählen kannst, um eine bestimmte, komplexe Materie sichtbar zu machen und fühlbar zu machen, weil das ist ja das Problem, was wir auch in der Netzpolitik immer haben, wenn wenn wir unsere Themen sagen, dass wir irgendwie über über Wörter Begriffe äh diskutieren, die die,
achtzig, 90 Prozent der Welt da draußen nicht versteht und du musst das halt runterbrechen, so dass die Menschen das verstehen können. Datenautobahn ist ja dieses berühmtbrüchtigte
Unwort, ja? Äh aber das macht halt, das können die Leute verstehen, ähm sozusagen äh Glasfaser, da wissen sie nicht, wo ist der Vorteil von glasfaser gegenüber Kupfer ist doch beides schönes Material, ja,
so und diese Kampf und Begriffe, Deutungshoheit, das so das ist mein mein Arbeitsfeld.
Also ein bisschen äh erinnert mich das, weil ich habe ja Madman geguckt. Das ist dann so deine Ecke.
Madman, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, weil da geht's doch um eine.
Sollen ja auch so Werbestrategen, die sich halt die Geschichte ausdenken und versuchen, wie sie das so erzählen, dass es halt.
Zukunft im, wo die ganze Zivilisation ah ach so Mad Man, Entschuldigung, ich habe das gerade mit dem anderen.
Nee, nee, nicht, nicht, nicht Mad Max, Madman, die Madison Avenu.
Mad Max. Ich dachte so, weißt du? Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich versuch's natürlich trotzdem nicht so also ich versuche sozusagen den die Moral nicht zu verlieren, ne, also nicht.
Ja, das war ja aus den 60ern, da war alles noch ein bisschen anders anscheinend.
Na ja, ehrlich gesagt, so es gibt sozusagen es gibt, du kannst immer auch fies sein und nett sein, es gibt heute immer noch, also du kannst ja auch immer noch korrupt sein, wenn du politische Kommunikation machst oder oder skrupellos, sagen wir's mal so, ne,
Ja, das mache ich so. Das ist mein Ding, aber das ist meine Berufswelt sozusagen.
Auch super. Ähm,
Ja wir haben ganz viele Themen. Ich weiß bloß nicht genau äh wir hatten jetzt keine Zeit. Ähm die gut vorzusortieren. Nicht, dass wir das jemals tun würden und so, aber.
Na so ein bisschen haben wir ja schon sortiert. Wenn wir mal über nicht Apple reden und dann über Apple und das war's halt mit der Sortierung.
Sucht euch mal was. Sucht euch sucht euch mal was aus. Ich lehne mich mal zurück.
Ich kann kurz ein Auto Update geben, aber es ist eigentlich kein Update. Das Auto ist bei irgendeinem Versender auf irgendeinem Laster. Den habe ich.
Das klingt sehr unseriö.
Wird er vom Laster fallen und auch der Espresso ist verloren gegangen.
Auch in so einem
gelesen, da war das Elektroauto meinte der Redakteur oder der der ähm ähm Autor des Artikels. Das ist das einzige Auto gewesen wäre, was halt nicht vorgefahren wurde, sondern aufm LKW vortransportiert wurde und nicht also hingefahren wurde.
Näheres Auto ist es hat halt keine Nummernschilder. Das kannst du jetzt mal eben schlecht.
Gelbe Kennzeichen, also sagen, du weißt das schon, ne.
Ja ja ähm na ja auf jeden Fall hat ja letzte Woche Dienstag das Ding abgeholt beim Händler und ich habe ihn am Freitag angerufen, was denn nur ist und der war mal so richtig grumpy,
am Telefon und meinte ja Mittwoch oder Donnerstag. Das wäre dann morgen? Na schauen wir mal was passiert,
Weiß gar nicht, ob ich den morgen nochmal anrufe, aber der war wirklich sehr grumpy.
Erklären.
Ich würde dann vorher einfach kurz das Amazon-Thema machen, weil nicht, dass ich das vergesse und ich finde das schade. Ähm und zwar,
Ein Artikel wurde von meiner Wunschliste, sollte an mich versendet werden, allerdings ist der nie bei mir angekommen und ich habe halt schon versucht über Amazon da irgendwie,
Hinweise zu bekommen, aber,
Die verweisen mich natürlich darauf, dass sie nicht sagen können ähm von wem das zum Beispiel gekommen ist oder ob's versendet wurde. Also wenn ich mich mal nicht bei jemanden bedankt habe und ihr habt mir was gesendet, was nicht also ja,
Nicht angekommen ist. Ähm also es wäre cool, wenn ihr euch irgendwie bei mir meldet, weil ich finde das doof, wenn ihr mir schon Sachen schenken wollt und sie kommen dann irgendwie nicht an, weil Amazon zu doof.
Sag doch einfach mal genau, was nicht ankam, damit derjenige sich jetzt besser raushört.
Also eine,
Flasche wurde mir, sollte mir geschickt werden und die ist bei mir nie angekommen. Liebe Hörer, ich will, dass ich, ich will wenigstens Danke sagen können dafür, dass du mir was schenken möchtest. Ähm und finde das halt ziemlich kacke von Amazon, dass man irgendwie,
nicht sagen kann, hallo, mir wollte jemand etwas schenken und es ist bei mir nie angekommen, dass da kein Use Case gibt.
Ja warum man nicht Mehl bekommt, die das sozusagen ankündigt, weil ich meine.
Also manchmal bekommt man das ja auch und manchmal halt eben nicht doch, ich habe einige Male schon extra von DHL.
Ja von der Eltern, aber nicht von Amazon.
Auch von Amazon habe ich, glaube ich, auch schon mal eine bekommen, wenn sie was versendet wurde.
Nee, das Feature gibt's nicht.
Und die Amazon-Fahrer selbst, glaube ich, sind ziemlich faul. Das sind die Typen, die wirklich auf dem Briefkasten oder das vor die Tür legen, ohne dass sie.
Ganz vorsichtig, ganz dünnes Eis.
Nee, bei mir nicht. Also bei mir sind das wirklich nur die, die das machen. Die anderen klingeln und oder geben das beim Nachbarn ab.
Hat da so sein anderes Target. Am Ende sind das alles irgendwelche voll ausgebeuteten Subunternehmer, die zu irgendwie na ja gut.
Mag ja sein, aber ich habe die Erfahrung immer nur mit den mit den Amazon Direktlieferungen, wo das so ist.
Nicht die Fahrer und man sieht das Problem, sondern das System, was diese Fahrer betreibt, ist das Problem.
Das ist mir egal, dass die alle ausgebeutet werden, das ist eh so.
Ach so, ne, machst du's ja einfach.
Wer wird da nicht ausgebeutet heutzutage.
Ich würde ja am liebsten gar nichts mehr bei Amazon kaufen, muss ich da mal ehrlich sagen, weil mich das,
dermaßen ankotzt, also egal wie das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt.
Löschen Letti? Ja.
Ich arbeite da bei so einer Firma.
Die hat auch eine Wunschli.
Wo du wo du inzwischen, wenn wenn du dir was von Amazon schicken lässt so ans Post-Office, dann kleben die da einen Aufkleber drauf, äh ach hast du eigentlich schon mal bei eBay geguckt, ob's das auch bei eBay gibt,
Noch eine Mail und darfst dann so ein dann begründen, warum.
Beim Chef vorher vorsprechen war, ob's jetzt wirklich keine Alternativen.
Ja, hast du schon mal hast du schon mal Bestellprozesse bei eBay abge? Also das ist ja ich meine das man kann natürlich auf Amazon jetzt viel äh rum äh äh hacken. Allerdings finde ich, dass sie nach wie vor,
Da sind, wo sie sind, weil sie besser sind als alle anderen.
Ja, aber sie sind schon schlechter geworden. Also du hast immer wieder das Problem, dass sie dir nicht schreiben, wo derjenige sitzt, der das verschickt,
und plötzlich kriegst du was mit vier Wochen äh Lieferzeit aus aus China geschickt, was dann irgendwo beim Zoll hängen bleibt.
Das ist in der Tat.
Oder du kaufst das und du erkennst nicht, dass es nicht ein richtiger Händler ist, sondern privat verkaufen, dann schreibst du, du brauchst eine Rechnung und sagst dann, nee, ist ja ein Privatverkauf und da gibt's keine Rechnung, was auch nicht stimmt. Also es ist so ein bisschen der also der hat,
Amazon hat auch seine Shady Ecken, wo die sich nicht so richtig kümmern.
Also vor allen Dingen finde ich das halt irgendwie.
Das will ich ja gar nicht beschreiben, aber entschuldigen die die gesamte das Gesamtpaket Amazon,
Ist einfach sehr solide bei bei eBay was suchst, dann tauchst du dich halt automatisch durch. Also es ist ja überhaupt nicht klar, was da neu ist und was da gebraucht ist und was.
Aber das verwischt bei Amazon auch gerade so ein bisschen, finde ich.
Gebraucht wird da nichts verkauft.
Neu oder gebraucht musst du aber.
Ja aber das muss auch explizit anklicken.
Kann man nicht so also du musst schon sehr genau hingucken, damit du das siehst. Das ist nicht mehr so einfach wie früher, dass du bestellst und dann ist das schon neu.
Nicht automatisch auf so einem Gebrauchteam ist auf der Artikelbeschreibung muss dann aber.
Ja, wenn's dir eine neue gibt, wenn's ihn aber nur noch in Gebrauch gibt in Gebrauch, dann landest du direkt bei dem Gebrauch und erkennst du das nicht sofort. Ja.
Ja, echt? Okay.
Beitragen, dass sozusagen einer der schönen Vorteile, wenn man sich mal so ein eigenes Büro holt in so einer kennst du solche Büro-Wegies? Das ist so.
So eine Bürogemeinschaft, wo man sich so einen ja.
Ist nicht so ein Coworking, das ist mir so ein.
Wohnung, wo nee, ach so.
Die die die vermieten so äh so tatsächlich sogar ein weltweites Unternehmen irgendwie in 2000 Städten aktiv und so und die haben halt überall so Büros und du kannst hier so eine Art,
mietest dir ein Zimmer in diesem und da hast dann geteilte Küche, geteilte Empfang, geteilten Postempfang und das Tolle an dem ist nämlich also seitdem habe ich nie wieder Probleme. Ich konnte die sind ja immer voll.
Dahin liefern lässt.
Genau, das ist in.
Ist in der Tat super.
Halt das Schönste, also wenn du ihr wenn ihr Geschäftsadressen habt oder irgendwo in der Firma arbeitet, lasst es einfach da hinschicken. Weil das ist, dann habt ihr mich rund um die Uhr seid ihr da und dann.
Ja gut, aber das das Problem, finde ich, ist derzeit auch ganz gut gelöst worden, weil ich kann ja jetzt muss man jetzt überlegen, ob das jetzt nur ein Feature von Amazon Business ist oder auch dem normalen Amazon. Weiß nicht, ob jetzt auch noch diesen Business-Account und da merke ich jetzt aber nicht so schnell, ob irgendwas
Feature ist oder so aber ich kann jetzt quasi als Lieferadresse ja auch direkt so ein Paketstation.
Kannst du auch als Privat.
Nicht nur den Locker, sondern hier auch so diese ganzen Reinigungsdienste und sonstigen Büchereien und alle, die sozusagen,
sind und da gibt's echt, echt viel und da ist auch genug hier in meiner äh Spuckweite. Und das ist für mich vollkommen ausreichend.
Das finde ich halt auch, aber was ich halt echt
äh schade finden ist, wenn sie schon dieses Feature haben mit du hast eine öffentliche Wunschliste und du kannst dann quasi nicht mal zurückverfolgen, wenn dir was nicht geschickt wurde oder etwas nicht bei dir angekommen ist, dass du nicht pinnen kannst, dass hey Amazon,
Hier ist was nicht angekommen, ähm was von meiner Wunschliste grad offensichtlich runter ist.
Es sollte einem einfach auch angezeigt werden können, was einem gesendet wurde über diese Wünsche, weil das wissen sie ja.
Genau, also man kann sich anzeigen lassen, was gekauft wurde und das eben nicht. Und weil das finde ich halt so ein bisschen unfair na ja ich weiß nicht, also.
Ohne Not irgendwie. Aber ich meine, Sie haben die Daten den den äh da einzukippen dürfte jetzt nicht sonderlich schwer fallen.
Das sind ja alles, letztlich sind das ja genau sozusagen so Übergangsschmerzen, die wir erleben in dieser Zeit von sozusagen Gewohnheit und stationären Handel hin zu dem sozusagen, wo fast alles in der Zukunft,
versendet wird,
Das ist halt, ne, dieses ganze Online-Versandhandel trifft auf sozusagen,
nicht gewachsene Strukturen auf der anderen Seite. So und und,
auch noch fünf Jahre schmerzhaft sein und da werden Probleme und irgendwann wird es so sein, dass jeder so eine,
intelligente Box zu Hause stehen hat und dann kommt irgendwann Delivery Bot und schiebt dir das in deine eigene Box rein und du kannst es einfach aus der Box rausnehmen. Also ich,
relativ optimistisch, aber man muss die nächsten fünf Jahre einfach irgendwie sich eine Lösung finden, mit der man dann überlebt.
Ich fänd's auch irgendwie voll cool einfach gar nicht mehr so diese Paketzustellung zu Hause als Standard zu haben, sondern wirklich eben, sei es jetzt irgendwo einen eine Box, die irgendwo ist, wo man sich's einfach hinliefert oder einen einen äh ja Unternehmen, was ihr hier auf der Straße
zum Beispiel sitzt, sondern man sagt von vornherein, nee, schickt's einfach nur dahin.
Sogar noch noch weiter geht die Zukunft, dass äh dass du quasi so eine Art ähm,
Israelisches Startup macht das gerade die die stellen so Boxen auf in Straßen mit denen äh irgendwie 2000 Items die am meisten bestellt werden auf Amazon und anderen Plattformen.
Also vorgefüllt werden.
Die sind sozusagen vorgefüllt und du bestellst quasi online und dann kriegst du nur noch so ein Code zugeschickt und und nimmst du sie aus der Box raus. Ich habe gerade vor kurzem mir dieses schöne neue Schul iPad gekauft mit Stift. Ähm und das habe ich äh,
Das habe ich bei eBay tatsächlich gekauft mit Pickup im Saturn und dann kriegst du einfach nur noch so einen Code zugeschickt und bin ich zum auf dem Weg nach Hause beim Saturn vorbeigefahren und dann nimmst du dir das einfach so mit,
Es ging echt fix und es ist besser als jeder Versand. Also ich glaube, das wird sozusagen äh auch nochmal eine Lösung sein, dass du äh insgesamt den Versand vermeidest und einfach so Pickupboxen hast in jeder Straße.
Gab's da nicht auch mal so ein so ein Modell mit Auto- und Kofferraum und.
Ist wiederum, dass das nicht das ist nicht das skaliert nicht, wie man das so schön sagt. Ja.
Für Leute, wo die ihr Auto vor ihrem Haus stehen haben. Das ist hier in der Stadt und macht das ja keinen Sinn, wo du dann den Wagen suchen musst. Das ist da, wo der wo der Wagen halt in der äh vorm Haus ähm in der Einfahrt steht. Da lohnt sich das.
Aber äh die äh für die Städte lohnt sich das deshalb nicht, weil die Autos immer irgendwo anders stehen und die Ortungsdienste, Ordnungsdienste in den Autos sind nicht scharf genug. Dass der Postbote schnell genug dein Auto findet und deswegen hat DHL dieses Testexperiment auch schön eingestellt.
Macht ja der Stadt auch keinen Sinn, weil der will ja
pro Hausnummer das Abarbeiten eigentlich und dann fängt er an hin und her zu laufen, um die Autos zu suchen. Da müsste er sich ja erst vorher gucken, wo die Autos sind, damit er sich eine eine Liste machen kann und dann parkt einer um und dann stimmt wieder alles nicht. Das geht nur, wenn das Auto in der Auffahrt steht, sonst geht das nicht
Das Auto muss da sein, wo die Hausnummer ist. Aber es gab zwar auch schon die Ideen, dass sie hier so eine,
Kiste irgendwie an die Tür hängen, indem sie was durch den Briefkastenschlitz stecken, was denn verriegelt, dass man die Kiste noch nicht mehr entfernen kann, aber das ist doch auch gescheitert, oder? Und dann die Geschichte, dass sie sogar Zugang zu deiner Wohnung bekommen.
Das wiederum macht Amazon hier, indem sie diese ähm Schlüsselstartup und die Kamera-Startup gekauf.
Genau, aber das das will doch niemand, oder? Ja.
Doch, das wird auch passieren, klar.
Ich kann das ja nicht nachvollziehen, aber gut, die Leute machen ja auf Facebook.
Und übrigens in den USA,
Ja. Da sage ich jetzt nix zu. In den USA.
Ja ich weiß, wir kommen da ja noch hin.
Weiß ich nicht. Äh aber äh in den USA ist es ja so, dass die das einfach vor die Haustür legen. Es war ja äh bei meiner Exfreundin, die.
Bei Häusern oder auch in Mietswohnungen.
Nee, ganz krass, also bei Hortern aber nicht so nur auf dem Lande, wo man jetzt denkt irgendwie, sondern wirklich so in den Städten,
wo wirklich so Reihenhäuser sind, ja. Und die legen das einfach auf die Porsche,
Gehst du die Straße lang oder liegt überall drei Pakete vor die Tür und ich denke so.
Also nicht mehr vor der Wohnungstür, sondern vor der Haustür.
Vor der also vor der Haustür.
Das müsste in Berlin ja mal machen. Ja, ja. Da. Da brauche ich ja nicht mehr arbeiten gehen. Da gehst du nur noch mitm Einkaufswagen die.
Das machen die ja nur so auch. Das ist äh beliebtes Problem.
Ja aber wie wie also.
Es gibt ja keinen, ich seien hier irgendwie Unterschrift und so weiter, die legen das einfach vor die Tür ab. Das ist so wie früher die Zeitung, ne.
Das ist das Land, das verschickt Shakes, wenn sie was überweise,
mit der Post.
Und das funktioniert und macht nicht viel Ärger und aber wer wer bezahlt das, wenn das dann weg ist? Der Empfänger oder der Absender.
Verbraucherschutz, USA. Ist halt.
Na ja komm, also wenn bei denen du nur einer irgendwie was im Essen hat, dann ist da gleich ein paar Millionen reicher. Also ich meine.
Die einzige Ausnahme, aber es ist halt auch das einzige, wie's geht und wenn irgendwas so richtig tausende von Leuten völlig irgendwie gegen Strich geht, dann haben sie die große Keule so, aber so im Einzelfall stehst du erstmal blöde da. Dass bei uns halt.
Ja. Wollen die jetzt ja in Europa auch einen von den Class-Action, ne? Da gibt's irgendwie Bestrebungen.
Sicher, dass die große Koalition daran scheitern wird an diesem Plan, aber warten wir mal ab.
Sogar von der EU eingeführt, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, war mir auch so.
Stimmt richtig oder hast Recht? Das ist eine EU äh genau, das könnte sogar vielleicht äh funktionieren. Die Frage ist nur, ist es eine Richtlinie oder eine Verordnung.
Das wird wohl eine Verordnung werden.
Ja? Na dann kommt's.
Also ich meine aber ne, die die die Wasser sind langsam in der EU, aber die der Plan steht.
Mühlen sind langsam heißt das.
Es wurde angekündigt, sagen wir's mal.
Noch für diese Legislatur? Weil das wäre ja dann bald.
Das weiß ich wiederum nicht. Nee, das weiß ich nicht. Das.
Ja okay äh wie auch immer, aber du hast mich grad dran erinnert, ich habe wusste das eigentlich auch schon, aber ich hab's verdrängt. Na ja, mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Jetzt sind wir aber durch mit dem Thema. Also ich wollte eigentlich nicht so ein Fass auf.
Ist das ja immer. Du kannst nicht einfach Amazon sagen und dann denken, das ist schnell erledigt. Das das so geht das nicht. Thema. Na.
Noch was Abseitiges machen.
Was was abseitiges.
Thema Bier,
habe äh wann war das letztes, vorletztes Wochenende? Habe ich mal ähm also ich habe bei irgendwann mal angefangen äh meine Rezepte,
zu posten und habe jetzt vorletztes Wochenende einfach mal alles, was ich bisher gebraut habe, die Rezepte da zusammenzusammeln, gut eins nee, fehlt eins.
O2 sind das.
Ähm nein, wenn du da unten guckst,
Das ist einfach nur dieser Texter und jeder von den Links blau Link.
Ist ein weiteres Marktdorn-Feil in dem Reposatory.
Nee, nicht alle sind ein Markteinfall. Es sind nur.
PDFs irgendwo, also hast nicht alles in Gitthab.
Nein, ich habe,
Nein, aber ich habe hier dieses eine Dokument, wo halt alles verlinkt ist. Nur die beiden letzten, weil die beiden letzten äh nein, die drei letzten äh Rezepte, die habe ich tatsächlich selber gemacht und deswegen äh gibt's die halt dann.
Achso, verstehen. Die anderen sind sozusagen nur von dir durchgeführt worden, aber nicht von dir.
Genau, deswegen habe ich die nur verlinkt. Ähm ja.
Dann kann ich ja nochmal eingrätschen, wenn wir schon bei sind. Ich nutze ja Git Up echt auch echt für alles gerade, um mir Notizen zu machen,
Dieses System und alles schön Versionskontrolle und allen die weißes, also jedenfalls wenn's um um Rechner geht oder so am Telefon muss ich jetzt nicht irgendwie meine Vorlesungen vorbereiten, aber das ist echt.
Was benutzt du denn von dem Gitab? Also könntest du das eigentlich auch mit einem lokalen Git klein machen oder schiebst du das wirklich alles hoch und brauchst das dann auch sozusagen von dort.
Greifen wir schon so vielleicht aufs nächste Thema mit dem Erklären vor, aber ich halte dieses Jahr wieder eine Vorlesung und ich habe auch letztes Jahr meine gesamte Vorlesung über GitHub verwaltet. Und vor allem, weil ich eine faule Socke bin und PDFs wirklich zum Kotzen finde als Präsentationsformat,
habe ich einfach äh Gitter Flavour. Also ich habe keine Folien mehr, wenn ich präsentiere, sondern guck mal hier, hier ist mein Pository, da ist das angezeigt. Sieht gut aus. Reicht für das, was ich mache,
Das ist halt wirklich eine eine sehr gute Erleichterung. Ähm also sei das jetzt für irgendwelche Talks, die ich vorbereite, dass ich mir,
mittlerweile auch mal endlich so ein bisschen die Scheu vor etwas öffentlichstellen verloren habe und mir wirklich meine Outlines da einfach reinhacke und sage okay, ich muss jetzt meine Vorlesungen vorbereiten, das heißt, ich mache einen Marktpfeil, haue das in meine Talks irgendwie rein,
und,
schreib erstmal einfach runter und das ist mir dann auch egal, ob da irgendwelche Taibus drin sind, wo ich vorher halt wirklich so sage, eher so der Meinung war so, ah nee, lieber nicht hochladen, weil dann sieht ja jeder, was ich mache und alle finden, dass es irgendwie doof ist, so nach dem Motto
Und äh diese Angst habe ich jetzt mal so langsam überwunden,
Habe irgendwie zum Teil eben meine Talks beziehungsweise Vorlesungen ähm komplett jetzt im Markt drin äh und vor allen Dingen in GitHub,
und auch so meine Death Notes, also weiß ich nicht, als ich jetzt erzählt hatte, dass ich so viel Serverkram grad mache und Administrieren ist es halt auch ein guter Weg, so seine,
Notizen darüber mit reinzuwerfen. Das ist schon echt äh.
Heißt das deine äh Notizen sind public.
Public aber natürlich hoffe ich jetzt ohne dass ich jetzt irgendwo mein Passwörter reingeschmissen habe oder die die konkreten URLs zu meinen äh Servern. Das habe ich eigentlich versucht wirklich immer genau rauszunehmen, wenn ich das dadrin gemacht habe.
Dann verlinke das mal.
Macht dir nichts draus, du wärst nicht der Erste, die da äh.
War auch in der Tat meine größte Sorge. Aber ich glaube in meinen dessen in der Dort nix drin, was äh ich gucke nochmal.
Ich gucke noch mal.
Äh ja.
Sind auch die Passwörter drin, also das ist äh.
Gut, dass dein Account nicht auf unserer Seite verlinkt.
Nee, nee, also das fändt ja niemand, also wer wer die Letti auf Gitter findet, das wäre ja wirklich, also überhaupt. Nee, in der Tat nicht, so gut.
Das streift ein äh Problem, was ich auch gerade habe, nämlich dass ich mal wieder, ich will ein White Paper schreiben, denn ich muss einen White Paper schreiben. Ist ja eigentlich das einzige, was ich gerne schreibe,
Ähm und dann frage ich mich mal als erstes,
Wie schreibe ich ein White Paper? Weil man will ja eigentlich genauso eine Gig-Transparenz mit Versionskontrolle bla, bla, bla, Historie und so weiter und kollaborativ will man ja haben,
nur was für ein Format.
Ja, aber das ist so. Genau.
Ist kein Format. Markdown ist ein stinkendes Stück Scheiße von Leuten, die keine Ahnung haben.
Nicht, ist es nicht.
Dokumente funktionieren, geh mir mit Markdown aus der Sonne. Ich brauche was, was Inhaltsverzeichnisse generiert
was man irgendwie problemlos äh in schick formatieren kann und ich will nicht dieses dieses kranke Geächte aus irgendeiner verschrobenen Bloggerecke das ist noch nicht mal in der Lage ist, irgendwie Listen richtig zu machen,
Nein, kann es nicht. Es ist einfach.
Listen, es kann Inhaltsverzeichnis.
Nicht, es tut, nein, es sagt, es glaubt, das zu können oder es behauptet das und dann schreibst du Listen und es ist alles kaputt,
schreibst du irgendwie fünf Punkt in deine Liste am Anfang, dann hast du in dem einen Rennerer das Ergebnis, in dem anderen das Ergebnis in dem Einschnitt eine Fünf, in dem anderen steht eine eins, der einen steht auch in den anderen dann eine Eins, der andere zählt durch
Einfach weg. Markdown ist keine Textverarbeitung. Markdown ist keine Dokumentenverarbeitung.
Sobald es darum geht, dass du etwas layouten musst und ich habe jetzt halt auch grad.
Nur Layouten, auch Struktur zu haben, so überhaupt mal so die Level richtig nicht H1, H zwei, H drei, H vier.
Genau, ich finde halt auch Latech ist so mein Standard, aber zum Beispiel musste ich jetzt einen Bericht schreiben, Zwischenbericht für fürs Forschungsprojekt. Und dann willst du halt eigentlich auch
Deckblatt einfach nur haben, wo dein Logo drauf ist und darunter kannst, ich sage mal, ein bissel geraffelter Text sein,
Aber ich weiß, wie groß die war irgendwie meine Masterarbeit des Deckplatz zu gestalten in Latech und wenn du da einmal wieder raus bist, brauchst du Ewigkeiten, bist du wieder drin.
Weil der Unterschied zwischen ich nutze so ein äh fertiges Template und ich baue ein Template, der ist extrem
Es ist nicht einfach zu konfigurieren und von daher handelt es sich ja eigentlich um zwei Systeme. Da sind so User und Designer von Templates. Ich meine ist nicht so, dass irgendwie Webseiten hast mit das geile, neue Latte ich Template und guck mal jetzt hier mit dem Modern Style und Look und
weiter und leicht anpassen und Pipapo, was vielleicht so ein Indikator wäre dafür, dass es einfach ist nein. Ja, du hast wahrscheinlich nur drei verschiedene Templates jemals auf diesem Planeten gehabt
und von denen hat dann jede Uni irgendwie eine Variante gemacht, wo zwei, drei Sachen und ein paar Zahlenabstände geändert worden sind und das ist alles.
Findet auch, das ist mir jetzt wieder aufgefallen, als wir beim Easterhack waren, gibt's immer Einführungen im Markt, auch in in Latech, schön und gut, aber so was zu finden, wie,
machst du dein ganzes Layout? Wie machst du, dass es schön ist? Wie machst du, dass es vielleicht auch na Corporat Identity ist, jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit gegriffen, aber einfach mal Richtung, du hast,
dein Layout, was für dich passt, wo du sagst, hast ist schön, gefällt dir, nehme ich jetzt für alles, veröffentlich das dann auch auf Gitarre von mir, aber wie strukturiere ich eigentlich mein Markdown Template so, dass es geil wird.
Ja und vor allem ich möchte halt, dass das Dokument, dass da auch ein ordentliches Dokument bei rauskommt, was man wie ein Online-Help-System äh mal eben in HTML überführen kann, was natürlich auch gedruckt ordentlich aussieht
was quasi wir auch eine Datenbank
benutzt werden kann, indem halt viele Informationen auch entsprechende Meta-Informationen oder das äh sozusagen auch in dem Text sagen kannst du hier ist ein Exampel und hier äh ist ein
Bild und dass du auch verschiedene Names innerhalb deines Dokumentes äh pflegen kannst, um verschiedene Nummerationsläufe äh zu haben, ne? Diagramm eins, Diagramm zwei, et cetera, solche Sachen
so und da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch gar keine Antwort. Ich stehe immer wieder vor diesem selben Problem, dass ich eigentlich gerne halt,
Natürlich am liebsten würde ich den Komfort einer richtigen, ordentlichen Textverarbeitung haben. So und ich hatte ja neulich mal erzählt, dass ich mir Melle mal äh geshoppt und näher angeschaut habe,
Zwischenstand ist so ja.
Nee.
Es ist es ist es ist es ist schon recht gut so,
aber es hat noch nicht so diesen also manche Sachen sind noch zu kompliziert und zu zu Orket. Kann aber da wirklich eine ganze Menge,
kein schlechtes, ist kein schlechtes Produkt, aber ich suche ja jetzt explizit etwas, was ist sozusagen, also etwas so ein so ein so ein offenes Format, ne. Und dann kommen natürlich dann alle gleich mit,
und so äh auch so Klassiker, die äh natürlich extrem komplex sind, ne. Schau dir mal irgendwie die,
Dokumentation zu Docbook, der weiß halt auch nicht mehr, wo oben und unten ist.
Na ja, ich glaube, wenn wenn du mit Kitt anfangen willst, dann brauchst du aber auch ein Format, was halt ein reines Textformat ist und aus dem du dann etwas generierst. Und da ist halt,
Genau und da ist zwischen Latech und Magda und ist halt nicht viel,
Ne, also mir fällt jetzt kein Programm ein, dessen Dokumente ich guten Gewissens äh in einen Kit reinwerfen würde, ohne dass das echt zur Hölle wird,
Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit Merell ist, aber wahrscheinlich kannst du da auch nicht die Dokumente in den Kit reinwerfen und diffen und.
Nee, eben nicht. So, das ist ja genau das Problem und ich suche halt irgendwas, was man äh in einem ordentlichen, aber trotzdem kappablen äh Format machen kann. Hier wird jetzt noch von Simplyfied Docbook gesprochen
dass äh wir sie nicht ähm aber ist das nicht alles XML dann irgendwie,
Meine nicht, dass ich äh keine Affinität für äh XML hätte, aber.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Man kann nicht in XML einen Textdokument schreiben.
XML ist nicht Human Readable. Alles andere ist Augenwischerei.
Ich würde es einen Fetisch nennen.
Es ist eingeschränkt wie readable, aber es ist äh ist es auf jeden Fall nicht,
Größere Problem. Also die komme ich gerade noch so klar, aber äh ist halt irgendwie kaum Schreibbar, weil du dann einfach nur Fehler machst und nicht weißt, was du hinschreiben sollst und viel zu viel Overhead hast et cetera.
Und die Klammer nie stimmen.
Ja gut, ich meine, da kann.
Jason willst du auch nicht per Hand schreiben.
Es ist die Hölle.
Jason per Hand. Du vergisst immer an der falschen Stelle einen Kummer oder hast eins zu 4 und ah.
Ich bin auch mittlerweile grad am überlegen, für ein einfaches Problem, ein doch eine Datenbank zu schreiben, die einfach nur ein paar Felder hat, wo ich dann wieder Sachen reinschreiben kann. Also Datenmarkt Interface statt irgendwas selber zu bauen an Jason.
Also Markdown halte ich einfach für ein gescheitertes Format
Das ist ganz okay, um irgendwie was Bowl und zu machen und äh eine eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Liste zu machen und vielleicht äh drei verschiedene äh äh Level von Hierarchien
machen, aber allein schon sie absolute Adressierung von von Leveln geht halt gar nicht
Einmal was eindrücken über fünf Seiten in zehn Stellen und änderst irgendwie Lattenzaun, einen Lattenzaun, den Lattenzaun, Latten.
Wie was wie wir's einrücken.
Na du willst halt irgendwas, was der.
Machen. Ja, da bist du aber bei Latech auch falsch aufgehoben.
Ich habe auch nicht gesagt, dass ich da richtig aufgehoben bin. Das akzeptiere ich nicht.
Du bist nirgendwo gut aufgehoben.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich möchte gerne, dass das Internet mir eine Lösung äh.
Lernprogrammieren.
Kann programmieren.
Dann wende es an.
Du wirst lachen, das war tatsächlich mal eins meiner ersten ähm Projektziele oder man überlegt ja manchmal, was könnte ich denn mal programmieren, was reizt mich denn am meisten.
Was was müsste da am meisten mal gefixt werden? Dann kommen auch die besten Programme bei.
Ja noch in der Zeit, wo es nichts gab so und da dachte ich so, was was müsste man denn mal überhaupt mal schreiben.
Eigentlich jemals einen Kalender fixen? Du hast ja mal dieses Kalenderthema gehabt, dass du.
Das habt ihr auch alle total missverstanden. Das war eine User-Interface-Kritik, ja.
Ist auch scheiße. Ich habe den letzten mal benutz.
Ist auch teilweise gelöst worden nach zwei Jahren. Ähm so ich wollte eine Textverarbeitung schreiben,
Ähm ich habe also ich habe schon aufm C 64 damals mit großer Begeisterung Visabreit verwendet. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand von euch äh noch im Ohr hat. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Mal verwendet, aber.
War definitiv der beste Textprozessor aufm C vierundsechzig. Das war so das erste Tool, was ähm das mit den Absätzen äh hinbekommen hat,
Also was überhaupt so eine Vorstellung von einem Absatz hatte, das war schon neu damals, ja und ähm erinnere mich jetzt nicht an zu viele Details, aber es war recht inspirierend, wann ich die Lösung aller Probleme, aber ich habe damit umfangreiche, mehrseitige Dokumente geschrieben,
Viel und oft. Und so habe ich auch Deutsch gelernt, also richtig. Und dann hatte ich irgendwie in welcher Phase war denn das eigentlich,
ähm muss so meine kurze,
Phase gewesen sein, genau, das war meine kurze Doss-Phase. Ich hatte mal so für ein Jahr oder so, hatte ich, glaube ich, mal Doss,
PC gekauft habe, so aus Interesse, weil mir der gestunken hat und dann war aber auch furchtbar. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mich da mal einen Tag hingesetzt und habe mal so aufgeschrieben, was meiner Meinung nach eigentlich eine Textverarbeitung äh honorieren müsste,
Also welche Konzepte müssten in der äh in so einem Programm drin sein und wie wie müsste ein Programm das Prinzip Dokument, also Textdokument äh verstehen und da habe ich halt so verschiedene.
Ja für welche Texte.
Alle Texte. Textverarbeitung halt. Du schreibst etwas und äh wie.
Naja, weil es ist ja ohne Unterschied, ob jetzt ein Romano oder eine Gebrauchsanweisung schreibst. Nee, das ist ein Unterschied.
Er will die Universallösung.
Wieso? Wieso ist das ein Unterschied.
Ja weil du andere Dinge brauchst. Also ich meine, Roman ist im Wesentlichen eine Bleiwüste. Während eine eine Gebrauchsanweisung halt hochstrukturiert ist mit Bildern und allem drum und dran und Achtung, Zeichen am Rande.
Auch.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dafür gibt's ganz äh ganz äh viele Softwarelösungen, dass so deine Chapter irgendwie hast und deine ganzen Charaktere mit mit Steckbrief und so weiter. Also das kannst du auch bis ins Unendliche treiben.
Das ist äh.
Ja aber das ist trotzdem, das ist halt einfach was anderes.
Habe das alles mit berücksichtigt, keine Angst. So und dann habe ich mir so einen Plan gemacht und habe mir vor allem irgendwie ein Konzept darüber gemacht, wie Formatierung und äh
sozusagen zu trennen äh und zuzuordnen ist so mit Absatzformatierung, Zeichenformatierung, Vererbung und so all diesen ganzen Sachen,
Dann äh dachte ich mir so, geil, gutes Konzept,
und dann äh bin ich lustigerweise, ihr werdet's nicht glauben, auf Microsoft Word gestoßen. Version drei null. Wohlgemerkt nicht für Windows, sondern das Original.
In schwarz weiß, ne.
In schwarz-weiß.
Menü unten.
Ja genau mit dem Menü.
Ja ja, da renne ich mich noch dran.
Und äh,
Mark, das war ein echt gutes Programm. Microsoft Word, also das Original Word war wirklich toll, das war schnell und,
Ich habe dann meine meine Ansprüche äh verglichen. Okay, alles klar. Gibt's schon,
mixt und habe das dann nie so richtig weiter verfolgt.
Kannst ja auf eBay schauen, ob's noch.
Du musst deinen, warte mal, ich muss mal, ich fixe mal hier dein, das muss mal da, genau.
Ah okay. Du kannst auf eBay schauen, vielleicht gibt's ja noch einen alten Rechner und dann kannst du dir.
Nee, das ist mittlerweile auch äh.
Molator laufen lassen.
Später äh später wurde das ja von meinem anderen Traumprogramm von äh ersetzt
habe ich damit Wört nicht äh viel gemacht, weil ich einfach mit dOS nicht viel gemacht habe. Ich habe irgendwie Doss schnell wieder sein lassen und mich anderen Dingen äh zugewendet. Das war ja auch nicht zu ertragen,
Äh worauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus? Das.
Ein richtiges Programm.
Textverarbeitung muss irgendwie elegant sein, die muss schnell sein, muss ordentlich strukturiert sein und ich bin immer wieder entsetzt, wenn ich mir so anschaue, was heutzutage alles so,
falsch gemacht wird. Und als ich dann das erste Mal Winward gesehen habe, oh man. Und das war so furchtbar,
Ist ja auch immer noch furchtbar.
Gut, keine Lösung gefunden. Prangere das einfach an.
Nee, ist ist wahrscheinlich auch ab einer gewissen Komplexität gibt's ja nicht die perfekte Lösung. Ne, da gibt's irgendwie viele Lösungen und eine ist besser und die andere ist schlechter.
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass man dass man solche Gedankendokumente umfangreicherer Art von irgendwie 20 Seiten nicht irgendwie Internet kompatible äh erstellen und sharen kann.
Aber Tim das ist den gleichen Vortrag kannst du zu 15 verschiedenen anderen Softwareeinheiten vortragen? Ja ich weiß, deswegen,
als als Stimme der Hörer,
sozusagen das, was ich dir schon immer mal sagen wollte. Seit drei Jahren höre ich den Podcast. Seit drei Jahren möchte ich dir das dann in dem Moment immer sagen, es gibt auch andere Nutzergruppen da draußen, die haben andere Bedürfnisse. Da ist sozusagen andere, die haben andere Prioritäten,
deine äh sozusagen Idealvorstellung, die du immer formulierst, äh ist nicht das, was die Mehrheit der Nutzer.
Vollkommen egal. Was was interessiert.
Das weiß ich, dass es mir vollkommen klar ist, ist egal. Ich wollt's nur formell mal.
Nur weil die Mehrheit sich mit weniger zufrieden gibt, muss ich ja noch lange nicht meine Ansprüche.
Nicht nur.
Lasse doch deine Software Maßschneider nur für dich. Ist das ein bisschen teuer, aber dann macht die alles, was du brauchst.
Ist ja nicht nur, dass die weniger wollen sozusagen, sie sind mit der Komplexität überfordert,
Sozusagen das Kernproblem. Das was du willst ist an sich technisch überhaupt kein Problem. Es ist sozusagen das ja der Trend und das ist ja siehst du ja auch bei Apple so insgesamt ja, dass sie sozusagen weggehen von dem
Profi-Tool hinzu dem was sozusagen die 80 Prozent Schnitt braucht. Und das ist sozusagen der Sweet Spot den die meisten,
äh Menschen, die Geld verdienen wollen, sozusagen anstreben, weil sozusagen die 100 Prozent Lösung ähm hat zu viel Knöpfe, um es mal ganz blöd zu sagen, für die meisten Anwender und ähm sozusagen es gibt dann für die Profianwender, die ja äh das.
Hallo, die Leute benutzen wird und hast du mal gezählt, wie viel Knöpfe das hat? Das ist doch genau das Problem. Komplexität
Ist doch äh was vollkommen anderes als kompliziert. Also kompliziert gibt's da draußen viel. Man kann ein komplexes Problem auch elegant lösen,
also ein User-Interface muss ja nicht zwangsläufig kompliziert sein, um ein komplexes Problem zu lösen, sondern es zeugt geradezu von einer guten Lösung eines komplexen Problems, wenn das User-Interface klar ist und wenn auch äh Formate klar sind,
Datei nicht parsen und nix.
Ich möchte mich ungern in die Position begeben, um jetzt Wörter verteidigen, aber
möchte gerne sagen, dass sozusagen, dass du dieses Phänomen immer beobachtest, dass sozusagen äh die äh Reduzierung eher gerade stattfindet bei den bei den meisten User äh sozusagen Programmen und Softwarelösungen, die schmeißen eher noch Funktionen raus
die eben nur von 0,1 Prozent der Nutzung genutzt werden sozusagen zwecks Vereinfachung und du hast natürlich Recht, dass das eigentlich ginge, aber,
Es ist natürlich äh ökonomisch gesehen für den Hersteller immer äh besser sozusagen sich auf das 80-Prozent-Modell zu verlassen, weil das der muss halt nicht in die Pflege von Funktionen investieren, die die die sozusagen nur für die Minderheit äh Nutzern relevant ist.
Äh das hängt ja ganz von deiner Zielgruppe ab. Ich meine, wenn deine Zielgruppe Leute sind, die technische Dokumentation schreiben, dann schreibst du ja nicht äh für Leute, die äh fünf Zeilen Brief äh in schlecht formatiert und auf den meisten Druckern kommt's sogar auf einer Seite raus äh schreiben.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich schreibe meine Briefe immer mit Text Edit. Da gibt es diese Funktionsseitenränder einblenden und dann geht's los.
Ja. Und schreibst immer wieder alles komplett neu.
Sehr geehrter Herr, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, ja.
Deinen ganzen ja.
Freundlichen Grüßen. Anbei erhalten sie.
Ja, das ist deine einzige Aufgabe, ja, was ja nicht die Aufgabe, von der ich gerade sprach. Ich rede ja von ein White Paper, was man äh schreibt und was halt äh sowohl in Form als auch in Funktion in GIT,
gut darstellbar ist.
Na ja, wie gesagt, da hast du zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ist äh.
Überhaupt nicht so. Ich habe mich hier in dem Zusammenhang ähm ich habe zum Beispiel mit diesen Transkripten über die wir letztes Mal gesprochen haben,
ähm mich jetzt auch mit dem Problem auseinandergesetzt, wie kriege ich das Ganze in PDF ordentlich,
Also wie kriege ich sozusagen aus so einem generischen Datenbankinformationen, die die Transkripte ja letzten Endes äh sind, auch ordentlich äh was in PDF auf den richtigen Weg,
und äh bin so na ja so halb zum Ziel gekommen, bis ich festgestellt habe, dass die Art und Weise, wie unsere transkripte intern äh gespeichert werden derzeit noch nicht optimal ist
Wenn sich das ändert, wenn ich dann den zweiten Schritt gehen. Aber ich habe einen äh guten, alten Bekannten wieder getroffen in dem Zusammenhang, der eigentlich äh ganz cool ist,
und zwar äh das gute alte XSL in seiner ursprünglichen Inkarnation FO,
Heißt das? Also der XSL Standard also XML Style sheets ist ja dazu gedacht,
ähm XML-Dokumente in andere XML-Dokumente zu überführen, das ist dieser Transformationsteil, also das XSLT. Und.
Das eigentliche Ziel von Anfang an, was aber erst Jahre später so richtig äh implementiert wurde, aber mittlerweile äh wie es scheint ganz ordentlich funktioniert ist äh FO, nämlich,
ein bestimmter äh XML äh eine bestimmte XML Syntax,
mit der ich halt for Metting Objects definiere. Das heißt, ich kann halt sagen,
Hier sind Dinge auf Seiten, hier sind Header, hier sind Footer, hier sind Spalten, das läuft über mehrere Seiten et cetera
man kann Bilder platzieren also man hat quasi so 'ne Art XML-basierten PDF-Generator,
und man kann dann quasi seinen Inhalt in XML in diese FO-Objekte äh definieren und da ist dann halt XSL als äh Transformationssprache, also XSLT, als Transformationssprache sehr gut geeignet,
und ähm am Ende, wenn man diese FO-Dateien hat, die also XML-Dateien sind,
Wirfst du das in einem sogenannten FO-Prozessor, da gibt's von Apache opensource dieses Apache FOP und dann kommt da PDF bei raus.
Schon mal eine ganz gute Basis, wenn man quasi vorne eine eine so eine Textlogik hat,
am Ende geht's nur dadrum, jetzt soll das Ganze irgendwie auch schön aussehen, du kannst halt das nehmen, weil du kannst halt im Prinzip aus FO,
auch Hypertext äh machen und das irgendwie in andere Systeme überführt. Weiß nicht, ob's so der optimale Weg wäre. Daraus HTML zu machen
eher besser. Man macht vorher die Transformation gleich hin HTML, aber im Prinzip ist das eine ganz gute Basis für alles, was so seitenorientiert äh funktioniert. Also auch wenn man so,
Präsentationsslides draus machen will oder so, kann man das halt mit XSL, FO ganz ordentlich machen, sondern dann hättest du als Targetformat halt PDF,
Also du formulierst das in FO, dann ist es immer noch XML,
äh renderstuden dann hast du halt PDF-Dateien, die dann halt auch Links haben und äh all diesen ganzen Kram, den man eben haben will, ohne irgendwas von Hand zu machen, sofern du eben überhaupt erstmal eine generische,
Tour hast, in was du dir die dann anlegst, ob das aus einer Datenbank kommt oder aus eigenen XML-Dateien, ist natürlich eine andere Geschichte. Sprich, es muss sich eben äh,
letztlich dafür sorgen, dass ich meine Transkripte in XML, in einem ordentlichen XML-Darstellung habe, ballere das durch so eine Transformation und dann kann ich halt,
für meine Webseite automatisch PDFs erzeugen, wo eben dieses Transkript drauf ist, wo dann halt so wie man das so im Slack einen Dialog liest, quasi auf Papier ist,
Schon mal eine ganz interessante äh Sache, da bin ich jetzt gerade mal wieder so ein bisschen mehr am forschen, wenn ich Zeit finde zwischendurch.
Die Monolog Alarmlampe.
Ich habe mich nicht getraut als Gast.
Der You Lost lost me ad X,
Das ist.
Ist gut für dich.
Du äh du erinnerst.
Ja eigentlich bei Notizen auf Gitthup.
Du erinnerst es mich gerade so ein bisschen an diesen diesen Comic von Dragon äh nee äh.
Ach so. Nee.
Ähm äh mit mit äh wie heißt die eine Sprache? How to slayer dragon? Warte, ich such's gerade raus.
Angerichtet, Letti. Ja, Notizen auf Gitta.
Was ist meine Schuld? Äh.
Das ist so wie Kalender, das ist das schreibt man einfach nicht auf. Gewisse Themen schreibt man einfach.
Dafür bin ich überall was zu sagen habe.
Du bist müde Mann.
Habe doch gesagt, ich bin jetzt schon wieder auf Temperatur.
Ja, man merkt,
Kill Dragon Comic.
Apple reden. Was zahlt ihr denn davon? Wir haben ganz viel Apple-Themen. Apple, Apple, Apple, Apple, Apple.
An den hast du mich erinnert aus dem Comic warte, ich schmeiße das Comic mal eben mal eben in den Slack.
Der ja, ihr werdet schon irgendwann feststellen, dass ich immer Recht gehabt habe.
Ich finde das eigentlich total gut, wenn du ähm.
Der Meinung bist, dass du Recht hast.
Also ich finde das ja faszinierend wie Tim äh Konzepte für sozusagen die konzeptuale Probleme von von gewissen Onlineprodukten definiert. Es es ist nur die Lösung sich anzuhören ist nicht immer beglückend.
Die Lösung finde ich auch nicht beglückend, die da draußen sind.
Noch ein bisschen weiter, da gibt's irgendwann also da gibt's diesen Comic äh how to killer Dragon and nine programming langwitches und dann gibt's weiter unten den äh you have hask ana Monat,
Und dann fängt er an und am Ende steht er vor der bröllen brennenden Mülltonne unit help.
Na ja, Coffee Script Haskur, Kobol, Skala.
Der Swift Typ ist auch nicht schlecht.
Peisen, na Elixir ist ja auch nicht dabei.
Der der der Swift-Typ ist auch nicht schlecht. Just as you are äh done Apple releases in New Dragon.
So, Apple, lass mal über Apple reden. Apple Apple Apple Apple. Wir haben verschiedene äh Apple äh Sachen. Wo wir letztes Mal nicht drüber gesprochen haben, glaube ich, ist äh,
Diese Wetten das hier überhaupt eingetragen. Habe ich das eingetragen? Nee.
Das mal von der letzten Sendung.
Der letzten Sendung, ja.
Jetzt irgendwann nur noch vierundsechzig bit äh Applikationen erlaubt sind und die zweiunddreißig Bit, wenn's dann noch welche gibt, also ich habe glaube ich keine mehr. Äh werden einfach nicht mehr gestartet dann.
Kurz vor der WWD C wird Apple äh für den App Store Apps ablehnen, die noch 32 Bit enthalten.
Inzwischen kriegt man ja schon eine Warnung, wenn man sie startet, ne? Damit man schon mal Bescheid weiß, damit man.
Habe schon Horrorvorstellung, wenn sie das durchziehen, die ganzen Drucke, Apps und Scanner, Apps und sonstigen Hilfe von.
Im App Store. Es ist erstmal nur der App Store. Sie lehnen es.
Keine neuen mehr.
Nur die Sachen im App Store ab. Du kannst also keine Updates mehr machen zur Apps oder neue Apps einreichen. Die 32 Bit enthalten,
Wann sie dann den 32 Bit-Support komplett rauswerfen, steht halt auf einem anderen Blatt. Nur wenn man jetzt argumentiert, der Armprozessor kommt, dann werden sie sicherlich einen Armprozessor bauen für den MAC, der Armprozessor für den Mac,
Dann werden sie einen bauen, der kein 32 Bit-Support hat. Ist meine Vermutung und um das vorzubereiten, versuchen sie jetzt alles, was 32 Bit ist, loszuwerden.
Vierundsechzig Bit Arm und 64 Bit Insel, der nichts miteinander zu tun hat. Also das das,
Notwendigkeit in dieser Transit.
Moment, Moment. Wenn du wenn du äh ein Source Code hast, der unter 4und6 Bit nicht kompiliert,
Dann unter 64 bit intel, dann wird er auch unter vierundsechzig bit arm nicht kompilieren und äh deswegen äh glaube ich halt,
Also aus den letzten Transitionen, die ich so mitgemacht habe bei Apple, ist es halt so, dass äh also zum Beispiel die Transition von Power Pc zu Intel war halt die das Problem, aber nicht, dass es ein anderer Zeichensatz ist
und die Transition von von äh von Intel zu arm jetzt gut das eine war Mecco ist das andere war iOS, aber da war das Problem überhaupt nicht der Prozessor,
sondern dass du halt dass der Set von APIs nicht so ganz hundertprozentig ist. Äh wohingegen der Übergang von dreißig2 bis zu vierunddreißig, 4undsechzig Bit deutlich schmerzhafter war als diese anderen beiden Transitionen.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Läuft, nur die Ergebnisse sind falsch.
Ja oder läuft gar nicht. Also wenn du Code hast, der irgendwie in Strukturen rumgräbt, die halt davon ausgehen, dass dass das 32 Bett ist und alles, dann funktioniert's halt nicht.
Wie ist denn das? Ich habe das gar nicht jetzt so mehr verfolgt, aber wie verhält sich denn so vierundsechzig bit Insel kurze 32 bitt intel äh Code Performance mäßig, also auf arm war das ja auch von der Performance her ein großer Sprung.
Ich glaube, bei Intel war's schon auch ein Sprung, ja.
Also das das gibt ja also ich finde ja immer, dass es ein Urban Legend ist, aber vielleicht ist es auch nicht ganz so. Es ist schon so, dass durch die vierundsechzig bit pointer brauchst du halt mehr Speicher, wenn du halt viele Pointers und die hat man ja nun mal in so einem Programm
Das heißt, es ist schon ein Nachteil, weil du musst dadurch auch mehr Memory durch die Gegend schieben und so weiter und so fort. Das ist eigentlich sozusagen könnte man dann alles langsamer
Aber da vierundsechzig Bit halt eben nicht nur 64 Bit ist, sondern die haben ja auch äh mehrere Gister und so weiter, weil X sechsundachtzig hat ja eigentlich mehr oder weniger keine und bei vierundsechzig Bit gibt's dann mal ordentlich welche, ist alles
deutlich schneller durch, dass man halt mal Register ordentlich benutzen kann, so wie sich's gehört und das holt den Speed wieder raus und meiner Meinung nach ist das halt am Ende ein Win, also das bisschen Memory da stört nicht so. Da sind viele Leute aber andere Meinungen, weil die sagen immer ja, es braucht ja mehr Speicher.
Ja, das.
Programme selbst, ja weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, dass Arm viel stärker relative Sprünge benutzt und dann hast du ja du machst ja selten einen relativen Sprung über 4undsechzig bit Adress-Raum und dann hast du halt weniger Bikes in deinem Code, wo du tatsächlich springen musst. Also ich das.
Wieso X 6undachtzig kann ich relativ springen.
Gute Gründe, Intel 32 Bit an sich auch zu verlassen. Einer davon mag einen Wechsel auf arm 46 Bit sein,
einer, aber ist nicht der Einzige, sondern es ist generell auch, sagen wir mal, der Wunsch sich zu erneuern auf der Plattform.
Ja, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das inter jetzt einen Chip rausbringt, wo sie den 32 mit Support wegschmeißen.
Nee, aber ein O aber ein OS, in dem keine 23 bit Librarys mehr ähm sind. Wo sie quasi das ganze Betriebssystem um die ganzen 2und3 Bitcode entschlacken können.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Aber macht das nicht auch Sinn, wenn Sie auf ihrem Silicon den 32 Bit Quatsch alles mal weglassen.
Ja, aber sie werden das bei Intel glaube ich nicht tun.
Nee, bei Insel nicht, aber.
Wenn sie's auf jeden Fall tun. Also die.
War, das war ja meine Argumentation, dass es danach riecht, dass sie dann auf arm gehen, weil Arm da nie 32 Bit haben wird und dann musst du halt darauf vorbereitet sein.
Hat mir überhaupt eigentlich schon über diese 4und6 Bits äh gesprochen? Überhaupt.
Was über die 64 nein, die 64 Bit Transition, das hatte ich zur letzten Sendung rein einge.
Es es gab doch jetzt die Meldung dass also es gab noch diesen Blomberg äh Artikel wo halt mal wieder gesagt wurde arm wird kommen.
Zweitausendzwanzig oder was haben die gesagt, ne? Na ja, wir hatten das.
Kurz, ja. Nur dass dass die das jetzt offiziell angekündigt hatten, dass dass sie kein dass sie kein 32 Bit mehr haben wollen. Darüber haben wir nicht gesprochen.
Wie konkret haben Sie sich denn hier geäußert? Dass Sie okay, jetzt gibt's diesen und dann zehn äh zehn dreizehn vier.
Also muss also musst vierundsechzig Bit unterstützen,
Du musst für ein unterstützen. Also zweiunddreißig Bit alleine geht nicht mehr. Wenn du im Make-up Store Publishing willst, aber das ist natürlich so ein bisschen der Hebel, mit dem Sie wahrscheinlich anfangen zu biegen.
Na ja, schon diese Warnungsmeldung hat jetzt extrem viel äh Bewegung ins Spiel gebracht. Also ich hatte tatsächlich noch so einiges in zweiunddreißig
äh rumliegen und auf einmal Blumen, die Blumen kamen überall so, ach ja, übrigens hier Update und 64 Bit und testen wir schon seit einem Jahr und jetzt können wir's ja auch mal releasen
und so, hust, hust. So hier unter anderem meine äh Buchhaltungssoftware und so weiter war dann auf einmal auch so heute auf morgen dann doch mal vierundsechzig bit
und äh ja und wie du schon sagst, diese ganze Scanner ja ja genau, da ist ich habe.
L Chipo Software.
Ja ich weiß gar nicht, was das Problem da ist. Es sind einfach Leute, die sich nicht ausreichend kümmern irgendwie oder Firmen, die nicht genug äh in diese Programmierer investieren, äh um da mal eine regelmäßige Produktpflege zu machen, sondern die quasi sagen, na ja, wieso denn,
Der Scanner ist ja vor drei Jahren erschienen. Da brauchen wir jetzt auch keine neue Software zu machen.
Das Projekt sozusagen.
Ja, bis dann alle äh bis an alle schreien,
Das ist halt immer das Problem, aber das wird jetzt auf jeden Fall eine Menge Welle bringen und äh allein schon in dieser Woche, in einer Woche ist es draußen, ne,
Habe ich also diverse Softwareupdates bekommen auf verschiedenen Sachen und ich habe jetzt vor allem auch viel Zeug auch irgendwie weggeschmissen, was.
Seit einer Woche draußen.
Zehn 4 oder zwei Wochen? Weiß grad nicht.
Ist schon ein bisschen länger, oder? Ist doch egal, ist schon eine Weile draußen. Gestern kam ja schon das Update auf, zehn dreizehn vier eins.
Mir auf jeden Fall immer sicher war, dass dieser Abendtransition stattfinden wird, dass wir irgendwie Max sehen werden mit 4undsechzig Bit, am Prozessoren. Und ich glaube auch.
Hoffe, dass sie sich damit nicht in Fuß schießen, wie gesagt, weil weil halt doch da sehr viele Backend-Entwickler da draußen sind, die halt die halt auf Docker setzen und du kannst jetzt von Docca sagen, was du willst, aber das ist halt Intel, ne? Also.
Was hat sie jetzt mit Dinkel zu tun.
In dem Docker-Container läuft halt ein Linux, ein Intel Linux. Und.
Container hat er doch genauso gut auch ein Armlehnungslauf.
Nur wenn du auch abends Server hast, was aber niemand hat oder kaum jemand.
Ich verstehe jetzt grad auch den Bogen nicht.
Also wenn du wenn du lokal auf deiner Maschine Docker Container entwickeln willst, dann müssen die natürlich auch dort lauffähig sein. Sprich, du lässt den Code laufen, der hinterher auch auf dem Server läuft und wenn du jetzt.
Server gibt's auch immer mehr Armen.
Das mag ja sein, nur wenn du wenn du halt,
da draußen deine ob es jetzt private oder Public Cloud ist, äh die komplett aus äh Prozessoren besteht und du willst auf einem Armrechner lokalen Dockercontainer entwickeln, dann müsste der ja in der virtuellen Maschine laufen, die wiederum halt
Intercoat,
interpretiert und dann wird's fürchterlich langsam. Also an diese Leute kannst du dann den armen Rechner nicht verkaufen, weil die brauchen den Prozessor.
Ich denke, dass gerade im Serverbereich Ahmen gerade riesige Fortschritte macht. Also.
Das mag durchaus sein, aber es ist trotzdem so, dass halt Doccar Container auf Intelmaschinen äh entwickelt werden und dann halt auch die Ployd werden.
Ich glaube, du guckst da auf so eine Gruppe von Leuten, die erstmal nicht für das erste Gerät interessant sind.
Benutzt keiner Doktor mit Raspberry, und irgendwie anderen Armmaschinen irgendwie. Kannst du mir nicht erzählen.
Brechenzentren.
Auch in Rechenzentren.
Und so weiter.
Ja da da sind jetzt Armprozessoren der Hit, weil sie halt extrem viel weniger Strom äh hauen. Die Cloud hat gerade angekündigt, dass sie überhaupt keine Intelmaschinen mehr kaufen. Und Cloud für.
So im Armkurs mit achtundvierzig, also Kern, ja genau.
Also Cloudflair ist eh ganz interessant. Da gab's vor ein paar Monaten schon mal einen Blogpost von diesem Tech-Hat also von dem V äh C äh CTO,
der so schon seit längerer Zeit Benchmarks gemacht hat, ne da mal Benchmarks veröffentlicht mit armen Prozessoren und mit Innenprozessoren und da war dann schon sehr deutlich sichtbar.
Bild mit den beiden Kilowatts.
Ich müsste den linken, vielleicht kann der Chat uns da mal kurz helfen, Cloud Flair Blog äh Abendserver, Performance so als Such äh Keyword. Ähm,
Auf jeden Fall war die Essenz die das äh und für sie ist ja auch Performance relativ wichtig. Jetzt bei cloudflair, weil ne so.
Absolut wichtig.
Ist generell wichtig, aber äh ist bei denen sozusagen etwas, was er sich halt sehr genau angeschaut hat und äh gibt da ganz interessante Vergleiche. Äh wir haben auch den äh Lock schon Arm,
Danke schön. Ähm und äh in der Essenz hat er äh festgestellt, dass,
die Armprozessoren, insbesondere im Multichor
äh mehr als nur mithalten können, sondern teilweise auch schon äh schneller sind
und äh es nur bei manchen Benchmarks, wo halt noch intel optimierter Code drin ist, äh es eben entsprechende Einbrüche gibt.
Mit was vergleichen Sie denn? Pro schnell pro Mega jetzt schnell pro Watt verbraucht oder was ist äh der Vergleich.
Oder ist es.
Na ja das sind hier so RS.
Memory Bount.
Sachen, sind hier verschiedene äh Tests, die er gemacht hat. Also hier.
Weil da die großen Player da draußen, die fahren halt sehr, sehr viel ja war, ne und äh Java braucht vor allen Dingen erstmal Speicher. Also unter.
So eine Leute baut Apple eh keine Rechner, das könnte voll knicken.
Nein, natürlich äh baut für Apple solche Leute keine Rechner, aber die fahren halt solche Server. Ne, klar, das kann natürlich passieren, dass Apple sagt, wir bauen jetzt nur noch arm und dann gibt's halt diverse Firmen, die sagen, ja okay, dann kaufen wir halt jetzt Trinkpads.
Nur noch werden sie wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht machen. Das wird wieder von.
Ja, nicht nur noch, aber für die Leute, die halt entwickeln, die entwickeln dann halt nicht mehr auf Apple-Artwear.
Nein, die kaufen dann einfach einen anderen Apple erstmal.
Ja, welchen denn? Mc Minnie.
Was weiß ich.
Genau, was weiß ich. Ja, ich weiß es nämlich auch nicht, was man da gerade.
Das nächste Macbook Air kommt vielleicht mit einem Arm und dann müssen sie ihre Docker woanders machen.
Zweiter Punkt, Cloudflair hat jetzt angekündigt, dass sie nur noch abends kaufen werden, also offensichtlich sind sie mittlerweile also dieser Blogpost ist jetzt vom November 20 siebzehn, da Maxi schon ein bisschen was getan haben. Äh außerdem meinten sie halt,
Selbst wenn die Dinger äh noch langsamer sind oder teurer zu kaufen sind, das Geld sparen sie sich locker wieder rein beim Stromverbrauch,
die Armsauer werden einfach so dermaßen viel mehr Speicher sevy, was einfach mal äh bei großen Data Centers, äh was habe ich gesagt.
Speichershobby.
Ja, genau. Stromsevy, das äh sich das einfach bei solchen großen Installationen äh doppelt und dreifach Lot allein schon von dem Gesamtstrombedarf, den du hast, nicht nur, dass er weniger kostet, sondern du musst.
Cloud Flair hat aber auch eine sehr spezielle Anwendung, ne.
Ne, die müssen halt auch auf den Strom gucken, genau.
Die haben eine sehr spezielle Angriff Wendung.
Alle haben spezielle Anwendungen.
Ist es nicht so, wie wenn es letztlich gesagt hat, dass dieser Transit,
äh insofern einfach gemacht werden kann, indem man zwei Modellserien läuft. Man läuft noch mit ein bisschen mit Intel und dann gibt's die neuen fancy Macs mit Arm und man man lässt erstmal noch beides irgendwie für zwei, drei Jahre übergangsweise existieren
Weiß aber wo die Zukunft ist und diejenigen, die noch ein bisschen alte Software laufen lassen müssen, können sich dann noch, aber ich meine, ist nicht Apple Style jetzt, weil.
Überhaupt nicht, Apple Style ist überhaupt nicht Apple Style und ist auch völlig unglaubwürdig, dass sie das machen. Also wenn sie umsteigen, dann stellen sie alles um.
Und darüber habe ich auch nachgedacht und habe da eine steile These, weil äh es geht ja immer dieses Argument, oh ja für diese paar McPros jetzt nochmal High End Version von ihren Prozessoren zu bauen. Äh wie soll sich denn das lohnen,
Auch vollziehbares Argument. Und da äh habe ich mich erinnert, dass ja vor einer Weile schon mal so die Nachricht kam, dass Apple für seine eigenen Data-Center keine Manboards mehr in China kauft.
Keine Main-Nords mehr von Super Micro.
Oder von Super Micro, aber ich glaube, das lässt sich äh in eine generelle Skepsis gegenüber diesen Herstellern äh hin übersetzen. Und wenn ich mal so mein eins und eins zusammenzähle,
So ja warum baut sich den Apple nicht einfach seine eigenen Server? Sie brauchen da viele von. Sie haben da spezielle Anwendungen.
Aber viele ist ja nun auch ein bisschen relativ oder.
Was meinst du, wie viel Maschinen sie haben.
Na was meinen sie, wie viel Maschinen Mike äh Super Micro verkauft.
Ist egal. Apple kann sich doch selber ihren eigenen Prozess ja.
Sie bauen genug also sie brauchen genug dass sie sich lohnt sich mal dasselbe zu machen.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall mehr Eigenbedarf an Servern in ihren iCloud-Datencentern, als sie mit Pros verkaufen. Ja. So, aber sie haben
vergleichbare Anforderungen an diese Prozessoren. Abgesehen davon, dass es vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt immer im Rhein ist number crunching für alle Fälle, wo so ein Mac Pro äh glänzen muss, aber du brauchst halt schnelle Kryptoperformance, so,
brauchst einfach generell maximale Performance,
Und äh warum sollten sie nicht ihre Prozessorschmiede damit beauftragen zu sagen, okay, ihr baut jetzt mal hier eine schnelle Variante upsa, eine schnelle Variante, die im Prinzip,
von Feststrom ausgeht.
Du meinst äh.
Also Steckdosenstrom und nicht Akkustrom darf mehr Strom ziehen, ist nicht auf Batterie hin optimiert wie jetzt die ganzen iPhone Prozessoren oder Laptops,
sondern halt mir so iMac und MacPro Style und das selbe oder nicht dasselbe, aber ein ein äh sich in diesen Bereich bewegendes Anforderungsprofil hast du halt im Data-Center auch,
Brauchst viele Calls, du willst hohe Performance haben, Stromverbrauch,
Ist jetzt nicht so megakritisch. Es geht nicht so sehr um Stromsparen um jeden Preis, um irgendeine Akku-Laufzeit lange raushalten.
Aber Apple schon, weil müssen ja ihren Solarstrom nutzen. Außerdem kriegen sie uns von Greenpeace aufs Dach.
Ja, aber du hast bei Armprozessoren generell weniger Stromverbrauch als bei.
Du musst vor allem du musst vor allen Dingen allen Strom, den du verbrauchst hinterher durch die Klimaanlage wieder wegkühlen.
Genau. Man braucht immer das Doppelte.
Ja, ich meine, ich gehe davon aus, dass sie mit diesen Armprozessoren eh besser dran sind als mit den Inselteilen, nur,
Optimierungsziel dieser Prozessoren ist nicht das die maximale Batteriekapazität zu erhalten, sondern Performance zu haben,
Wenn Sie dann immer noch bei gleicher Performance weniger Stromverbrauch als Intel ist immer noch genug gewonnen so,
Nur es geht dadrum, so schnell wie möglich zu sein, also von dieser Architektur her, so schnell vom Aufbau äh und genau dasselbe Prinzip können sie dann eben auch für Mac-Pros oder iMac-Pros verwenden und sie haben trotzdem einen Skalenfaktor, der ist nicht
selbe Skalenfaktor wie die ganze Welt kauft diese Sachen,
Aber sie haben immerhin noch einen geilen Faktor, der ein Vielfaches von Mac Pro in ein Mac Pro Umsatz ist.
Ist übrigens eine kalifornische Bude.
Aber es hieß doch, dass Sie da bestimmte Mainboards aus Taiwan oder China.
Die lassen bestimmt auch in China herstellen und die drei Gründe haben auch chinesische Namen würde ich mal behaupten, aber es ist äh Sandrosee irgendwie. Kalifornien Base.
Ja wahrscheinlich beherstellen die alles in China wäre. Nur die Firma sitzt halt dort,
Naja du hast, natürlich hast du noch Ausfallsicherheit und so ein Server muss halt muss halt äh auch IO machen. Der muss vor allen Dingen IO machen. Also,
Rechenleistung ist gar nicht so entscheidend. Also für so einen normalen Wald und Wiesenserver,
Der packt halt Bits von rechts nach links und vor und zurück und in die Datenbank und aus der Datenbank wieder raus und in den Kafka-Stream und aus dem Kafka-Stream wieder raus und und und ach wie sie's anders heißt.
Genauso wie mit Pro. Der macht auch viel IO.
Ich fände das mal ganz angemessen, wenn Sie so einen Server bauen, dass Sie ihn dann auch verkaufen würden.
Ja
Das ist so ne es muss ja nicht jetzt unbedingt ein hübscher Xurf sein aber einfach mal ein Stück Hardware was irgendwie was kann und was man sich bei uns untern untern Schreibtisch stellen kann. Also es ist irgendwie.
Aber das, was die dann da bauen, wenn sie das so machen, so rechenzentrenmäßig, dann äh Google macht das ja auch,
Die haben ja auch so Boards, die haben gar keine Gehäuse mehr, ne? Haben eine eigene Batterie drauf, damit sie,
Sind damit sie keine US kaufen müssen, hat jedes Board seine eigene kleine Billig.
Batterie, ne und sie ähm haben keinen Wechselstrom mehr, sondern die kriegen irgendwie so achtundvierzig oder vierundzwanzig oder 12 Volt direkt angeliefert schon, weil das auch äh effektiver ist als jedem Ding extra nochmal so ein so ein äh Netzteil zu geben.
Hatte nicht sogar Facebook angekündigt, dass sie auch eigene Prozessoren entwickeln wollen oder habe ich das mir.
Ja, die haben jetzt wahrscheinlich inzwischen auch so viel Hardware, dass sie sich da auch langsam mal lohnt. Dann kommt halt irgendein so ein äh irgend so ein Typi an, rechnet das einmal durch, ob sich das lohnt oder nicht und dann wird halt entschieden, ja wir können da zehn Prozent sparen und dann schwupp macht man das.
Also solange du wirklich wirklich vom,
Vom blanken Metall bis ganz oben an der Anwendung alles unter deinem äh unter deinen Fittichen hast, dann lohnt sich das auch. Wenn du aber eigentlich solche Ressourcen woanders einkaufst, dann bist du sowieso ein bisschen davon abhängig, was
dir bietet. Ne, also ich meine.
Aber ich meine Apple hat ja wirklich alles selber vom Data-Center über die CPUs, also die können ja wirklich das alles designen.
Im Prinzip ja.
Oder was heißt sein, haben sie auch schon.
Ich glaube um das und also ich halte das für sehr möglich.
Nee, ich halte es auch für möglich, dass Sie's machen. Ich bin mir nur nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob's der
Schritt ist, für alle Apple User und dass sie, wenn sie von arm, von Intel weggehen, halten einen Teil verlieren, weil die sagen, wir brauchen unbedingt Kompatibilität, damit wir in irgendwelchen virtuellen Boxen irgendwelche anderen Betriebssysteme laufen lassen können.
Möchte gerne einen Abendprozessor haben in meinem Mac Alleine schon, um mich wieder über Chips äh lustig machen zu können, wie früher.
Das sehe ich ein aber wir haben ja gerade eben schon festgestellt, dass du nicht so bist wie andere User.
Sei froh.
Mag ja die Interchips.
Ich habe mal diesen Artikel äh rausgesucht hier, den ich gerade äh meinte Aussage von dem CEO. Äh Abend wäre für sie sogar billiger, wenn sie die ganzen X86 Prozessoren kostenlos bekommen würden,
Preis, wo nicht richtig mithalten kann, weil sie sich so viel Strom sparen würden dadurch. Das ist schon ähm an.
Mal eine Ansage, ja.
Genau, zumal es eben auch dann nicht nur die reine Performance ist, weil dann kaufst du halt ein Service, weil einfach mehr, wenn ihr dann weniger Strumpfer brauchen, irgendwie kann's ja auch egal sein. Weiß nicht, ob's hier noch genauere Zahlen Zahlen äh geben. Es ist hier so ein Interview, was hier zusammengefasst wird.
Weißt du, wie ähm,
lagert Apple seine iTlot derzeit auf eigenen Datenzentren. Ich meine, sie weiß, dass sie eins haben, ein größeres, aber ich hatte vor Kurzem was gelesen, dass sie jetzt umgestiegen sind. Ähm,
zu Google sogar, dass ihnen die Hälfte des der ihrer eigenen Daten der inzwischen auf Google Servern liegt. Ich glaube sie waren von Amazon zu Google gewechselt.
Von Azure, von Microsoft sind sie.
Sie haben von Anfang an haben sie das gemacht, also als ICloud gestartet ist, haben sie ähm also
Genaue Zahlen, wie viel das ist, habe ich nie gesehen, aber äh sie haben das auf verschiedenen anderen Architekturen gemacht, um ihre eigene Infrastruktur mal zu bootsrappen. Mittlerweile haben sie diverse Data-Center. Wie viel Prozent ihres Eigenbedarfs sie das äh dahin bekommen? Weiß ich nicht.
Fand's erstaunlich, dass sie sich dann dennoch sozusagen jetzt getrennt haben und jetzt nochmal zu Google umgezogen. Das finde ich eigentlich auch schon pR-technisch relativ,
äh na ja ungünstig, wenn man sozusagen die die ähm Company ist, obwohl das natürlich völlig wurscht ist, weil es natürlich der Lage aber nichtsdesto.
Sicher.
Hoffe ich doch.
Kannst du mal von ausgehen, ne.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz fand ich's fand ich's erstaunlich, wenn man jetzt nochmal umzieht, dann ist man noch glaube ich nicht 100 Prozent selbst versorgt. Also vielleicht sind sie noch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Getränke irgendjemand? Deine Getränkepause.
Wenn das die letzte Brause war.
Ich werde ich werde jetzt nur noch die Fritzlimogrufen.
Hast du eine Cola mitgebracht.
Also keiner will Getränke.
Na ja, wenn es die letzte war, nicht.
Klare Ansage.
Da letztens auch so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, weil eben alle so darauf abfahren, äh Cloud-Computing zu betreiben und einfach
irgendwo was gefühlt zum Mieten ähm ob man nicht eben, wenn man bisschen größer ist, irgendwann an einem Punkt kommt
wo es halt wirklich günstiger ist. Also wo ist es günstiger zu sagen, ja am Anfang nehme ich's, kaufe ich so was wie Amazon ein und habe halt vielleicht trotz alledem, wenn ich eine große Firma bin, so ein
täglichen tägliche Amazon-Rechnung von tausenden von Euro,
Wo kommt dann der Punkt, wo man sagt so, es lohnt sich dann doch selber, die Infrastruktur zu haben, wo man, wie Huckel irgendwie meinte, bis ins kleinste technische Detail irgendwie die das Optimum aus den Servern,
rauszuholen.
Nicht so richtig sagen, weil du dein Bedarf nicht so vielleicht abschätzen kannst oder weil du halt nicht immer gleich ist. Also jetzt gerade zum Beispiel Pokemon Go,
jetzt mal erwähnen.
Wir sollten WOW da lieber erwähnen.
Nee, jetzt ist ich glaube, die machen's tatsächlich selber. Die haben das nicht in der Cloud, bin mir aber da auch nicht so sicher. Früher haben die das hier auf jeden Fall selber gemacht in Paris,
Jedenfalls Pokemon Go hat am Anfang irgendwie 500 Millionen User und der Typ hat ja auch mal geschrieben, sie haben ähm im Worst Case sind sie von 50 Millionen ausgegangen und haben aber eher so für
zehn Millionen geplant oder weiß ich nicht wie viele und und haben gedacht, na ja vielleicht werden's fünfzig Millionen, aber dann dann brennt alles, aber es wurden dann halt 500 Millionen User. So und damit du so was abfangen kannst, gehst du halt in die Cloud und was die gemacht haben, die haben einfach
so einen Button geklickt haben und gesagt, ja dann gebt uns halt eben dementsprechend mehr Cloud-Server
und dann war das Problem jetzt nicht gelöst. Sie mussten schon eine Menge machen, so auch traffic und kostenmäßig. Sie haben irgendwie glaube ich so ein paar Features aus aus Pokemon Go entfernt, damit weniger Traffic stattfindet. Also haben das ein bisschen durchoptimiert. Aber sie konnten einfach den Bedarf durch den Cloud-Kram
einfach nach oben schrauben und als dann wieder weg sind, muss dann auch nicht deine Hardware kaufen oder dein dein weiß schon die ganzen Verträge kündigen, sondern sagst,
Amazon oder Google ja wir brauchen jetzt ein bisschen weniger Cloud-Rechner und bum fertig, das ist schon.
Das stimmt, wenn du so mit.
Wenn es sich so anpassen kann.
Wenn du halt dieses User-Problem halt dann also oder die Problematik der User und Skalierbarkeit hast, das stimmt, ja.
Und ich meine, das ist ja so, ich weiß, ihr habt ja vielleicht auch selber eure eigene Hardware irgendwo zu stehen. Ich habe auch einen einen Rechner, der Mail macht und ein bisschen Mambeln kann er und und da läuft Bitcoin-Diemen so neben
bei so ein bisschen,
Also nicht als Mining, sondern sondern nur als als Note so und aber ehrlich gesagt, der Rechner ist ja keine 1 Prozent ausgelassen und wenn man mal überlegt, ist ja eigentlich
total bekloppt, da die Festplatten rennen die ganze Zeit. Alles rennt da die ganze Zeit. Der Platz wird belegt, aber der Rechner wird eigentlich nur zu zehn Prozent benutzt und so ein Cloudding
sorgt Amazon halt dafür, dass die halt dass die halt glühen die Dinger und dass die halt,
Bis am Rand irgendwie zu tun haben. Natürlich haben die so ein gewisses Limit und so weiter, so dass du halt immer ein bisschen Kapazitäten frei hast, aber die nutzen das eigentlich insgesamt viel besser aus und das spart ja auch, ja, schont unsere Umwelt am Ende, wenn man das mal ganz unterm Strich betrachtet.
Ja vor allen Dingen vor allen Dingen hast.
Hinterher auch im zunehmenden Maße, also sicher viel einfacher mit einem äh erneuerbaren Energiestrom versorgen lassen.
Es gibt noch einen anderen Effekt. Du willst ja oder Aspekt
du du willst ja, du willst ja eine Ausfallsicherheit haben. Das heißt, wenn du wirklich eine größere Firma bist, die davon abhängig ist, dass das System immer läuft, dann willst du ein Betrieb haben und wenn die
wenn du das auf eigener Hardware machst, dann musst du auch zwei Data-Center haben.
Idealerweise schön weit voneinander wächst, sodass wenn Erdbeben kommt.
Richtig.
Dein eigenes, dabei bist beide und.
Kommt, spielt eh keiner mehr. Poké.
Genau und dann kostet es halt nochmal richtig, wenn wenn du halt zwei Data-Center haben mussten mit zwei Anbindungen und, und, und, und, und.
Ja ich habe mich das deswegen gefragt so ein bisschen äh ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich warum ich mir über so was überhaupt Gedanken gemacht habe.
Was? Zu viel Podcast gehört deswegen.
Das könnte gut sein, ähm weil,
ebenso dieses ah wann lohnt es sich wirklich so selber so oder mini Rechenzentrum selber zu haben und wenn du dann eben noch äh deine Software so optimieren kannst, genau dass sie halt eben wirklich parallel auch ähm,
Das ist so Paral Computing mit den Dingen, mit den Dingen betreiben kannst. Dann wird sie halt erst so richtig spannend,
aber ich glaube meiner besten Freundin habe ich das erzählt und die meinte nur so, geh weg, das ist ein ekelhaftes Thema,
dafür ein bisschen bekomme. Aber das ist halt was, wo ich mir echt dachte, so ah, wie muss ich das eigentlich aufbauen,
damit ich so quasi den besten kurz Kosten-Nutzen-Faktor habe.
Total interessantes Thema.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Nicht super einfach natürlich.
Nee, nee. Weil ich nämlich auch gedacht habe, so bei einigen Sachen viel also viele Software ist halt irgendwie,
Läuft halt nicht so verteilt oder wird nie so primär so ähm entwickelt, dass es halt auch verteilt gut äh skaliert.
Ja das ist auch total schwierig.
Ich habe eine total geile Vorlesung gehabt,
auf die mich so gefreut habe irgendwie hier leider war mein Professor irgendwie ein bisschen krank und äh hört sehr langsam geredet so zäh und Computer und ich bin echt,
Das war eine harte.
Äh ganz spannend finde, das ist, dass ihr das alles gerade so positiv seht und das ist äh für mich gerade insofern neu, als dass es ja sonst immer hieß, so irgendwie ah Cloud, gefährlich und und irgendwie ist es doch immer die Computer und so weiter.
Ja, so ist das ja auch. Also ich habe.
Ist es hier so, aber was ich immer, was ich immer dachte dabei war, ähm äh dass das natürlich immer von einem sehr hohen Ross äh ist, ne? Wir sind wieder bei den 80 Prozent und zwanzig Prozent ähm.
Na, ich habe ja mein
Rechner muss sich ja eben nicht eine Businessentscheidung treffen, dass ich da Geld spare, sondern ich mache das ja für mich und habe auch da Ansprüche, die kosten mich auch, ich könnte wahrscheinlich viel billiger jetzt irgendwo mich in so einen Cloudserver irgendwie einmieten, wurde bei Headser dann mit 100 Leuten auf einer Kiste steck.
Nochmal auf diesen Sicherheitsaspekt kommen, dass er immer gesagt hat, ja aber deine eigene Software ist doch viel sicherer und ich mir dann immer denke, also das sind halt äh,
Hardware und Software, die du dann betreiben kannst, nur wenn du denke ja, es gibt nicht sehr viele Leute da draußen, die wirklich einen sicheren Server laufen lassen können,
keine Ahnung ja aber du bist ja angreifbar die NSA überwacht dich und ich so die NSA überwacht auch deinen privaten Server, wenn sie wollen plus
dein Haus, in dem du deinen Server stehen hast,
der wird halt auch gerade nicht dann überwacht, wenn du nicht zu Hause bist, also die Annahme, dass äh die Cloud äh nicht sicherer ist ähm ich weiß nicht, ob das heutzutage noch stimmt oder ob es jemals gestimmt hat. Also das Entschuldigung, dass es zu Hause sicherer ist als.
Das macht der NSA auf jeden Fall mehr Arbeit, wenn du dein Zeug auf deinem eigenen Rechner hast und nicht bei Amazon, wo sie direkt die Glasfaser dann ausm.
Zu gefühlten Select all darauf.
Wenn du dein eigenes Data-Center hast, dann kannst du schon auch andere Policys and Forcen, da hast du natürlich alles in in der Hand.
Viel Wissen unglaublich viel Updates äh trallala, die du ganze Zeit musst dich drum kümmern.
Es ist halt extrem.
Den Durchschnittsnutzer, den ich ja hier vertrete.
Na ja gut, aber aber das äh das macht's halt auch so teuer. Ne, also wenn wenn du den Kram selber äh selber betreiben willst und und deswegen gehen ja auch,
viele davon weg. Also äh selbst wenn du ein eigenes Data-Center betreibst, betreibst du's ja im Prinzip wie eine wie eine wie eine Cloud,
Nur dass du halt deine eigene Cloud aufbaust, sprich du schiebst ja auch die ganzen Instanzen ständig zwischen den Servern hin und her und und und es die neu und Zeug, weil,
der Ansatz, der technische Ansatz macht total Sinn, egal ob dir jemand anders die Ressourcen gibt oder ob du die eigene Hardware im Keller hast.
Natürlich immer ein bisschen mit deinem ähm Drogenszenario, deinem Potentiell, ne
zusammen. Also erstmal wie wie wahrscheinlich ist das überhaupt, dass hier jemand äh ans Fell will beziehungsweise,
was würde dich das im Zweifelsfall kosten? Also wie sensitiv sind deine Daten oder wie sensitiv ist deine deine Betriebszuverlässigkeit oder wie hoch ist der Spionagefaktor
und da gibt's natürlich durchaus Branchen. Äh das kann man jetzt nicht mit
Allgemeinnutzer beschreiben, sondern wir reden ja hier von Unternehmen und Organisationen, die in irgendeiner Form Daten vorhalten, prozessieren,
oder Dienste anbieten und natürlich,
Ist das schon ein Faktor, wenn du selber die Hardware unter Kontrolle hast? Dann kannst du zum Beispiel sicherstellen, dass alle deine Prozessoren auf deinen Mainboards auch das neueste Microcode Update haben, was gegen Meltdown et cetera gehärtet ist.
Es ginge, sagen wir es mal so. Ich habe nur die praktische Lebenserfahrung, dass ich bei verschiedenen Agenturen gearbeitet habe und da dann irgendwie jemand auf die Idee kam, zum Beispiel so eine Windows Cloud lokal zu betreiben äh und dann äh
oder so ein so ein Service da an dem ja ist ja total super, dass wir hier einen lokalen Server haben, das alles lokal speichern und dann werden aber zum Beispiel wurden dort ein Max rausgegeben an die Mitarbeiter und äh weil die von der IT gemanagt wurden,
Die nicht verschlüsselt sein, weil sonst hatte die IT.
Keinen Zugriff mehr.
Zugriff. Also haben wir keine lokale Festplattenverschlüsselung gehabt,
auf diesen Rechnen, wo dann die ganzen Unternehmensdaten drauf waren und äh um sozusagen,
Die Mitarbeiter sind natürlich ständig zugefahren oder sonstwo draußen gewesen und.
Dann war's aber eine unfähige IT.
Natürlich ist es eine untätige Art, wie der Hund rede ich ja. Das sind die 80 Prozent von denen ich spreche. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist
Also und was haben Sie gemacht als Lösung, damit Sie sozusagen mit Ihrer IT-Richtlinie wir haben in die Arbeitsverträge reingeschrieben, du darfst auf deinem tragbaren Computer, was unser einziger Computer war, den wir hatten,
keine Unternehmensdaten speichern. Und dann habe ich die,
einzige habe ich mir diese Security Anweisung da durchgelesen, die uns gegeben haben. Habe dann angerufen und gesagt, wie wie stellt ihr euch denn vor? Na ja, sie können ja jeden Abend die Daten, die sie am Tag bearbeitet haben, wieder zurück auf den lokalen Service spielen,
Und ich so ey warum gibt die mir einen mobilen Rechner,
um mir dann zu verbieten, diesen zu transportieren, damit ich ihn dann benutzen kann. Das war sozusagen oder es werden halt diese gesamten irrationalen Entscheidungen gemacht, wie zum Beispiel irgendwie, ihr dürft kein Chrom verwenden,
weil der kommt von Google und Google ist böse. Ähm so sind diese äh IT.
Endlich sagt's mal einer.
IT-Aft und
Was ist ihm die Nutz was war die Antwort der der Mitarbeiter, die natürlich Chrome brauchten ähm ist sie nehmen den einen von zu Hause einen einen äh Speicherstick
und machen einen mobilen Chrom drauf sozusagen und umgehen die gesamte Security, die sich die IT also sozusagen dieses ähm Linux sagt dann ja immer irgendwie, man muss halt da die das als Gesamtheit denken und deswegen denke ich das ganz oft für ganz viele Unternehmen in einem praktischen
eine gut verschlüsselte Cloud mit zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung als Absicherung besser ist als eine lokalbetriebene Sicherheit
oder die eigenen Server, die eben dann nicht richtig gemanagt werden und das ist halt immer so dieses Jahr
abstrakte Sicherheit und nicht so dieses Konkrete in dem Alltag der Menschen.
Da hast du total recht. Also.
Ja
Aber ich finde halt auch so,
Ich man hat manchmal bei einigen Unternehmungen so den Eindruck, sie wollen alles geschenkt haben und sie wissen auch alles immer so was ITs Security und Infrastrukturbetreiben angeht. Und das,
na ja wie soll man sagen, vielleicht einfach mal ganz gutes Geld in die Hand zu nehmen, einen Menschen einzustellen, der davon Ahnung hat oder sich beraten zu lassen und nicht einfach jede Grütze sich dahin zu stellen,
echt ein Problem. So dieses.
Noch größer, dass die meisten noch nicht mal wissen ähm sozusagen, dass sie ein Problem haben,
auch schönes Beispiel bei der gleichen Agentur, wo ich war, beziehungsweise war ein größeres deutsches Unternehmen. Ähm da war das halt so, dass die äh IT am Einrichtungstag, ne? Erster Tag kriege ich also meinen Arbeitsrechner und dann ähm rufe ich die IT an, ja irgendwie Einrichtung, mein,
Outlook wird dann konfiguriert aufm Mac, aber nicht. Ja. Ja.
Ich leide mit dir.
Danke, ne? Und dann äh sage ich so ruhig so und ja wir schalten uns jetzt auf deinen Mac. Und ich so okay und dann so, wir sind jetzt auf deinem Mac und ich so, äh wo ist denn das Fenster mit bitte geben Sie dem Admin Zugang und die so nee, das haben wir, das haben wir nicht,
wir kamen einfach hier und ich glaube, ihr habt jederzeit Zugang zu meinem Mac. Ihr könnt euch jederzeit, ohne dass ich gefragt werde und ich so,
Weiß der Vorstand das? Dass die hier jederzeit auf den also der Vorstand, die Boards und so weiter, die auch Max haben, ja, dass ihr jederzeit Zugang habt,
Ich sage, ihr seid ja ein unkündbares Volk in der IT-Abteilung, weil ihr sozusagen die geheime Macht habt und euch auf jeden Mitarbeiter in dieser Firma schalten könnt zu jedem Zeitpunkt abends dreiundzwanzig Uhr dreißig. Ähm fand ich äh also.
Aber das war vor 20 Jahren auch schon so. Beim Chef war alles total geheim, aber der Admin hatte alle Passwörter.
Ja, ich glaube ja, dass die Admins sowieso die geheime Macht haben in äh so, nächstes Thema.
Bleibt noch interessant. Also im Chat kam grad hier noch der Hinweis, jemand arbeitet hier bei äh einer großen Bank, da geht äh gar nicht, ja? Wir haben zwei Datencenter und viele, viele Server, geht nicht anders, das ist auch von der Barfin so,
vorgesehen, dass.
Bei einer sogenannten modernen Fintech, die ganzen neuen Unternehmen, die da so Payments und Bitcoin und den ganzen Scheiß machen, die sind auch alle bei Amazon Cloud und noch nicht mal in Europa, sondern auch in in USA und so und.
Genau am Bitcoin siehst du auch, was passiert, wenn man's nicht gut macht. Also da sind ja so viele gescheitert schon dran.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, aber ob's an den Cloud lag oder sonst.
Anderen im eigenen sonstigen Inko.
Ja, genau,
natürlich schickes Ziel sind, weil frische Firmen gerade angefangen, aber liegt viel Geld rum und natürlich sind da die Hacker am Start. Die sind bei den Banken sicher auch am Start, aber die Banken kaufen sich das ja äh die zahlen ja und dann ist ja wieder Ruhe und dann die publishen das ja nicht.
Zweiter Link Day noch kam ähm hatte ich auch immer schon mal gelesen nicht mehr so ganz auf dem Zeiger, dass Dropbox vor ein paar Jahren auch angefangen hat von zu marschieren, seine eigene Cloud aufzubauen und ich glaube, das hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass eben diese Dienste, also
Amazon ABS war ist natürlich super, wenn du mal eben was starten willst oder irgend so ein Produkt hast, was,
was weiß ich, irgendwas macht, aber das keine Megadimension hat. Ab dem Moment, wo du
mehr oder weniger klar ist, was du machen willst, beziehungsweise auch die Art und Weise, wie du es machst, entscheidend ist für die Weiterentwicklung des Produkts und deine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
dann äh wie zum Beispiel jetzt bei Dropox macht's halt Sinn, ne, weil sie können natürlich auch ihr Datencenter genau äh daraufhin auslegen für den Bedarf, den sie haben, was auch immer dieser Bedarf,
im Einzelnen sein.
Kostenfrage oder? Also ich meine.
Da ist natürlich eine Kostenfrage. Erstmal muss natürlich das ausbauen. Du brauchst die Kompetenz et cetera, die Standorte, äh Security und so weiter. Klar, aber dann zahlst du natürlich jetzt auch äh nicht so viel Geld für den ganzen.
Wenn du genau weißt, was du brauchst und hast das Know-how, dann kannst du's wahrscheinlich günstiger machen, als wenn äh Amazon an dir verdient. Das ist logisch.
Für so eine einzelne Kiste, schnell mal aufgesetzt, das machst du, da musst du dir einen Rechner kaufen hier und da, also alles, was du nur unter einem Dutzend Mal benutzt, da lohnt das wahrscheinlich noch nicht
Netflix ist ja auch weggegangen von, jetzt weiß nicht, ob sie bei Amazon war, aber die hatten irgendeinen Standard-CDN benutzt, wo sie ihre ganzen Movies von verteilen und die haben sich das auch durchgerechnet und haben sich dann auch, die Nutzen der Free WSD
sich dann auch so ein so ein ich weiß nicht wie die das genau nennen so ein oder keine Ahnung die haben auch so Namen dafür ihr Kasten
und äh machen das auch selber mit eigener Software. Ich glaube, wir nutzen sogar engine X so eine Spezialversion und.
Dazu kommt natürlich auch, dass also gerade so Firmen, die halt sehr viel auf große Performance machen, dass du dann natürlich auch den gesamten Stack optimieren willst. Und wenn da irgendeine Maschine in irgendeinem Data-Center in irgendeiner,
kannst du halt zum Thema Performance auch nichts sagen und dann willst du die eigene Hardware haben.
Habe auch schon von größeren deutschen Unternehmen gehört, die so äh klug waren vor Kurzem, mal so ihre Datencenter äh komplett äh Amazon zu verkaufen, so nach dem Motto betreibt das mal für uns. Wir haben davon keine Ahnung
jetzt mal irgendwie als Dienstleistung und die jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen in den Schlund der Datenschutzgrundverordnung,
blicken konnte, überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig unter Kontrolle haben, ob sie denn überhaupt ihre ganzen Police hieß bezüglich Speicherungen, Zugängen und so weiter äh überhaupt noch äh,
richtig aufrecht erhalten können. Das wird noch ganz.
Das wird spannend, äh.
Ich bin sowieso ich freue mich auf die ganzen Abmahnungen, die da verschickt werden. Also das wird das wird aber das irgendwo stand hier auch das nicht stand heute gar nicht auf der Themenliste, ne,
diese ganze Datenschutzverordnung, aber ist auch mega mega juristisches Thema, also aber ich ich glaube, das wird sozusagen so umgekehrtes Abmahnspaß. Also jetzt können die Bürger mal die ganzen Firmen abmahnen und zwar so richtig auch massenweise und ähm das wird.
Das Cloud-Thema mal äh zumachen. Ähm womit machen wir weiter.
Du bist der Moderator, oder.
Du wolltest noch irgendwas erklären.
Nee, ich wollte. Also Letti wollte dann weitermachen. Ich wollte eröffnen.
Genau, lass mal bei der Dennis eröffnen.
Wobei ich weiß nicht, ob's erklären. Bis dann passt nicht ganz, aber ich erzähle trotzdem. Und zwar habe ich meiner Mum, die hat ja meinen alten Mac bekommen,
Die kommt dann natürlich immer an und hat so Fragen, wie sie ihre Bilder sortiert und soweit alles ganz simple Sachen, aber ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich verstehe nichts, was die mir da erzählt,
Also weil sie das nur so erklärt, ohne dass sie am Rechner sitzen, weil sie hat den nicht dabei, ihr Laptop. Und ich kapiere mal nix und dann fiel mir irgendwann mal ein, dass ich äh,
Das irgendwo gesehen habe, dass wenn du, du kannst ja hier so einen Schach Großmeister, deswegen hatte ich vorhin erzählt, hier Carpov oder Casperhof oder jetzt von mir aus Magnus Karlson. Den stellst du 20 Stellungen, berühmte Stellung oder auch nicht so berühmte Stellung, aber zwanzig,
Spiele, die im Laufen Spiel angehalten wurden und die laufen da 5 Minuten lang vorbei, merken sich das. Dann deckst du das zu und dann bauen die das nach. Und das können die so ausm,
ausm Stegreif irgendwie, ne? So, jetzt ist aber der Trick, wenn du den 20,
Schachspiele hinstellst oder Schachbretter mit Positionen, die es nicht so gibt, die man gar nicht so spielen kann oder die keinen Sinn machen
scheitern die wahrscheinlich schon an dem ersten Brett, weil sie das sich einfach nicht merken können. Das heißt, die brauchen auch schon so eine gewisse Logik da auf dem Schachbrett, damit sie sich das einbringen. Da wissen ja alles klar, diese Öffnung war am ersten diese Eröffnung war am zweiten und dann noch so.
Die sie schon mal gelernt.
Die sie schon gelernt haben und die kennen ja alle Muster, aber Muster, die sie nicht gelernt haben, nämlich irgendwelche Positionen, die gar nicht gehen oder die nie so einer spielen würde,
Auch schwer merken und so geht's mir mit meiner Mutter auch, die erklärt halt Sachen, wie ich die halt überhaupt gar nicht machen würde.
Beispiel geben oder geht es auch schon nicht.
Sie sagt dann, ja dann drücke ich da so rechts. Ich meine, ja wie rechts, rechts am Fenster rechts aufm Desktop rechts rechts rechts wo rechts ja auf,
Wir haben das Icon oder das Bild, also äh na das kleine Ding da. Also das weiß, dass es einfach nicht so wie wir das sagen würden und wie wir uns ausdrücken würden und auch der Job, wie sie den macht teilweise, das würden wir auch schon nicht so machen.
Ja. Ohne Terminologie sozusagen.
Genau und äh das fiel mir vorhin ein bei Erklären, aber eigentlich hat es jetzt, ja ihr merkt schon gar nicht so viel mit erklären zu tun, aber sie dürfen jetzt übernehmen.
Ich finde das ganz lustig, weil meine Mama ist auch so ein Kandidat äh eine.
Mamas wahrscheinlich. Ist halt.
Meine nicht äh ehrlich gesagt.
Die erklärt jeder wie der Rechner.
Nee, aber die ist die ist ganz gut äh alleine unterwegs. Vor allen Dingen.
Meine Mum ist auch alleine unterwegs. Die kommt ja klar. Die macht da Sachen, die ich ihr nicht beigebracht habe. Die findet sie von alleine raus. Aber wenn sie mir davon erzählen will, weil sie jetzt wieder mal irgendwo dann doch hängenbleibt, dann verstehe ich sie halt nicht. Darum geht's mir. Also die fummeln sich schon alleine durch da, also das geht schon.
Verwendet nicht dieselbe Terminologie wie Dennis.
Ja na ja bei meiner Mutter ist es so.
Ist. Es geht es um das gesamte Verständnis von sozusagen, was passiert da eigentlich, zum Beispiel sozusagen ich merke das oft,
ich ich mache ja auch Workshops sozusagen, wo ich den Leuten Facebook erklären muss, ja, was also jetzt nicht so auf eurem Niveau, sondern du erstklickst auf erstellen, neuen Beitrag, ja und hier ist lest du Foto, also so auf dem,
der fehlt halt so die Grundverständnisse von was ist ein Desktop, was eine Ordnerstruktur, was ist eine Datei? Also diese diese Grundbegriffe fehlen,
und deswegen äh die merken, die schreiben sich dann eben nicht auf äh Ziel, Datei aus Desktop hoch, sondern die schreiben sich auf eben sozusagen aus dem oberen rechten Bereich des Bildes, wo,
in dem Fall die Screenshots dann automatisch landen bei denen. Äh ziehe, ich verstehe's, also die haben.
Wiederholen eher das, was sie auf dem Bildschirm sehen und nicht das, was so was wir dahinter beschreiben, was passiert so das Ordner aus, Datei ist ja eher was, dass da unten irgendwo passiert und die beschreiben ja aus dem Fenster außerhalb des Fensters gezogen, so ungefähr.
Terminologie, sie haben sie haben halt dieses Grundprinzip User-Interface überhaupt nicht begriffen oder nicht äh mit nicht vermittelt bekommen.
Ich wollte meiner Mutter ja all das erklären, ne, weil sie wenn sie Fotovorführung macht,
macht sie von allen Fotos, die sie zeigen will, macht sie eine Kopie in einen Ordner rein, damit sie diesen Ordner dann zeigen kann,
Mit APFS jetzt eigentlich auch nicht mehr so schlimm, deswegen dachte ich mir, hätte ich eigentlich das das Konzept von Aal lassen ja gar nicht erklären müssen, weil eigentlich hat's sich ja eh erledigt mit APFS, ja weil da ist es ja egal,
Aber ich hab's auch nicht geschafft. Sie hat's nicht nicht so schnell, sie hat's irgendwie nicht verstanden mit den Aliasen, weil das ja wieder so man im echten halt auch nicht abbilden kann, ne, weil im echten kannst du halt nicht mal so eine Kopie von irgendwas machen,
im echten Leben, weil man tickt immer symbolisch, man vergleicht ja mit dem, man zieht eine Analogie mit irgendwas im echten Leben, wenn's denn geht, weil es sehr praktisch, weil das jeder kennt. Aliasse kann man da beim echten Leben keinen Vergleich ziehen und deswegen ja kam das nicht so rüber.
Alias kann man im echten Leben keinen Vergleich ziehen.
Na wenn du eine gute Idee hast, also das ich suche ja immer, wenn man was also wenn du da was hast.
Es ist ja ein ist ein sehr elektronisches Konzept.
Ist ja sehr virtuell so ein Alias, also ist ja eine künstliche Kopien, die sind ja eh schon dass wir da Apfel Drückt und Ukropie am geht ja im echten Leben auch schon nicht so easy.
Neuer Fernseher.
Replikator.
Na ja und Kopierer.
Im Fernsehen hast du ja auch nicht.
Zwei Dateien am Ende äh zwei Elemente am beim Replikator. Da entstehen ja nicht zwei Dateien, sondern das ist eine Datei, die nur an verschiedenen Orten liegt oder die eine Repräsentation an einem.
Wenn wenn du einen Alien machst schon. Wenn du dich wirklich deplizierst.
Der Jan Böhmermann sitzt ja auch nicht in jedem Wohnzimmer, sondern er wird ja sozusagen nur aufm Fernseher als Schatten replizieren.
Das muss meiner Mum mal so erklären.
Reservierung wird gerade vorgeschlagen, finde ich interessant im Chat.
Na jedenfalls war ja das mit dem Alias das das war hier nichts.
Ich sag's ja nur, dass es da steht.
Wird sie das wahrscheinlich demnächst weitermachen, wie sie es macht und deswegen gibt's APFS und das Problem ist gefixt und dann wissen wir jetzt auch, warum das gut ist. Weil ich habe ja schon mal gefragt,
Wozu brauche ich dann dieses APFS-Feature? Weil wann mache ich denn mal eine Kopie von einer Datei? Ja ich mache das nicht, weil es halt auch keinen Sinn macht,
Meine Mum macht das aber schon, also sozusagen APFS ist für meine Mom gemacht.
Amen. Letti, du wolltest was zum erklären.
Das war wahrscheinlich der der Grund auch, warum Apple das
entwickelt hat, weil es so viele Mütter gibt, die bei einem anrufen. Nee, aber bei einem erklären, ich finde, was sie halt auch schon sagte, manchmal fehlt halt so diese gemeinsame Grundlage, über ein Thema zu reden und dann Metaphern zu finden
Also ich finde Metaphern, du hast ja auch gerade gesagt aus dem aus dem Leben sozusagen versuchen zu finden, um etwas Technisches zu erklären,
und ich habe jetzt auch grad wieder eine Vorlesung es ist keine Vorlesung, Vorlesung in dem Sinne, sondern eher so ein Zusammenkommen wenn man Programmieren lernen will,
Zusammen mit einer anderen Kollegin und ich habe heute versucht Grundkonzepte des Programmierens einfach mal so ganz banal, variablen Datenstrukturen, Schleifen,
So conditions und Functions. Und Loops.
Da gibt's Spiele, für die einem das beibringen.
Genau, aber ich wollte.
Human Resource Maschinen, sage ich nur.
Oh Gott, ja das da habe ich auch kurz drangedacht, aber manchmal weiß man halt auch nicht, was den Leuten wirklich weiterhilft und was sie überfordert.
Ja, ist halt auch bei jedem ein bisschen anders, weil es kommt ja immer drauf an, wie weit die Leute schon sind, was sie so kennen, wo man dann drauf aufbauen kann. Ich glaube.
Genau und ich habe so von ich habe schon mal gehört, dass es Programmiersprachen gibt, aber noch keine im echten an mir vorbeilaufen sehen so nach dem Motto und ich habe schon mal irgendetwas zumindest benutzt gehabt. Also wirklich so die Range von
Ich will ähm vielleicht nicht mehr direkt programmieren lernen, sondern eher,
Grundkonzepte verstehen, damit ich dann, wenn ich mit einem Entwickler arbeite, mit ihm reden kann? Also ich arbeite ja hauptsächlich in der Uni mit den Designern zusammen,
einige wollen programmieren wirklich lernen und andere wollen vielleicht einfach nur eine Grundlage haben um eine gemeinsame Kommunikation überhaupt aufbauen zu können was ja ziemlich wichtig ist, wenn man an einem Projekt zusammenarbeitet. Und ich habe halt versucht so Grund,
Beim beim Kunden zu erklären, also wirklich das, was einem selber halt so komplett banal mittlerweile vorkommt. Ja. Ist total logisch,
das stimmt oder das stimmt nicht,
Dann sitzen halt irgendwie Leute und und gucken dann so, ja wie, was heißt das jetzt? Und und was mache ich da und das ist echt wieder.
These. Ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich nicht möglich ist Dinge zu erklären. Also ich glaube, dass sozusagen ist.
Du zerstörst meine Welt.
Na ich glaube nicht, dass es möglich ist, aus meinem Kopf etwas zu nehmen, ein Wissensstand und den in deinen Kopf hineinzupflanzen. Mit Hilfe der Sprache, dafür ist die Sprache für uns unterkomplex.
Aber mit Metaphern kann man's versuchen, auch nicht.
Was einzig hilft ist, du musst es in deinem Kopf neu erfahren, das, was ich dir vielleicht zeige, musst du dann nochmal nachspielen oder nachmachen, sondern Fußball, ne, so lernen wir Fußball, indem wir spielen. Und ähm.
Learning by doing, aber man braucht ja schon ein bisschen Regeln erklärt, dann braucht man auch Tipps, was was geht dann überhaupt und was geht.
Begleitende Spielen würde ich das eher nennen. Also und und.
Ja. Aber es ist doch auch erklärend. Also man hilft dem anderen dabei das zu lernen.
Unterschied, den ich machen will, ist,
die gesamte Schule wie wir sie kennen sozusagen Akademie und aber auch Grundschule und so weiter da da ist das Konzept jemand steht vorne und berichtet,
danach ist das beim Schüler angekommen. Das ist sozusagen die Annahme der der der Schule und ich glaube, dass da ein Missverständnis vorliegt, dass das nicht praktisch eigentlich gar nicht so funktioniert, sondern der der Schüler lernt es erst, wenn er zu Hause vor der Hausaufgabe sitzt,
Und dann sagt shit, das geht ja gar nicht. So oder wie wie so und dann fängt er an.
Äh hallo, ich habe nie Hausaufgaben gemacht.
Es gibt Ausnahmen, aber ähm sozusagen, erst wenn du's selber machst und das ist vielleicht auch für die Universitäten, deswegen glaube ich ja nicht mehr das Konzept von Universitäten. Eines der Hauptprobleme, dass sie sozusagen gerade im in der Vermittlung von IT sozusagen ähm Lernerfahrung, die du selber machen musst
versuchen über eine Vorlesung zu vermitteln und besser wäre sozusagen,
äh du in deiner Vorlesung jetzt, Lady, müsstest sozusagen die Leute äh sagen programmiert das jetzt mal und ich gebe euch hier ein Set an Werkzeugen zur Hand,
versucht es mal und guckt wie dann können die Leute sich melden und eine Frage stellen. Also so rum haben sie sozusagen sind sie dann eher gezwungen diesen Lernerfahrungen, die du schon gemacht hast für dich selber nachzuvollziehen? Also sozusagen als Grundannahme, ne? Ähm,
Ich weiß noch nicht äh sozusagen, ob das es ist halt länger und das dauert es komplizierter,
In meinen Workshops, wenn ich äh irgendeine ähm irgendetwas erzählen will über Social Media, obwohl das noch,
mal Banane ist, als das, was du unterrichtest,
gemerkt, dass ich den Leuten,
das super erklären kann, aber es es wird einfach nicht verstanden, bis du es machst. Es ist der Moment in dem Workshop, wo immer sozusagen, wo ich sage, so jetzt klappen eure eure Laptops auf. Ich habe dann so eine Online-Software, mit denen ich wohl mit die Bilder gestalten und wenn sie plötzlich wie,
Wie schreibst du das? Welches Bildmotiv wählst du aus? Das ist der Moment, wo sie anfragen,
Konzept gehe ich eigentlich vor und wo sie sich dann Gedanken machen und dann können sie auch das, was ich ihnen vorher erzählt habe, teilweise verwenden,
Es ist ja nicht ganz so, dass es alles unnütz ist, aber da erst beginnt der Lernprozess und und das kommt oft zu kurz, leider in Universitäten und und überall auch sonst in unserem Bildungswesen bisher.
Das würde ja bedeuten, dass man nur Dinge verstehen kann, die man auch selber zur Anwendung bringen kann. Ich meine, so kann ich's jetzt
B. Gravitationswellen äh könnte ich dir auf diese Art und Weise halt dann nicht näher bringen. Trotzdem würde ich mir äh einbilden äh wenn ich genug Zeit äh äh von dir zugestanden bekomme
dass ich dir an einem Abend äh zumindest meinen Kenntnisstand da drüber äh umfangreich ins Hirn pressen könnte, so dass auch
was hängen bleibt.
Meine These wäre, dass sozusagen in dem Moment, in dem ich ähm versuche dann jemand Dritten zu erklären, was du mir beigebracht hast, dann erst verfestigt sich das Wissen bei mir.
Das ist ohnehin so.
Das ist der Lernprozess, von dem ich dann wirklich spreche sozusagen, aber,
ich passiv sitze und nur mir gesagt wird versackt 80 bis 90 Prozent des Wissens und das ist sozusagen auf die Mauer, auf die du stößt, glaube ich Latina.
Du würdest ja unter Umständen auch helfen, dass man die Leute sozusagen so versucht so weit zu bringen, dass sie in der Lage sind, die äh also dass sozusagen der praktische Teil darin bestehen, dass anderen Leuten.
Das stimmt, das ist eine.
Brauchen andere Lernkonzep.
Also genau heute war das halt für mich so ähm von vornherein gar nicht so auf eine spezielle Sprache fokussiert, weil ich einfach mal,
noch mal so eine Art wie so ein Input von den Konzepten hergeben wollte, weil mir eben in der ersten Vorlesung, die ich gegeben habe, da kam irgendwie so was die Frage wie ja wie kann ich mir denn eine Iteration vorstellen,
Also dass sie mit diesen Begriffen noch nicht wussten umzugehen und ich habe halt heute wirklich so versucht, so eine Grundlage zu schaffen, dass sie wissen, auch welche Begriffe sie zum Beispiel googeln müssen. Weil das ist ja auch so ein Ding, wenn du was du bei bei Neulingen so beim Kurden häufig,
äh merkst so, sie wissen so irgendwie, wo sie hinwollen, aber die Begrifflichkeit fehlt grad noch,
Dass ich ihn einfach so eine Art so ein bisschen äh mitgeben konnte und aber halt gleichzeitig dann auch nicht nur hm ich sage mal Pseudocode gezeigt habe, sondern nebenbei irgendwie so eine äh Jahreskrippel aufgehabt habe,
Um das irgendwie kurz zu zeigen, wie verhalten sich denn irgendwie Iterationen? Was heißt nach.
Ähm inkrementelles und dekrementelles Itterieren und einfach so Conditions so ein bisschen gezeigt. Ähm und da haben sie dann halt auch wirklich so,
Klar, da haben Sie jetzt nicht mitgemacht und das ist vielleicht auch ein Fehler gewesen. Ähm,
Da haben sie schon mal so ein bisschen was gesehen und halt auch in der Tat Fragen gestellt. Also nicht nur so gut du kannst bei einer Gruppe von 20 Leuten auch wissen, dass nur fünf Fragen stellen und.
Aber das ist eine guter guter Hinweis. Das werde ich wahrscheinlich einfach bei den nächsten zwei äh Themenkomplexen machen, dass ich denen ein bisschen was vorgebe,
Und ähm die einfach rumspielen sollen.
Rumspielen, dialogisch und ähm Dennis, das ist letztlich auch der Grund, warum du sozusagen diesen Diskursproblem in deiner Mutter hast, dass eben sie nicht sozusagen den Prozess nachfühlen kann. Verstehst du? Wenn den.
Ich kann ja Ihren Prozess nicht davon, es geht so rum, also.
Nee, nee, ja, aber weil weil du nicht in ihrer Welt,
und sie nicht in deiner und in dem Moment, in dem ihr gemeinsam vorm PC sitzt, habt ihr.
Ja, das, ja, ja, auf jeden.
Ihr dann dieses gemeinsame Erfahrungsbild habt und.
Das ist schon klar. Es ging ja nur darum, wenn Sie was erklären muss, ohne dass Sie da am Rechner sitzen, wenn Sie dem mir das zeigt, dann verstehe ich das ja auch.
Rache ist so überschätzt. Also vom vom dem, was sie transportieren kann. Nee, wirklich, aber es ist ja so, ich habe vor kurzem ähm oder gestern, um genau zu sein, habe ich.
Das sagst du in einem Podcast Mann.
Worauf ich hinaus will. Ich habe gestern ein tolles Video gesehen von einer alten Schulfreundin von mir, die jetzt äh Achtung nicht gleich weggelaufen für die CDU in einem lokalen Wahlkampf kandidiert, ne? Und die haben ein ganz schreckliches äh,
Video gemacht, also wir haben ein Video gemacht, sagen wir's mal so,
und ähm in diesem Video haben sie sowieso typische schlechte Wahlkampfvideos in Kommunalpolitik eben sind, haben sie so,
Wörter eingeblendet, Digitalisierung, Annehmen, äh Wirtschaft die Region entwickeln, so so,
Schlagwörter halt so.
Platitüden heißt das, oder.
Und ja genau und was aber sozusagen wirkt, ist,
gesamte restliche Videos hat eine wahnsinnig, also jedes Video hat also da sind Menschen, die sich ja zeigen in irgendeiner Art und Weise und die Inszenierung,
tausend Bände. Ja, also der der eine Typ und das waren so vier Leute, die im Video der stand da wie so ein Aristokrat im im 15. Jahrhundert mit so einer Körperhaltung, äh die sozusagen, wo er die die Beine auf den äh die die Arme auf den Beinen abstützt,
Im Hintergrund lief so ähm klassische Musik aber mit so einem äh Titanic Soundtrack so,
Kommunalwahlkampf, ne? Offen irgendwo im Lande. Und es ist so vollkommen abgehoben,
So, ja, also so wirklich nicht so, ey Leute, stellt euch da einfach, ihr seid doch das sollen übrigens die jungen Leute in der CDU sein, also die, die unter 40 sind, also es waren jetzt die vier Jungen und ich so, ey,
Denkt doch mal darauf, wie das wirkt auf andere. Ja, wir sind doch jetzt in der YouTube und Instagram-Zeit, ihr könnt euch einfach nur hinstellen und sagen, hey, wir sind die und die
Machen das und das und dafür stehen wir ein. Total like mit einer ganz normalen Klamotten oder setzt euch auf ein Sofa, äh was auch immer, aber und wir hatten dann so Drohnenflug ja, so ein Drohnenflug. Ich meine, es fancy, aber und es kam dann so von oben so runter.
Ich würde mal sagen, das war vor wie bei dir vorhin nämlich die hat ein Budget.
Die hatten ein Budget, aber ähm was sie was ich sagen will, ist ähm dieses Video hat sehr viel darüber ausgesagt, wer die sind und ob er alles nicht durch Sprache, sondern sozusagen durch,
Unterschätzen immer sozusagen, was unsere Körper verraten, was unsere Gesichter verraten und,
Ist auch so ein bisschen meine These, warum im Internet so viel Hass und und und gegenseitiger Argwohnen herrschen, warum wir auf Twitter uns ständig streiten, weil weil sozusagen diese ganze Körpersprache, unsere Gestik weg ist,
nutze auch grade meine Hände während ich spreche, obwohl das völlig absurd ist. Ähm,
weil weil sozusagen ähm wir dass wir die Menschen nicht sehen und wir so eine Intention deshalb nicht erahnen können. Wir sehen nur den Text, den er schreibt,
Der Text ist eine ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz stark verkürzte Sache. Sprache ist ganz und wir wir Menschen nehmen ganz viele wahr aus aus Körperhaltung, aus,
Kleidung aus allem drumherum. Und das ist eigentlich schade, dass das das Medium Internet sozusagen so begrenzt ist in in seiner,
Präsentation. Deswegen sind ja auch Emoticons und und Smileys und und und diese ganzen.
So wichtig, weil das da so ein bisschen zurückbringt.
Weil das plötzlich so einen Kontext gibt wieder und und man.
Deswegen sind Podcasts so wichtig.
Podcasts sind toll, weil da hat man die Stimmlage, nicht der Text ist hier entscheidend, sondern die Stimmlage ist das, was sozusagen, also wenn als Tim vorhin sein Rant abgegeben hat, war nicht der der Text, den er gesagt hat relevant, sondern die Stimmlage war.
Nee, die stimmen Lautstärke vor.
Die Lautstärke war das, was sozusagen am meisten äh die eigentliche Botschaft, die er hat.
Schnappatmung.
Ja ja genau. Also das ist halt so ein bisschen.
Das ist auch der Grund äh wenn ich jetzt immer erkläre warum ich immer noch, ich gucke auf Netflix so eine spanische Serie, warum ich die,
Genau, warum ich die tatsächlich in Spanisch gucke, mit deutschen, ja mit deutschen Untertiteln,
weil ich halt äh was die Synchronsprecher die sind schon gut, aber die sind halt lange nicht
gut wie der spanische Schauspieler. Da ist halt eben auch die Sprache, dass Atmen, dass wie schnell, langsam laut die sprechen, das kommt halt in der Übersetzung, also in einer Synchronisation kommt das einfach nicht rüber, deswegen gucke ich das lieber in Spanisch
äh mit deutschen Untertiteln,
Viel mehr Emotionen in der Sprache, ich lerne noch den den spanischen Flow lerne ich auch gleich noch, also wie man halt sowas also das äh nicht, dass ich jetzt Spanisch lernen würde, aber.
Das so spricht.
Italienisch.
Panisch aus einem Buch lernen und wüsste schon, hatte schon so eine Ahnung, wie man's dann aussprechen würde,
die sagen nicht, die sagen nicht absolut wie der Schwede, die sagen immer klaro.
Bei äh Narkoss ist mir das aufgefallen. Hast du.
Habe ich wieder einen Ohrwurm. Ja den Bella tschau.
Ciao, bella ciao, bella ciao ciao, egal äh.
Zum Thema erklären.
Nur empfehlen, die Serie gut.
Genau, weil zwei Leute auch grad noch sagten, also der äh eine Person meinte im Chap äh Chat gerade, Kochrezepte sind super. Oh, das habe ich auch gehört und habe dann mir gedacht, so ja, schreiben wir doch so als Abschluss einen Algorithmus, wie man Pancakes kocht,
ein bisschen länger geworden und ich habe ihn heute jetzt noch nicht gemacht, weil ich dachte so oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, nicht, dass ich die Leute verschrecke mit so einem simplen Kochrezept in Form eines Algorithmus und dachte dann so, oh je,
Bisher nächste Woche.
Rezepte sind übrigens ein schöner Einstieg in den Zusammenhang.
Du kennst die Programmiersprache Chef, ne? Da formuliert man alle Programme wie ein Kochrezept.
Das davon habe ich gehört. Ja.
Chef heißt die.
Was heißt das? Was also was wie formuliert man das dann? Muss man dann irgendwie eine.
Greediance.
Eine Prise Witz.
Geil.
Ja, du du deklarierst deine Variablen wie Zutaten. Zwei Eier, fünfhundert.
Oh ist das geil.
Besser Spitzerahmen.
Dann kannst du halt angeben, was tust du wo rein und das.
Welcher Reihenfolge bei wie viel Grad.
5 schmelzen.
Geil, ich schreibe den nochmal um,
Hammer. Genau nach so was habe ich gesucht. Geil, danke. Ja? Perfekt.
Also das auch ist auch mehr so eine esoterische Programmiersprache, weil sie glaube ich.
Jetzt nicht drauf gekommen.
Nicht so ernst gemeint ist.
Ja, das ist äh ich finde das jetzt nicht so schlimm, weil ich habe einfach nur ich wollte den halt auch so ein bisschen zeigen,
wie man.
Die nicht ernst gemeint ist und nicht funktioniert als eine Sprache, die ernst gemeint ist und nicht funktioniert.
Vatikan.
Ich wollte den Leuten einfach nur ein bisschen zeigen, wie man so an Probleme herangeht oder wie man Probleme auf,
ähm Teile runterbrechen kann und habe denen halt auch ähm ein großartiges Video von extrakredit gezeigt, äh wenn ich das noch auf die Schnelle finde, wo sie äh also Extracredits sind ja eigentlich mehr Richtung Gendesign
Gebende seiner die verschiedene Themen,
aufarbeiten und unter anderem haben sie zwei Folgen zu äh wie man also was man als Entwickler so macht und äh wie man als Entwickler denkt, die ich ganz cool fand ähm,
Hier habe ich den meinen Mädels heute quasi gezeigt.
Also ich für mich ist ja erklären ein Hobby,
Weiß nicht, wie's euch geht, aber ich äh kann den Zustand, was nicht zu nicht zu erklären, also wenn ich versuche etwas zu erklären und es gelingt mir nicht,
Das ist das geht nicht. Das ist das trifft mich tief so und ähm von daher,
bin ich da etwas optimistischer, als du vielleicht so, dass man schon mit Sprache äh was erreichen kann? Die Frage ist halt nur ähm redet man überhaupt über das Richtige,
So, weil das,
Hauptproblem beim Erklären meiner Auffassung nach ist, dass die Leute halt viel zu sehr von der eigenen Gedankenwelt in der eigenen Gedankenstruktur ausgehen und äh sich dabei eben nicht an die vorherrschende Gedankenstruktur des Gegenübers anpassen,
Sage ich nicht, dass das leicht ist oder dass das auf jeden Fall immer gelingen kann, aber dass es zumindest die Methode, mit der ich relativ viel Erfolg oder glaube zumindest viel Erfolg äh zu haben, indem ich halt immer zunächst einmal versuche zu verstehen, warum,
man eigentlich etwas nicht versteht.
Ja das ist ja das Wichtigste beim Erklären, oder? Moos ja finden, auf welchem Level er sich schon befindet, das wird man dadran anbauen kann.
Glaube ich glaube, was Tim was du gut machst in deinen äh Podcasts äh,
warum du erfolgreich bist, ist dass du es schaffst Bilder zu finden, die ähm sozusagen etwas
Also du hast Gäste, wie du gerade gesagt hast, die in ihrer Welt sind und du versuchst, äh sie zu zwingen, in in Bildern zu sprechen, ähm die sozusagen andere wiederum verstehen kann, also so eine Art Transfer zu machen
Was ich eigentlich vorhin sagen wollte, ist nicht, dass ich nicht an Sprache oder Wörter glaube sozusagen, sondern dass ich nicht daran glaube, dass sozusagen ähm,
einfach nur die Vorlesen eines Wikipedia Textes dazu führt, dass sozusagen eine beliebige Person sich das Wissen aneignen kann, sondern man muss sich ähm äh von dem von den abstrakten Begriffen
ein bisschen entfernen und sozusagen das Runterbrechen auf den jeweiligen Wissens und Realitätsstand, auf die
ähm auf die ja Bildsprache, die diese Person äh sitzt schon, ne? Wie gesagt, Dennis Mutter finde ich sozusagen so ein wirklich super Beispiel dafür, weil sie eben ganz viele von diesen Begriffen und und Vorstellungsformen von von was ein PC es nicht kennt
und eben,
Die andere Stärke, die du hast ist, du hast ähm immer spannende Gäste, die sozusagen aus einem Wissenschaftsbereich kommen und die dann auch mit ihrer ähm mit ihrer Leidenschaft oft in in diesen Podcasts erzählen, ja, also keine Ahnung irgendwie, ob das dieser.
Podcast war zum Thema Kaffeebohnen wo wo die seine Frau irgendwie über diese
Katzen die den Kaffeebohnen auskacken oder so ja und das hat sie mit so einer Freude erzählt. Das ist auch eine Freude ist da zuzuhören und und ihre persönliche
lebens Philosophie bringt sie da mit rein und das macht dann sozusagen diese sonst eventuell trockene Fakt ist ein dass eine Katze,
Kaffeebohne verdaut, bevor man sie konsumiert äh sozusagen plötzlich witzig, spannend und erlebbar. Und dann kann man das auch aufnehmen.
Ja. Wobei das ja jetzt eine andere ähm quasi andere Richtung ist, ne, weil man ja an der Stelle verstehe ich mich ja mehr als Katalysator äh und ich muss halt oder als Transformator
Hinsicht. Das erklärt vielleicht auch, warum ich an dieser Sprache XXL T so viel Spaß habe, weil XXL T ist ja sozusagen äh von der Einverständniswelt in die andere Verständniswelt äh transformieren,
das ist ja eine andere Art des des des Denkens über Programmieren ein deklarativer Programmiermethode
die eben sozusagen das Verständnis der beiden Ein- und Ausgangsstrukturen äh voraussetzt und darüber dann eben über Muster äh eine Verbindung zu
schaffen und das äh spielt vielleicht eher noch das wieder, was man in so einer Interviewsituation hat, weil man ja da quasi dann für Leute denken muss, die man ja gar nicht sieht
Also es äh nochmal eine eine besondere Härte. Aber so in im im unmittelbaren Dialog denke ich ähm muss man halt einfach Zeit investieren,
und was ihr einfach oft festgestellt habt bei Leuten, die anderen versuchen vergeblich etwas zu erklären, der Kernfehler, den sie machen, ist, sie hören einfach nicht zu,
glaube damit kann man schon mal 80 Prozent aller äh Probleme äh schon mal lösen, wenn ihr irgendwie das Gefühl habt euch verstehen die Leute nicht, vielleicht hört ihr ihnen nicht genug zu und das könnte äh.
Nachfragen, wenn man mal was nicht versteht. Also das geht auch,
nicht. Wenn man dann so ja ja, nickt, also nach.
Das merkst du aber auch
Wenn du ein guter Erklärer bist, dann dann merkst du auch, ob der das jetzt überhaupt wissen will oder nicht. Weil wenn da kein Feedback zurückkommt, dann dann geht das nur rein und aufm anderen Ohr wieder raus. Also erklären, das finde ich auch immer auch so ein bisschen interaktiv immer so ein bisschen gegenchecken, den anderen irgendwie mal auch.
Aber da kann man aber auch gegenwirken, weil manchmal ist das ja nur so eine eine Verzweiflung, so dieses oh Gott, ich verstehe's eh nicht. Fünf Leute haben schon probiert mir das zu sehen, ich bin ja zu doof dazu. Das ist nicht meine Welt und was man nicht alles immer so hört so, ne? Und äh auch da kann man glaube ich was dagegen tun
indem man,
Gut, das ist jetzt eine sehr psychologische Geschichte, hat erstmal was mit zuhören, auch wieder zu tun. Ähm aber man muss dann vielleicht auch erst mal rausfinden, okay was,
Was sind denn Dinge, die dir gelingen? Was sind Bereiche, in in denen du dich wohlfühlst und in denen du deine Erfolge hast? So,
aus diesen Bereichen und das kann irgendwas sein, ja, was weiß ich versucht, Computer zu erklären, aber das mit einer Person zu tun, die eigentlich nur aus Sport,
irgendwie was ziehen kann. Dann versuche ich meine Metaphern möglichst aus diesem positiv besetzten Feld.
Dieser Person quasi naheliegt und wo sozusagen allein die Erwähnung von und wenn du dann die Hürde übersprungen hast und wenn du irgendwie deinen Marathon abgeschlossen hast,
So was so und dann aber die Anstrengung irgendwie und dann diese,
Kilometer fünf, wenn die Maschine noch nicht so richtig warm ist, also
irgendwie in irgendwas, das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel, ja, in irgendwas eintauchen, wo schon positive Konnotationen, äh Erfahrungen und äh äh Erfolgserlebnisse sind,
Und da äh anzudecken äh anzudocken, um dann irgendwie daraus vielleicht auch seine Metaphern äh zu ziehen, um da erst mal so kleine äh Schritte bereit zu machen.
Ja, man kann alles erklären. Wenn jemand das zu schwer ist, dann braucht man vielleicht ein bisschen bisschen länger zum erklären, aber eigentlich müsste das immer gehen.
Ja, aber.
Das Zuhören ist auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig, dass man weiß, wo der andere ist, was er nicht versteht und und dann kann man da nochmal genau nachhaken.
Aber genau das, was Tim auch grad sagte mit dem vielleicht auch sich nicht trauen oder sozusagen, ja nee,
Ich programmiere eh nicht, habe ich jetzt halt auch irgendwie einmal gesagt bekommen, wo ich mir dachte so, na ja, also ich kann dir jetzt nur so bedingt Hilfe geben im Sinne von ich kann dir Dinge erklären, ich kann dir Hilfestellung im im Sinne von,
welche Webseiten gibt es, die dir deine Fragen vielleicht auch erklären können beziehungsweise wo du auch programmieren, vielleicht auf einer besseren Art und Weise lernst als in einem Kurs,
Aber ich kann Sie auch nur anbieten jemandem und
wenn ich dann so dieses höre, ja naja ich programmiere ja gar nicht, dann denke ich mir auch so, na ja, also du musst es halt auch schon selber machen, wie halt auch schon irgendjemand im Chat, sagte so, es ist halt so ein,
Was oder du auch grad sagtest, man kann nicht nur zuhören, man muss selber ausprobieren und rumspielen und auch mal ordentlich frustriert sein, wenn man was Neues lernt,
Genau, bist dann wirklich mal so der Sweet Spot oder der Süßpunkt, wie Rolli vorhin sagte,
an denen die Sachen halt auch funktionieren und man endlich merkt so geil, ich hab's geschnallt. Und das ist
Das ist halt auch irgendwie schwierig, weil ich beziehe das gerade halt total häufig auf mich als äh Lehrkörper, wie man so schön sagt. Wenn jemand eben so gefühlt aus der Vorlesung dann geht und sagt, ja nee hier, der nichts eh nix mehr oder denke ich mir halt so, ja habe
ich jetzt irgendwas falsch gemacht oder ähm kann die Person vielleicht einfach in so einer Umgebung auch nur nicht lernen. Also es ist halt auch.
Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass ich zum Beispiel in Mathe in der Schule schon immer so gut war, nicht weil ich so gut war, sondern weil ich das Glück hatte, dass ich sie sowohl in der Grundschule als auch in der Oberschule einen guten Mathelehrer hatte.
Oder es ist sehr viel wert. Ich hatte einen furchtbar schlechten.
Meiner war sehr lustig.
Oh Gott, jetzt kommt die Materie.
Meiner war auch noch Sportlehrer.
Er hatte einfach ein herausragenden Humor. Mein Englischlehrer im Übrigen auch.
Mein Mathelehrer hat äh ich war super schlecht in Mathe. Äh passt jetzt zu meinem Gesamtbild und ähm der hat mir irgendwann aus Frust in der gesamten Klasse sozusagen irgendwie das Heft auf den Tisch,
knallt und irgendwie Sebastian, du wirst es nie lernen und dieses ganze Internet-Scheiße, die du machst, das hat keine Zukunft,
Matian,
Ich hätte ihn so gerne heute angerufen und gesagt.
Oder vor drei Jahren schon.
Vor drei Jahren schon. Ich lerne ich ich lebe davon sogar von dem Internet scheiße. Leider ist ja.
Wie wie alt bist du, dass dein Mathelehrer vom Internet erzählen konnte.
Also was, wie alt ich bin.
Ja, das ist dein Mathelehrer von Internet erzählen kann.
Na ich ich bin ja fünfunddreißig. Ähm also ich bin ich bin,
eins noch zur Schule gegangen, also zum Gymnasium und ähm da war das da war das ja der große Hype, ne und so weiter und und irgendwie ich hatte damals Lahn-Partys organisiert so und deswegen war ich so ein bisschen da in der Schule halt auch irgendwie,
so eine Personality auf auf also man kannte mich sozusagen, also es war mit.
Internet geil.
Ja ja es war halt so dieser Internettyp, dieser Verrückte ähm,
Ja. Ich habe wer ist denn meine Lieblingsstory aus der Schulzeit ist, dass ich äh meine Abiturabschlussarbeit, das sind ja so sechs Stunden, wo man dann nur so sitzt, ne? Da habe ich den Rektor gefragt, ob ich den nicht am Laptop schreiben könnte, was damals sozusagen so also,
vollkommen out of the order. Es gab's halt, also es gab weder Computer noch eben Laptops an dieser Schule.
Heutzutage sind ja sogar Taschenrechner erlaubt, ne.
Ja und ich habe nee, ich hatte eine deutsch-leistungs äh Arbeit und ähm meine Handschrift war so schlecht, dass ich gesagt habe, ich würde lieber am Rechner schreiben,
dann die Word automatische Wordkorrektur ausschalten,
Und ähm und um dann natürlich das Endergebnis, das musst du ja, das kann ich ja nicht nach Hause nehmen und dann der Lehrerin per E-Mail schicken oder so. Oh, gesehen davon sind sie keine E-Mail hatte. Ähm,
Also habe ich einen Laserdrucker mit in die Schule gebracht, was dann,
sozusagen, also den hat die dann in so einem Jutebeutel noch mit mit dabei und als ich dann äh also die anderen Schmidtschüler wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt nichts und als ich angefangen habe mein Laptop aufzuklappen und meinen Laserdrucker neben mir aufzubauen, da waren die
Augen sozusagen so auf mich gerichtet hat, so what the fuck is man from the futures ähm,
2tausendeins, zweitausendzwei, zweitausend ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wann ich Abitur gemacht habe, aber so um die Zeit, ja. Also es war halt eigentlich eigentlich albern. Da gab's schon alles, aber es war halt noch in der Schule nicht angekommen. Es ist ja leider
Ich frage immer meine Nichte und die sagt so, ich sag's nicht, ja was habt ihr denn so alles, ne? Na wieso ein Zettel und Stift nicht so wie immer noch, also ist immer noch keine Laptops angekommen in der Schule. Es ist ja also.
In Costa Rica gab's übrigens oder in Nicaragua ganz groß Werbung für vielleicht sollte dann das mal auch mal hier einführen.
Ich hatte ich hatte einen Grundschullehrer, der also er hatte Matheunterricht, der der hatte echt einen extremen Weitblick. Man muss sozusagen, das waren Siebziger, ne? Da hat er,
uns. Erstens mal, da gab's halt so rechnen auf anderen Zahlen, Basen. Wurde da irgendwie geleert, die ganzen Parallelklassen hatten irgendwie auf Fünferbasis, auf Dreierbasis, auf siebener Basis sonst was gemacht. Wir hatten nur binär,
So mit uns nur binär gemacht und dann.
Zweierbasis.
Erste Zweierbasis.
Tim wäre auf ihn sehr stolz gewesen.
Und dann hat er vor allen Dingen auch sehr viel Mengenleere gemacht und hat die Mengenleere halt auch so gemacht, dass du hinterher auch Bullshi Operatoren verstehst
Also es war halt und das in der dritten Klasse. Das war halt irgendwie auch total genial. Und der Typ, der war aber schon, keine Ahnung
glaube ich den Weltkrieg noch mitgemacht. Irgendwie äh super alt, aber der hat diesen extremen Weitblick gehabt. Das hat ja echt lang, lang gedauert, bis sie's gemerkt habe.
Irgendwie leider immer nur schlecht, nicht so gute Mathelehre, also bis zum Abi dann gehabt. Ähm,
was nie so ein gutes Verhältnis ist, wenn man sein Sportlehrer auch als Mathelehrer hat und man vorzugsweise gerne nicht zum Sportunterricht geht und wenn man da da ist, nur seine Eins mal eben mitnimmt,
wieder abzuhauen. Es kommt auch nicht so gut beim Mathelehrer an. Das hat sich immer so ein bisschen ausgewirkt.
Also stellen wir jetzt fest, ich bin eine einzige schlechte Matheschüler an dem Tisch hier, oder.
Ich auch gewesen und mein ja ich finde Mathe nie wirklich gut gewesen.
Mitgenommen.
In Sport, nicht in Mathe,
Aber deswegen hat er mich halt auch gehasst und hat das auch so ein bisschen dann auch in einen in einem Matheunterricht mitgenommen. Das war irgendwie nicht so eine gute Kombi und selbst noch in der Uni,
Weiß nicht, ich kann damit Formeln nicht so gut. Ich habe dann irgendwann mal zu meinem Matheproff gemeint, ich so, ja, also wenn das hier alles nicht in Formeln wäre, sondern Pseudocode fände ich das total klasse,
so die Augen gerollt, weil ich bei ihm auch formale Sprachenautomaten hatte und das fand ich halt leicht,
das geht nicht, du fällst mir halb durch Mathe durch und geh durch ähm Automaten kommst du irgendwie einfach,
so mit dem Fingerschnipp, versteht er nicht und es war ziemlich lustig,
Aber Mathe war auch, wie gesagt, durch die Formeln immer so ein bisschen. Ist nicht meine Notation.
Ich kann dich übrigens beruhigen, also Mathe Abi habe ich ein bisschen Probleme gehabt. Das.
Beruhigt mich überhaupt gar nicht.
So so einfach.
Minderwertigkeitskomplexe größten Ausmaßes an diesem Tisch, aber das ist okay, muss ich durch.
Ich habe noch Realschule bleibt ganz locker. Siehste.
Ja, aber ich habe auch ähm.
Ich meine, nichtsdestotrotz stellst du alle den Schatten hier, aber ist auch.
Nee. Nee.
Schulbildung glaube ich eh nicht so richtig dran. Also zum Beispiel wenn ich einen Mitarbeiter einstelle und mir die dann ihre Zeugnisse zuschicken, dann denke ich immer so hä was willst du? Geh weg. Also ich will nicht deine.
Mit mir.
Ich will nicht deine Zeugnisse haben. Was hast du denn außerhalb der Schule gemacht? Also das ist halt äh aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich da.
Projekte gemacht, hast du selber mal was gemacht? Äh ja genau.
Ja irgendwas, irgendwas.
Telefoninterview spätestens einer halben Stunde, ist alles klar.
Ich hatte auch irgendwie immer den Eindruck, ich meine, ich habe ich habe Abitur, aber ist auch eher, glaube ich, äh ich glaube ein Jahr später und ich hätte auch kein Abitur.
Schon zu alt war und so schon zu viel Scheiß gemacht.
Weil weil mein Leben geriet aus den Fugen irgendwie so langsam und geriet aber nicht schnell genug aus den Fugen damit noch das Abitur verhindert werden konnte,
Also ich habe schon mein Jahr vorher schon schon versucht, wollte ich irgendwie von der Schule weg. Keine Ahnung, ich wusste gar nicht, was ich wollte, aber ich wollte nur irgendwie Rebellion. Und ähm dann habe ich dann trotzdem einfach dieses Abitur gemacht, auch nicht besonders gut irgendwie mit
2 ,5 oder so im Schnitt und dann,
die hatte ich dann auch irgendwie schnauzvoll. Dann bin ich da zwar trotzdem nochmal kurz auf einer Universität gelandet, weil mich meine Freunde bequatscht haben, also irgendwie meinten, ich müsste jetzt mit ihnen mitgehen so, aber dann habe ich mir das halt angeschaut, das Elend, dachte mir nur so,
Sorry, aber nee.
Ich hätte glaube ich auch weder äh weder Schulabschluss noch Uniabschluss ohne meine Mutter, die mich halt sozusagen irgendwie da gepeitscht hat, moralisch äh ich ich.
Feiner Herr.
Nee, ja, ich meine, man man ähm was was mit Muttern, ne, Mütter haben großen Einfluss. Aber äh ich fand das halt, also wer in der Schulzeit habe ich so viel Unsinn gemacht, dass ich halt ähm,
Ja äh Schule echt nur so nebenbei gemacht habe. Also das war so das Ding, wo man am Vormittag abgehangen war und dann ging's los,
Ich habe ich war damals schon Chefredakteur eines Onlineportals mit sehr vielen Lesern und und äh musste und ich habe sozusagen so nebenbei während des Unterrichts schon so ein bisschen nochmal gecheckt, was die Kommentare machen und so, also.
Ja
Habe ich auch gemacht. Das war bei sechsundneunzig.
Stimmt, du hast doch diese wie hieß denn noch eure Macintosh.
Punktseite.
Punkt Seite. Ich habe mich auch eine Weile getragen, irgendwie sowas zu starten, habe ich dann aber trotzdem nicht gemacht, obwohl ich schon einen Namen hatte.
Spaß gemacht. Dann kam ja hier Mac, wie heißen die, Mac Gadget oder so, diese deutschen Dinger? Gibt's die immer noch? Ja, ne? Die kamen dann so auf und haben da auch mehrere Manpower reingesteckt und haben mich dann überflügelt, aber ich war die Erste. Also,
Ja ja, also sechsundneunzig. Da gab's sowieso nix. Ich will online. Meint und und ich,
Ich war ich habe meins auch nur gefunden. Mac, äh Mac Mac Rumors geklaut damals,
Und habe das ins Deutsch übersetzt, plus so wie ich jetzt hier bei der Sendung meinen Stuff einbringe, habe ich da dann auch, was ich so sowieso so rausfinde,
noch so ein bisschen mit mit reingeklebt, aber das das lief.
Pirat von von Beginn an.
Sind ja nur News gewesen, die kann man ja klauen.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe ähm also Schule auch irgendwie so als überflüssig empfunden und hält auch fast gar nicht äh mich fürs Abi beworben, weil ich auch nur Realschule am Anfang gemacht.
Mir fehlt einfach die Motivation, da mich groß irgendwie anzustrengen, jetzt schief man's, da gab's keine.
Genau und aber das hat sich halt im im Studium komplett gewandelt, weil da habe ich halt Informatik studiert und Informatik ist geil,
Und da habe ich also wirklich das erste Mal gemerkt so ja er ist halt genau das was ich will und dann kann ich mich reinhören,
das stört's kein, wenn ich das Wochenende die Sonne an mir vorbeiziehen sehe und programmiere.
Und dann zocken bist.
Ich weiß nicht, also.
Wie bist du, du arbeitest jetzt in deiner Uni weiterhin? Also dir gefällt grundsätzlich das Uni-Leben.
Das ist gut, aber nicht auf Dauer. Also mir fehlt auch so ein bisschen ein größeres Team mit den Informatikern, mit Informatik Hintergrund.
Also mit Profis und nicht mit Studenten meinst du.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich meine, ich habe in meinem Team sehr viele ähm Designer,
Und also so Interface zu sein sehr viel, was total großartig ist, um als Entwickler mal einen die Designperspektive richtig kennenzulernen und die Zusammenarbeit wertzuschätzen,
Aber es fehlt mir dann so mal an einigen Stellen der der Austausch mit anderen, die halt auch mehr ich sage mal Hardcore-Cola sind, einfach mit denen ich mich mal unterhalten.
Machte dann mehr Spaß, Design oder Kurden.
Ich mache gar kein Design. Das ist ja der Punkt. Ähm also Design mache ich gar nicht. Ich mache ein bisschen Fronten-CS, wenn's sein muss,
bin immer ziemlich froh, wenn ich's nicht machen muss ähm und bin jetzt auch eher sogar, dass dass ich eben so backend und server mich gerade sehr viel mehr flasht, weil ich's einfach irgendwie spannend finde und was ich eben auch gerade meinte mit so verteiltes Rechnen,
finde ich jetzt auch nicht unspannend,
Und grad so in der Visualisierung sehe ich halt so das Potenzial, dass du eben die Möglichkeit hast, auch so was zu machen, wo du nicht nur,
übertrieben gesagt, irgendeine schöne Grafik am Ende rauskommt, die irgendwie ein bisschen interaktiv ist, sondern du dich um so ganz viel Geraffel hintendran kümmern kannst, was die Leute aber nicht sehen,
Was aber vielleicht für eine Visualisierung, die mit sehr vielen Daten arbeitet, aber total wichtig ist,
Deswegen also ich bin auf gar keinen Fall Designer, das wäre ja eine Beleidigung für jeden Designer, wenn ich mich das nennen würde. Nein, nein. Deswegen.
Ich bin hier totaler Außenseiter. Mich hat die Schule nicht weiter gestört, also nicht groß interessiert, aber das wird einfach fertig gemacht.
War halt faul.
Erfolgreich auch, aber es ging irgendwie trotzdem. Ich glaube, ich habe drei Wochen vorm Abi das erste Mal richtig gelernt.
Ja gut, ich meine,
das stört mich nicht. Mich stört sozusagen mir das Konzept Schule. Also so wie wie sozusagen letztens ich kann's immer so mit so Beispielen bringen. Kam halt so ein Typ an, der meinte ist ähm TÜV zertifizierter Social Media Manager. Musste ich echt ins Lachen ausbrechen so,
was so sein Ding so nicht so ey, was was heißt das? Ja, ich hatte einen dreiwöchigen Kurs,
Der war ehemaliger Soldat, ne, also wenn du Soldat bist, dann musst du halt, dann gibt's ja irgendwann die die wirst du überführt ins Zivilleben, du wirst es bereit gemacht sozusagen, wird dir die Waffe so vorsichtig aus der Hand genommen
werden diese Kurse geschickt. Und dann gibt's zum Beispiel jetzt so ein TÜV-zertifizierten Social Media Manager und da meinte ich, ah ja okay,
Melde dich mal in drei Jahren, wenn du irgendwas gemacht hast damit und dann also weißt du, das ist halt dieses ganze deutsche Denken ist immer ähm äh,
Prime durch irgendwie wir brauchen einen Zertifikat. Wir brauchen TÜV, wir brauchen Abiturnote, wir brauchen Uniabschluss und das das.
Gläubigkeit.
Es ist halt es ist halt eine Pseudovergleichbarkeit, die man möchte. Man möchte gerne Dinge in Boxen packen und so
Labels drauf tun und Menschen sind aber individuell und ich meine das ist jetzt alles so Standardfloskeln, das wisst ihr ja wisst ihr auch alle, aber ich find's halt besonders nervig, gerade wenn man Bezug auf die,
neue Welt schaut sie sozusagen, wo es eben nicht mehr darum geht ähm sieben Millionen ähm Industriearbeiter am Fließband auszubilden
alle das Gleiche machen oder die alle irgendwie äh das Gleiche hm TÜV-Zertifikat für den Ottomotor bekommen, ja, sondern es geht jetzt dadrum,
individuell denken zu können, selbstständig handeln zu können, Lösungen selbst auch zu finden und und nicht einfach nur,
Dinge umzusetzen. Wir gehen eben weg von dieser Gesellschaft, in der sozusagen Dinge äh standardisiert sind und sie,
sozusagen die IT ermöglicht individuelle Lösung und da müssen wir hin und das gilt für alle Bereiche von,
Musik machen, zeichnen, egal wo. Du musst deine individuelle Kreativität stärken und nicht das und nicht sagen, ich habe Standardprogramm XYZ durchlaufen, weil das,
haben auch drei Millionen andere und im Zweifelsfall kann das auch ein Computerprogramm, das Standardprogramm, deine individuellen Stärken sind, das was zählt. Ja.
Vor allen Dingen, ob die Leute das verstanden haben, also,
Ich habe ja auch diverse Leute eingestellt und das ist halt für mich ist halt ich versuche die Fragen immer so zu formulieren, dass Leute halt erklären müssen. Ne, nicht was macht man in dem Moment, sondern warum macht man das, was man tut,
Das ist halt meistens äh merkt man halt dann sehr stark, haben die Leute wirklich verstanden, was sie da tun,
warum sie das tun und wenn sie verstanden haben, was sie tun, dann wissen sie auch, dass sie in einem etwas anderen Moment auch was anderes tun müssen und nicht einfach nur die Standardlösung draufkleben.
Ja das auch wieder mit dem erklären, wenn man das so äh dieses Einstellungsgespräch oder dieses Casting, wie auch immer, bisschen interaktiv macht, dann merkt man auch, was man da gegenüber zu sitzen hat, wenn man den so simpel irgendeinen Test gibt und die irgendwas ausfüllen, dann hast du ja auch wieder nichts gelernt, oder? Deswegen will man schon interaktiv, oder? So.
Ja ja, nee, wir wir machen halt immer ein Telefoninterview, also klar guckt erstmal die Unterlagen durch, da fallen natürlich sagen wir mal zwei Drittel raus,
und äh dann machst du ein Telefoninterview oder fallen dann halt vielleicht auch nochmal 50 Prozent raus und,
Leute, die dann durchs Telefoninterview durch sind, den schickst du halt also entweder wir laden die ein und dürfen das vor Ort machen oder schickst du's ihnen hin, halt so eine Coding Challenge,
baue das.
Aber ihr ihr seid jetzt nicht so, dass ihr sagt, schickt uns mal bitte dein Abiturzeugnis oder das ist halt das oder dein TÜV-Zertifikat als.
Ich kann mich ich kann mich nicht erinnern mal ein Abiturzeugnis von einem Bewerber gesehen zu haben. Also normalerweise guckt man nur den Lebenslauf an. Gut, dass diese ganzen.
Den guckt man auch schon nicht wirklich an, oder.
Na, ein bisschen schon. Äh die ganzen Zeugnisse, das macht alles HR, also die die gucken das alles an und und wenn die wenn
da irgendwas faul ist, dann schmeißen sie mehr oder weniger eh schon raus, aber aber nee und und am am Ende des Tages brauchst du auch kein Abitur für das, was wir machen. Also du musst es halt können, also das ist irgendwie,
ja wie gesagt ne Coding Challenge und dann schreibt der Mann halt oder die Frau halt irgendwas und dann guckst du dir den Code an und sagst warum hast denn das so gemacht
Und wenn die dann ihren Code erklären müssen,
Dann merkst du sehr stark, ob sie sich was dabei gedacht haben oder ob der einfach so passiert ist. Ja, weil das macht man so. Das ist halt keine Antwort.
Ich muss dir auch meine erste richtige Bewerbung jetzt wirklich in diesem öffentlichen Dienstkonstrukt schreiben,
Es ist halt so der Moment gewesen, wo ich dachte, ah okay, strange, weil vorher war das eher so, you komm halt mal vorbei und wir reden,
Und da ist das wirklich so äußerst formal mit ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Abizeugnis hinschicken musste, aber so Masterzeugnis, Bachelor Zeugnis, auf jeden Fall erstmal. Ansonsten wirst du da ja gar nicht,
Auswahl genommen, wenn du halt auch noch ähm in diese E-Geschichten, also du bist ja öffentlicher Dienst, dann wirst du nach Tarif bezahlt,
Meine Fresse, was für ein hin und her.
Auch der einzige Grund, warum man noch diese Uniabschlüsse braucht, nämlich in diesem öffentlichen Dienst, wo halt in Großunternehmen, die eben auch irgendwie scheinbar unfähig sind, äh etwas neue Prozesse eben jetzt etablieren, die dann eben auf.
Geschichte. Ich habe mich mal bei Siemens beworben auf irgend so einen Job und habe denen alle Unterlagen hingeschickt, aber halt wenn du zehn Jahre studiert hast, dann ich habe halt kein Abiturzeugnis mitgeschickt,
meinten die so, ja wir brauchen aber noch das Tabiturzeugnis
so na ja okay, dann schickst du's halt noch hin. Und dann haben die halt gesehen, dass in dem Abiturzeugnis stand halt für Mathe eine Drei drin.
Ach und deswegen bist du nicht genommen worden. Das sind echt Trottel. Also das muss man echt mal sagen, wer auf sowas achtet in einem Abiturzeugen.
Aber dann dachte ich mir, na ja gut.
Da will man auch nicht arbeiten.
Will man da auch nicht arbeiten. Also das war oha.
Ich glaube schon seit 20 Jahren,
äh oder vor 22 Jahren habe ich mich, glaube ich, zum letzten Mal mit Zeugnis irgendwie beworben. Da war ich ja auch noch ein bisschen jünger. Da musste man wahrscheinlich so machen. Aber seitdem immer nur noch
Irgendwie Leute, die ich eh schon kenne, die dann ankommen und sagen, hier Dennis, du programmierst doch da gerade schon aufm iPhone da, also 2tausendacht, ne? Willst du nicht mal hier bei uns irgendwie hier fürs iPhone programmieren und schwupp, hast du einen Job? Also es ging.
Ich meine, die Programmierer wählt ihr sowieso noch mal. Äh ich meine, ihr seid so umkämpft, ja, also jetzt sage ich ihr, aber äh,
Menschen, die programmieren können, da ist sowieso eine andere Welt, aber ich sage mal, es gilt ja eben auch für immer mehr Berufe,
dass das eben nicht mehr auf die Standards ankommt und und ich find's halt schade, dass das Bildungssystem,
eben immer noch auf AB Tests, also irgendwie ausfällt, Ankreuztests äh so und lernt halt Dinge auswendig so, also ähm,
Das gesamte Konzept von wir geben Schulbücher raus und dem gibt es ein Kanon und dann gibt es am Ende des Jahres,
Prüfungen und es gibt irgendwie besser sozusagen Standards wissen Kanons, die vermittelt werden und in Hörne reingeprügelt werden und äh es gibt null,
individuelle Lernförderung, die wirklich darauf äh basiert, dass jemand erstmal angeschaut wird, äh was kann der eigentlich äh jetzt ohne äh äh die DDR irgendwie preisen zu wollen, aber das haben die schon damals ein bisschen besser gemacht. Also da gab's wirklich sozusagen eine Anschauung,
von Schülern, was was kann dieser Schüler und wo können wir den irgendwo mal hinbringen in der Gesellschaft
Dann hat das nicht zwingend bedeutet, dass der eben immer alles machen musste, sondern dann hat er eine spezielle Förderung bekommen, hat mehr Sportunterricht bekommen oder hat mehr Musikunterricht bekommen und so weiter und das basiert eben auf einer individuellen Bewertung der Schüler
Das sind so Dinge, die halt irgendwie verloren gegangen sind und dass wir eben unser Bildungssystem ist ja immer noch sehr preußisch äh sozusagen inspiriert und die Preußen wollten eben ein großes, stehendes Heer hatten und wollten dafür sozusagen einen Standard wissen
vermittelt bekommen und dafür wurde das Schulsystem entwickelt und.
Aber hier gab's ja auch äh das äh Berufsinformationszentrum, da es ja schon auch gesagt was du kannst, was dir Spaß macht, wieder in den Noten sind und dann haben die dir schon auch dementsprechend.
Informationszentrum hat ja nichts mit deiner schulischen Ausbildung zu tun und die sagen ja nicht denn Lehrer äh lassen sie die mal in Mathe ein bisschen in Ruhe.
Noch vorher.
Ja, nein, in der Schule,
gefördert werden und für eine Grundschule bereits, da muss entdeckt werden, dass es ein musikalisches Kind, das ist ein sportliches Kind, das ist ein technisches Kind, was sie für Mathe und Logik interessiert, das ist ein das ist ein Forscher und dann musst du deine äh Kurse wählen können und dann muss auch
Kind, was sozusagen talentiert ist in einem bestimmten Bereich, auf eine höhere Schule gehen dürfen, auch wenn es vielleicht in bestimmten anderen Bereichen äh schlecht ist und ich hatte zum Beispiel das Glück, ich bin Legastheniker, meine,
Deutschkenntnisse waren katastrophal, ich hab 'n Rechtschreibung, ich hatte sozusagen durchgehend 'ne sechs, meine gesamtes Schulleben durch und
ich nicht, hätte es nicht damals sozusagen auch in Westdeutschland dann
ein System gegeben, das Legasthenie anerkannt wird als Krankheit. Hätte ich überhaupt gar keine Chance gehabt am Gymnasium und mein gesamtes Leben hätte einen anderen Weg genommen, nur weil sozusagen
Standardisiert muss sich Deutsch können, also Rechtschreibmäßig technisch. Wer ein Aspekt ist des Deutschen sozusagen
und ähm ja das das ich finde es halt schade, dass das viele Kinder, die bestimmte Sachen nicht können, aber großartige Talente haben in anderen Bereichen und auch neugierige Kinder sind dann eben so Lebenschancen versagt bekommen, weil man sie versucht in in Packungen zu stecken,
wie gesagt, ich höre mir so das ist alles so bekannt, also äh trotzdem regt's mich immer noch auf und und,
Man kam ja von erklären, sind jetzt einen sehr großen Bogen gelaufen zur Schulbildung, aber ähm ja, es ist halt.
Eigentlich ist es, wenn man immer beim selben Thema so und äh sind äh wichtige äh Aspekte. Ich hatte ja auch gerade kann ich hier mal kurz placken. Ähm vor kurzem mich mit,
Äh Harald Lesch äh äh unterhalten dürfen, Vorschaugeist. Äh es ist legendär. Weiß ich nicht, aber es war ganz okay so,
Also hast du's gehört schon.
Äh nein, tatsächlich nicht, ich habe nur deine Werbung schon dafür gehört, das war wo hast du das gepackt? Das hast du irgendwo in einer äh in den letzten Sendungen.
So bin ich.
Plack ruhig nochmal.
Ich bin manchmal ganz überrascht, dass mir Leute erzählen so ach was diesen Podcast machst du auch schon seit fünf Jahren in Klammern so wusste ich ja noch gar nicht, merke ich irgendwie sollte vielleicht mal mehr du kritisierst auch immer äh meine,
Was hörst du das? Nee, wer hat mich denn da.
Seine Social-Media-Aufstellung nicht so gut.
Tims zwischen mir, Ausstellung ist eine Katastrophe, ist praktisch nicht existent. Ist ja Verweigerungshaltung in der öffentlichen äh.
Jetzt komm, jetzt kommen wir auf ein neues Thema.
Tim verweigert sich. Was was deine Social Media.
Erzähl mal. Was? Ja sag mal. Analysier mal. Ich wollte jetzt den Nash nur äh erzählen wegen dieser äh äh Bildungsaspekte, aber die hast du eigentlich auch wunderbar.
So richtig ähm also ihr habt einen zielgruppenspezifischen Angebot und ihr seid in einer sehr sehr sehr wert kleinen Bubble äh sozusagen unterwegs, die ich sehr liebe und deswegen höre ich's gerne und ist total klug, aber,
Leider ist sozusagen äh ein ganz großes Potential, was ihr habt, nutzt ihr nicht sozusagen. Also jetzt spreche ich von Plural, aber ihr gehört ja alle mit dazu. Ähm weil ihr sozusagen gewisse Verweigerungshaltung habt, was die Kanäle angeht ähm und ähm,
Ich nehme ja nur das Beispiel Twitter, ne, dass die Tatsache, dass sozusagen Twitter sozusagen so eine Fixierung auf Twitter gibt und es so eine Verweigerungshaltung gegenüber anderen Kanälen gibt, egal ob Instagram
Facebook, Vero oder sonst was,
Ist halt eigentlich für 'n großes vertane Chance und natürlich YouTube auch, dass ich weiß du hast das alles und bisher haben wir auch zu zweit schon mal kurz drüber gesprochen, aber
Persönlich finde halt den Content, den ihr produziert äh extrem wertvoll und ich finde es unglaublich schade, dass ihr sozusagen euch so begrenzt in den Kanälen und,
Es hat äh eine sehr starke ideologische ähm Begründung, mit der ihr da rangeht, sozusagen so freie Kanäle und wir wollen uns nicht äh sozusagen von Facebook erklären lassen, äh wie wir unsere ähm Content verbreiten und und welche Reichweite wir haben.
Aber ist das wirklich ideologisch.
Ich glaube, dass es bei Tim und ähm auch anderen in der Szene jetzt, ne, von der wir sprechen, äh ist das schon eine ideologische Haltung und
Das Traurige daran ist, dass sozusagen der Content, der hier verbreitet und produziert wird, wahnsinnig wertvoll ist und wahnsinnig tolle Inhalte, aber auch zum Beispiel Netz äh Netz, wie heißt das, Entschuldigung, Ne,
Logbuchnetzpolitik, ne, wenn ich das sehe und ich mir dann mir denke, warum haben die nicht eine Million Zuhörer, ne? Ähm und,
und dann geht's auf YouTube und da ist Bibis äh Beauty-Channel, okay, ist nicht vergleichbar, wird auch nie die Reichweite haben, aber.
Was.
Ist eigentlich ein YouTube-Star. Könnte einer sein? So ja.
Ja
Aber ihr habt einen genialen Content und vermauert euch ein in einer ähm sozusagen Welt und das finde ich manchmal traurig. Nichtsdestotrotz ich meine ich habe ich find's ja aber es ist halt so schade, weil ihr euch.
Aber du wirst doch nicht Rockstar, wenn du eine Hitparade auftrittst.
Können wir das nee, ich würde das mal ich würde das jetzt mal ich greife das mal auf so, ne? Also ich habe ja auch zu jedem Kanal.
Rote Karte mit dem Monolog bereithalten.
So meine Ansichten, ja, das kann man jetzt als Ideologisch äh bezeichnen, hat aber auch äh andere Gründe. Mark hier und da etwas Ideologie mit drin sein, aber das ist es auf gar keinen Fall nur. So was jetzt mal wie Instagram nimmt,
Ich schieße keine Fotos, ich mache keine Fotos, ich schaue mir keine Fotos an.
War ja wahrscheinlich nur so ein Beispiel, was jetzt vielleicht nicht.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal eins nach dem anderen so, ja? Äh ich sehe ich sehe ja äh natürlich äh ist ja nicht so, dass ich sie nicht wahrnehme, dass viele Leute das benutzen und dass wir irgendwie ihre Dinge machen,
Ich äh mache mir auch immer mal einen Account und äh schaue da mal rein. So und nichts hat mich da berührt. Also.
Nicht verstanden Instagram.
Mich mich berührt auf.
Kann man doch nur abmeckern sagen. Posten Leute auch Twittern, Instagrambild, dann klicke ich da, dann will ich natürlich mal wieder ranzoomen, weil man will ja Details erkennen und dann kann ich bei Instagram nicht reinzoomen, weil das bei denen dann irgendwie nicht geht. Also das ist doch.
Technische.
Aber warum machen die das? Die sollen einfach dieses scheiß Bild posten.
Na, das ist halt.
Also jeder Kanal, den ihr nutzt und der nicht euch gehört, jetzt sind wir wieder bei den Cloud-Geschichten, hat sozusagen seine Begrenzung und damit muss man leben, man muss die lernen und dann anpassen und ihr habt,
Und man kann natürlich auf auf äh Instagram keine Podcasts posten, um's mal so ganz banal zu sagen, aber ihr könntet den Content, den hier aufbereitet, sozusagen schon nochmal äh anders visuell aufbereiten und jetzt meinetwegen die besten Zitate der.
Dem Link hier.
Ja und die besten Ziele hatte der Woche und auf Instagram posten.
Schockiert, wenn ich dir sage, dass einer meiner Podcasts auf Instagram tatsächlich beworben wird auf diese Art und Weise.
Ich bisher noch nicht, nee. Ja, aber ich bin schockiert. Ich finde das, finde ich gut.
Live-Geschichten, damit du.
Tue das nicht selber. Ja.
Hast du jemand? Von denen gemacht dann die.
Ne, es gibt ja immer diese Videos, hast vielleicht schon mal gesehen, die landen auf Twitter, die landen auf Instagram. So,
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das gut ist. Das wird gemacht, so. Ich kann keinerlei,
Reaktion also ich mir hat noch nie einer gesagt weil auf Instagram was,
deswegen Podcast ist eine Information, die man bei mir noch nie angekommen ist, nie auch nur ein einziges.
Auch immer sehr viel Feedback, wenn da nicht die Zahlen kommen, dass da so und so viel Prozent jetzt über Instagram reinkommen, findest du das nicht gut.
Was? Findest du das nicht? Nein, das ist warst du Quatsch. Nein, das ist äh eine Gefühlssache, aber ich meine, es kann ja zumindest mal einer erwähnen oder irgendwie durch irgendetwas könnte sie ja mal immanent werden. So, ist aber nicht.
Wir können das insofern abkürzen, wenn du den Kanal nicht betreibst, ist er auch nicht authentisch, würde auch nicht funktionieren. Also entweder du gehst wirklich damit rein und bist das ist dein Kanal, der muss dann auch von dir betrieben werden. Du musst dahinter stehen, du musst auch da einen Diskurs führen.
Hundert.
Dann kann das funktionieren und ansonsten ist das halt so ein äh Me too oder ein müssen wir halt machen oder so, aber.
Genau. Ja, weil ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, was ich da senden sollte, weil.
Also du musst äh deine Inhalte individuell auf die jeweiligen Kanäle anpassen und es ist sozusagen schon ein bisschen aufwendiger. Guck mal, ich ich formuliere es mal anders.
Das ist aber meiner Meinung nach schon der falsche Ansatz. Ein Kanal muss für meine Inhalte geeignet sein. Ich muss nicht meine Inhalte auf den Kanal anpassen. Der Kanal muss zu meinem Inhalt pass.
Ja gut, dann bist du halt auf einen festgenagt, nämlich Podcasting. Was ja auch okay ist, weil sie jetzt.
Ich mache ja nun mal Podcasting.
Ja ja, nein. Ich meine, ich du bist eine personality,
du machst keinen Podcast und du bist eine personelle und du verkaufst äh über deine Personality, über deinen Charakter verkaufst du Inhalte. So und du hast den.
Wer's er will, dass er über seinen Charaktersachen verkauft oder über den Inhalt.
Das denkt er ja, das über den Inhalt, das stimmt aber gar nicht.
Frage ist ja was er will.
Das denkt er überhaupt nicht, das ist mir vollkommen bewusst. Ich meine, ich benutze ja auch Twitter. Auf Twitter kann ich auch keinen Podcast veröffentlichen, aber Twitter ist ein,
Extrem gut geeigneter Kanal, der in seiner äh Art und Weise, wie er Öffentlichkeit erzeugt,
Leser, Konsumentenverhältnisse abbildet, also das Follower-Modell das war einfach irgendwie von Anfang an überzeugt und Twitter hat ja im Prinzip die letzten zehn Jahre auch geliefert. Ich meine also
für mich sozusagen in meiner Nutzung hat's mir was gebracht so.
Twitter ist ein absoluter Elitenkanal, der sozusagen überhaupt keine Massenwirkung hat, außer die Tatsache, dass die Journalisten sozusagen ihnen als Multiplikator nutzen, aber für.
Moment, wir wollen Moment, aber da bekomme ich doch genau die Leute, die ich haben will.
Gut, wenn das eben, das ist ja das ist genau, das ist eine ehrliche Einschätzung. Also da würde ich mitgehen, wenn das eure.
Bekommt man an welche Leute nicht mehr die Elite, sondern.
Die achtzig Prozent, von denen ich,
die nicht das unterstützen, was Tim will befindet euch sozusagen eher im 20 Prozent oder eher im 0,2% Promille-Bereich dessen, was sozusagen äh an Bevölkerung da ist und die Masse der Menschen sind eben auf diesen Massenkanälen
und ähm sind nicht auf also Twitter im Besonderen ist halt ein Kanal, der absolut Elitenkommunikation ist, sozusagen ja,
Also es gab mal eine Phase, wo ein paar Gamer auch äh auf äh Twitter unterwegs sind, sind auch noch immer da und so ein paar äh so ähm Promis. Aber gerade in Deutschland hatten haben die Promis eigentlich auf Twitter nie so stark gefunden, wie zum Beispiel in Amerika, aber auch in Amerika ist es vorbei. Die Promis sind alle weg. Der einzige, der noch da ist, ist Tim äh ist nicht
Tim ist äh.
Bin der Einzige verbliebene Promi.
Nee, nee. Der nee,
in Amerika ist ist sozusagen der US-Präsident noch da Trump und ansonsten ähm ist da auch nicht mehr viel los. Also äh Twitter ist sozusagen durch äh in gewisser Weise auf einem,
absterbendem Ast.
Aber das ist ja, ist doch äh das ist doch gut.
Die Art. Äh ich meine absterbender Ass. Das würde ja bedeuten, dass die Diskussionen, die vorher auf Twitter geführt werden, jetzt woanders geführt werden.
Also in Amerika war's halt eben mal ein Massenphänomen Twitter für eine Zeit lang. Das ist das und das findet nicht mehr statt. Das ist auf Facebook,
Und das ist halt komplett weg von Twitter. Natürlich findet auf Twitter immer noch eine Kommunikation statt, auch genauso wie in Deutschland, eben so eine Art Elitendiskurs, Journalisten, Politiker, Interessierte, äh Menschen, die sich mit Politik beschäftigen, sowas, aber äh.
Die Geisteskranken vergessen.
Tante Tante Erma sozusagen und äh Peter, der sozusagen Netflix schaut, der ist halt auf Facebook und Instagram. Und eine Zeit lang war auf äh Snapchat, aber Snapchat ist auch gerade wieder so ein bisschen,
am am Absinken und wurde von äh Instagram. Und ihr habt eine Auswahl getroffen sozusagen in eure in euren Kanälen und meine ich find's, ich wüsste ja keine Kritik, sondern es ist einfach nur ich find's schade, weil ich glaube, dass eure Inhalte eigentlich,
voll genial sind, also jetzt.
Sind denn ich mag das Elite Wort ja nicht so, aber sind unsere Inhalte da nicht auch sehr elite-mäßig, also würden das so wie du sagst, wenn Facebook andere Leute sind, würden die das dann überhaupt hören wollen.
Da ist ein Punkt, da hast du einen Punkt, also ich äh sozusagen äh zeitweise heute zum Beispiel, ne, äh wo wo wir 20 Minuten irgendwie über Vor-und Nachteile von bestimmten Cloud Installationen und bestimmten Prozessoren haben wir sie.
Interessiert die doch gar nicht.
Das kann keiner aufnehmen, der sozusagen nicht in diesen. Aber es gibt ähm ich spreche, wenn ich von euch spreche, meinte ich immer auch Tim mit einer Metaebene. Da sind ja viele, er hat ja viele Podcast-Angebote,
Davon sind viele auch über die äh sage ich mal CC äh Cancy Gruppe hinaus äh spannend und ich,
eben da sind halt,
noch unterschätzt und aber ich finde auch, dass selbst dieser Podcast hier sozusagen ähm gerade junge Leute anspricht, viel mehr ansprechen könnte und dass da einfach sozusagen ähm Potentiale noch nicht ausgeschöpft sind.
Na, was heißt denn ansprechen könnte? Du meinst ich werbe nur nicht ausreichend dafür oder ich veröffentliche nicht an den richtigen Stellen.
Genau, du veröffentlichst nicht an richtigen Stellen.
Deiner Meinung nach die richtigen Stellen.
Kanäle, Facebook, Instagram, YouTube.
Auf Facebook also.
Aber du hast doch, du hast doch auf Facebook überhaupt nicht die Reichweite. Ja. Das funktioniert doch nicht.
Ich glaube, die hast du schon, aber die Frage ist, ob man das will.
Nein, nein, nein.
Also ohne dass du dafür bezahlst, ne.
Doch auch ohne mit bezahlen.
Eine Frage des können.
Nein, du musst sozusagen, das ist jede jede Social-Media-Kanal hat seine Regeln sozusagen so, man muss diese Regeln halt befolgen und dann wird man vom Algorithmus belohnt,
sozusagen vor allem Menschen, die langweilige Inhalte oder schlechte Inhalte oder nicht gut,
auf den Kanal angepasste Inhalte produzieren, die dann dich darüber beschweren, dass sie keine Reichweite bekommen oder die auch einfach nicht zu erzählen haben. Also ganz viele Leute, also äh wer sich am meisten über mangelnde Reichweite äh beschwert, sind halt irgendwelche Leute, die irgendwelche also irgendwelche Firmen, die irgendwas verkaufen wollen
sich darüber aufregen, dass sie sozusagen nicht mehr kostenlos äh für ihre Matratzen laden, eine Million Leute bei jedem Post erreichen und da muss man sich halt sagen, ja aber du bist halt auch ein Matratzenverkäufer, das ist halt auch nicht spannend jeden.
Von alleine kommen die Leute ja auch nicht. Also ich meine, das muss ich ja rumsprechen, oder.
Du musst einen Mehrwert schaffen für die Nutzer. Das ist im Kern sozusagen. Also äh das ist ja wie bei jedem Kanal, ne? Und was nur bei Facebook anders ist als bei Twitter ist, dass ich
nicht manuell wähle, bei Twitter muss ich entscheiden, wer ist für mich interessant. Facebook-Idee ist sozusagen, wir nehmen das den Leuten ab und wir, der Algorithmus entscheidet für die Menschen, was zu sehen ist,
Der Mensch gibt sozusagen Feedback an den Algorithmus durch Likes sharest und Kommentare,
Und wenn du es schaffst interessante Inhalte zu kreieren, das gilt sowohl für Unternehmen als auch politische Organisationen, aber eben auch äh Creators, wie wir sie nennen, äh also äh Menschen wie wie Tim, dann äh,
Eigentlich am einfachsten, weil wenn du Journalistisch steht, die bist, hast du ja per se interessante Inhalte, weil du Meinung hast und du musst nicht immer jedes Mal versuchen, einen Post zu machen, der irgendwie versucht, noch eine Matratze zu verkaufen. Also eigentlich habt ihr das sozusagen ganz, ganz leicht,
und ähm wie gesagt, ist alles nicht schlimm. Das kann man alles machen. Ich ich find's halt nur schade, weil ich die Produkte, die Tim mach,
total super finde und ich finde die eher unterstellt sich noch, einfach weil er aus einer Tradition kommt, die sozusagen eher sozusagen neunziger Jahre geprägt ist aus den klassischen,
eins Punkt null Internet und ähm so ein bisschen so eine Verweigerungshaltung hat gegenüber den Plattformen.
Aber dafür läuft's ziemlich gut für diese Verweigerungshaltung. Findest du nicht.
Ähm wenn es nicht so gut liefe, würde es Ihnen ja gar nicht mehr geben, ne? Also so ich sage ja nur, dass es noch Potentiale gibt. Guck mal, wenn,
Weiß nicht, äh ich weiß jetzt nicht, die Zahlen von zum Beispiel dieser Sendung, ne, wie viele Leute die erreichen, aber wenn du das jetzt mal stellst gegen einen noch nicht mal die Top-Youtuber, aber dann ist das halt,
Zu vernachlässigen, weil die erreichen mit einer Wendung das, was ProSieben im Abend äh Deutschland sucht, den erreicht, erreicht so ein typischer 13-jähriger YouTuber mit seinem Laberformat, wo er echt dumm dummschuss erzählt.
Erreicht.
Es sind richtig durchgeschaute äh YouTube-Folgen und die werden halt von zwei Millionen Leuten angeguckt,
Ich finde das halt, ja gut, das hat halt natürlich auch Gründe, weil Jugendliche irgendwie.
Guck mal wie du das genannt hast, das kann man auch zwei Millionen mal unter die Leute schieben, weil da sind genug die sich das antun. Ich glaube, das was wir erzählen äh dann vielleicht können doch nicht so viele mithalten.
Ja, also es ihr werdet nie zwei Millionen haben, das ist klar, aber es gibt eben mindestens, ich würde mal sagen, so,
fünffach, zehnfach, vielleicht sogar hundertfach die Reichweite, die könntet ihr haben, wenn ihr euch gewissen Kanälen öffnen würdet und ähm wie gesagt, ich,
Es muss alles nicht sein, aber es ist einfach schön, aber,
Das wäre sozusagen mein Feedback sozusagen, ne? Das ist erstmal das Erste, was mir auffällt, wenn ich auf das Angebot schaue, äh was was die Mieterebene bietet, dann sage ich, aha, interessant. Da da wird ein Potential, was da ist, nicht äh nicht ausgeschöpft.
Es hat ja auch immer ein bisschen was mit den AGBs und den sonstigen Gepflogenheiten auf solchen äh Systemen zu tun und wie viel Freiheiten man da hat,
Und äh mir sind also zum Beispiel schon mal Systeme, die äh von sich aus den Content von äh äh meinen Content entfernen können, ja äh.
Gar nicht.
Bin ich schon, da bin ich schon nenn's ideologisch so, aber
habe ich da einfach ein Problem mit so und das ist einfach äh äh
Dieses selber der Hoster zu sein ist schon mal eine Menge
Wert so mal ganz abgesehen davon was für merkwürdige Regeln da teilweise gelten mit irgendwie Anstößigkeiten hier und inhaltlicher Bewertung und Copy-Ride,
Filter,
Urheberrecht und dann spielst du mal irgend so ein Scheiß äh Clip ein und dann wirst du halt gleich weggefleckt und hast vielleicht irgendwie auch noch was drauf so das ist auch alles ein Risiko so, das muss man in diese ganze Rechnung noch mit reinnehmen. Habe ich irgendwie auch relativ wenig Bock drauf,
so
Ähm ich ich sage mal folgendes, du hast mit allem Recht, man kann diese Kanäle nur bespielen, wenn man sozusagen den die Regeln dieser Kanäle befolgt. Das ist halt eine,
Das grinst einen auch ein als als jemand, der creative ist und natürlich
ist das auch ein genialer Vorteil, den ihr habt, dadurch, dass ihr diese Freiheit habt. Ich wollte mal eine Sache sagen, eine Sache, die jetzt eventuell zu euch zu Gunsten kommt, ist, dass Google jetzt hier angekündigt hat, das hatte ich hier auch in die Themenliste geschrieben, können wir kurz vorziehen, dass jetzt äh Google Podcast in die Websuchmaschine mit ein.
Ja so läuft's.
Also zumindestens stand das da, ich weiß,
stimmt, aber wenn das jetzt wirklich so ist, dass in Zukunft da oben dem dem sozusagen allgemeinen Google und Google News und Google Bilder dann auch Google Podcast kommt und Google hat auch angekündigt, dass sie die durchsuchen wollen, die also audio.
Ihnen erlaubst, dass sie eine Kopie ausliefern von deiner Datei, von ihren eigenen Servern.
Das ist die Voraussetzung, also.
Wenn sich das nicht geändert hat, das haben sie ja im Prinzip letztes Jahr schon äh angekündigt und haben da irgendwie sozusagen einmal komplett die iTunes Extensions äh kopiert,
machen jetzt mal dasselbe wie äh iTunes, nur dass wir mit den Kram selber.
Klicken, den ich da in die Themenliste reingeschmi.
Na ja, ich kenne das Ding.
Okay, hast du schon geguckt, ja.
Da ist bloß jetzt äh relativ unklar, inwiefern das jetzt was Neues ist äh bezüglich dem, was sie technisch schon vor einiger Zeit veröffentlicht haben so. Das heißt, äh du wirst da halt nur angezeigt, wenn du in dem Google Play Verzeichnis bist und in dem Google-Play-Verzeichnis bist du halt nur
dich da listen lässt und listenah ist halt wieder hier äh
unsere Bedingungen unter anderem wir liefern dann die Datei aus, das heißt äh
Statistiken werden bei uns erzeugt und wo ist denn das Problem? Wir machen dir hier auch schöne bunte Bilder. Das heißt, ich muss dann irgendwie wieder äh einen weiteren Kanal äh
anklicken und schauen, was ist und ich habe sozusagen die Auslieferung äh nicht im die machen renncoding von meinen Inhalten, da weiß ich nicht, was von meinen Metadaten übrig bleibt et cetera PP
total problema.
Ich verstehe deinen Punkt, aber ich ich bin so ich bin ein großer Fan dieser äh dieser Dienstleister, die sozusagen für dich Dinge tun, aber klar ist auch, man man muss dann, es ist so ein gegenseitiges Geschäftnis und so ein Nehmen und Geben.
Die müssen nicht unbedingt meinen Kram hosten. Die können auch gerne mich einfach so finden und den Link anzeigen. Da muss ich auch überhaupt nix für tun, weil ich bin äh komplett lesbar im Netz und die wissen alles, was sie wissen müssen. Das sind immer so so quasi Angebote
die so ein äh Klumpfuß noch mit dran haben. Das finde ich ja irgendwie so problematisch.
Ne, es ist halt das Einkassieren der der Inhalte im Wesentlichen, ne? Wollen die die halte unter Kontrolle kriegen.
Sie wollen sie wollen äh und es ist ganz interessant dieses Rennen gerade um äh Podcast, nicht? Weil alle wollen jetzt hier irgendwie
neue YouTube, der äh Podcast sein, da kommt irgendwie auch alle zwei Wochen irgend so ein Start-up angekrochen und meine Mailbox läuft die ganze Zeit über, weil sie meine ganzen E-Mail
Adressen, die in den Feeds drin stehen durch Spam und so. Ja und äh weißt du äh,
äh äh und du musst nur hier und klick da und Pipapo und dann hier diese ganzen Hirntoten
Radio Streamingportale wie TuneIn und so weiter die erstmal überall Feeds einsammeln, dich da irgendwie listen und so weiter und dann kriegt er hinterher und dann so wie ist denn das hier da drin gelandet und so ist das einfach nur ein Podcastverzeichnis, was ja okay wäre so ja
Dann so, nee, dann lese ich mal so die AGB durch. Ja und wenn du hier gelistet bist, dann akzeptierst du das wieder Werbung einblenden und Pipa
und überhaupt rechte Übertragung. Unser ganze Klimpern.
Schreibe ich denen irgendwie so, sage mal, Leute, habt ihr den Arsch offen irgendwie? Äh wie kommt mein Content da rein, so? Ja und äh bla, bla, bla, danke, dass Sie sich an uns gewendet haben,
das ist dann innerhalb von zwei Tagen auch gelöscht so, ne,
Bei Tune in irgendwie den einen Feed jetzt glaube ich drei oder vier Mal in den letzten sechs Monaten monieren bis er dann jetzt auch endlich mal weg war,
Natürlich gleich Geschrei von Tesla-Fahrern, weil die natürlich in ihrem bekloppten Gerät nur diese TuneIn Frontend haben, um Podcasts zu hören, die jetzt denken, so jetzt kann ich aber keine Freakshow mehr hören, weil ich halt nur so, wer kauft dir ein anderes Auto.
Mir doch egal.
Mein Punkt ist, dass äh du hast Recht, dass egal welchen,
du da zusammenarbeitest und das gilt ja auch für Twitter. Jeder kommt mit deinen Beschränkungen, mit seinen AGBs und Regeln und allem und eben auch ähm Vereinnahmung von dir. Aber du darfst nicht unterschätzen, dass eben diese Plattform eben auch ähm,
eben mit einem X Milliardennutzern oft kommen. Ne, also vielleicht die kleinen Podcast-Dienstleiter jetzt noch nicht, aber Facebook äh ist halt sozusagen 50 Prozent des Internets momentan und.
Komischerweise gibt's einen großen, riesigen Plattformanbieter, der seit zehn Jahren Podcast unterstützt und überhaupt null Vereinnahmungen macht. Na ja, jetzt fangen sie auch langsam damit an,
iTunes Podcast verzeichnet war schon immer ein Fair Deal. Wir listen den Feed. Alle Metadaten, die da drinstehen, kommen aus deinem Feed, kein Fünkchen mehr,
Hier ist ein offener äh Erweiterung für ein offenes Format, wo du den ganzen Kram reinschreiben kannst, der bei uns auftaucht. Das ist dann zum äh Standard geworden. Wir ordnen nicht deinen Content
den nicht, wir reden Kohl, wir fassen den überhaupt nicht an, wir liefern ihn nur aus. Ja, dann halt das Übliche, kein Porn, Pipapo, okay, mein.
Ähm diese andere äh Podcastanbieter, der jetzt gerade sich mit äh hier unserem Jan Böhmermann sich diese eine Show einge.
Spotify oder was? Das ist kein Podcast-Anbieter, das ist ein Musikstreaming-Anbieter.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist ähm ja klar, dir aber auch Podcast. Worauf ich hinaus will ist Spotify, also es ist es ist für mich sichtbar, dass Spotify,
äh etwas leistet, was iTunes in den letzten zehn Jahren nicht geschafft hat, nämlich äh im Podcast für die Masse,
wieder mal äh einfach und bedienbar zu machen,
Gerade weil sie es begrenzen und weil sie gewisse Vorgaben machen. Die Freiheit des Internets sozusagen dieses 90er Jahre Internet. Wir haben alle unseren eigenen Service. Wir hatten mit der Cloud schon gesprochen und so weiter. Das hat natürlich diese ganzen Vorteile von und die will ich überhaupt nicht abstreiten. Mit allem Recht,
aber es ist eben auch immer so, dass sozusagen ähm Freiheit immer auch Komplexität bedeutet,
Facebook ist ja nicht deshalb erfolgreich, weil sie sozusagen die komplexeste Plattform im Internet anbieten und da irgendwie das HTML besser funktioniert
weil es eben sozusagen reduziert und weil der Nutzer eben nur klicke ein Foto an und das zu posten und es ist eben nicht ich muss das Foto erst auf meinen Förder hochladen, da muss ich mir's mit einem HTL Tag in meinem Wordpress Blog einbinden und dann muss ich irgendwie äh verschiedene dann weiß ich aber noch nicht, wie ich ihn rechts und links ausrichten kann das Bild, sondern das das macht alles Facebook für mich.
Spotify macht ja Podcast für nicht einfacher. Und Audible auch nicht. Hast du überhaupt gar keine Podcastspezifischen Funktionen drin? Das ist irgendwie auf Musik hin.
Du sprichst wieder von dir 20 Prozent und nicht 80 Prozent Massenmacher. Ähm das ist hier zum Beispiel Audio Box als mal als.
Ich rede von der Zukunft, mein Freund.
Jetzt geht's los.
Ja, ich rede davon, wie es zu sein hat. Das, was heute ist, ist doch ja nicht meine ich lebe doch heute das, was ich vor zehn Jahren wollte,
So und ich bin aber auch nur deshalb hingekommen, weil ich das vor zehn Jahren schon wollte und ich will jetzt das Leben, wo ich in zehn Jahren sein will,
Kann ich mich doch nicht von solchen Honks aufhalten lassen,
sich einfach nur an irgend so einer bekloppten ist Multimedia Massenrealität orientieren und die mir am Ende nicht helfen werden. Die werden mich einfach die wollen mich einfach nur in ihre scheiß Plattform einsperren und mir ihre Regeln aufdrücken.
Aber solange du nicht anerkennst, dass die Plattform eben auch die Plattform selbst einen Mehrwert hat. Kannst du natürlich, könnte ich ne, äh kann ich, rede ich gegen dich gegen eine Wand, aber es ist eben so.
Mehrwert sein.
Ähm das ist für die Nutzer einfacher ist. Der Nutzer muss das nicht verstehen, um sozusagen ich muss nichts verstehen vom Internet, um Facebook als App zu benutzen,
das ist der Vorteil. Ich muss nicht äh verstehen, wie Fotos fotografieren, um bei Instagram Filter anzuverwenden. Oh, ich muss nicht Photoshop kennen. Also das sind sozusagen im.
Was musst du gerade wissen? Wenn mich Leute fragen, wie ein Podcast höre, sei du tippst auf Podcasts auf deinem Telefon und dann gibst du Prittlove ein return und dann drückst du nur noch aufs Plus für dich. Ist alles.
Bei Google Free Show ein und dann kommt da eine Webseite.
Und dann drückst du auf play. Ich meine, das ist doch nicht schwierig.
Meine meine Erfahrungen mit Nutzern ist, dass sie sozusagen das nicht,
und dass sie es nicht schaffen, einen Podcast in also eine Podcast URL oder in einem Suchverzeichnis den Podcast rauszusuchen, sondern dass sozusagen tatsächlich diese speziellen User-Interfaces,
mehr Werte bringen und
Für die Masse der Nutzer also anders wäre ja nicht zu erklären, warum sozusagen Facebook 80 Prozent des gesamten veröffentlichten Inhalts aufgesogen hat und die warum sind denn sozusagen heute
Leute nicht mehr Blogger, sondern Instagrammer. Warum sind sozusagen die Leute.
Wie kommt meine Bitte vom Bloggen nach Instagram? Ich verstehe das immer noch.
Das kann ich dir.
Diese Reduzierung von von Komplexität ist das, was,
Plattformen erfolgreich macht. Und es ist eben äh sozusagen ähm äh du hast als jemand, der Content in diese Plattform einstellt,
Natürlich weniger Freiheiten, aber du hast eben mehr audience, weil es für die audience einfacher gemacht wird, diesen diesen Inhalten zu folgen, diese zu abonnieren, weil sie einer Standardisierung untergelaufen sind, bevor sie.
Die Freiheit des Internets hat sozusagen den Nachteil, dass es komplexer ist
Es ist unglaublich ähm äh leicht davon zu zu sprechen, zu sagen, aber es ist doch nicht schwer, einen Podcast zu abonnieren
Das das das ist natürlich aus unserer Perspektive sich schwer vorzustellen, warum das schwer ist, aber wenn ich jetzt Dennis Mutter mir vorstellen würde oder meine Mutter, äh dann weiß ich, wie schwer das ist und.
Diese Apps oder sonstige Plattformen helfen dort. Und ähm schon die Tatsache, dass sie aufs Aufbereiten äh oder oder irgendwie die ein Podcast der Woche ähm im im,
und so weiter. Das sind das sind die und man kann trotzdem natürlich sagen, die Plattformen können offener sein und sie könnten sich an Web-Standards halten und sie könnten und so weiter,
Aber natürlich haben die auch einen äh müssen die auch überleben und die müssen ihr Geld verdienen und die müssen sich gegen Übernahmen schützen und sie müssen halt kommerzielle ähm äh,
Realitäten ermessen und,
kann man halt ignorieren, das kann man beklagen, das kann man äh da kann man sich gegen sperren und dann hat man eben den Effekt, dass man eben in seiner kleinen äh Basis ist und und die Masse eben nicht erreicht und das,
Wie gesagt schade, weil die Content eigentlich gut ist und du hast auch ein ein Geschäftsmodell, was dir nicht erfordert, dass du zum Beispiel,
Werbung einblendest oder dass du irgendwie davon dass du wie zum Beispiel die Zeitungsverlage, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass ihre eigenen Werbeserver betreiben und so weiter, ne
deswegen großes Problem mit Facebook haben, weil du bist ja finanziert durch deine Spenden
Du musst ja eigentlich nur Reichweite haben und je mehr Reichweite du hast, desto mehr Fans kannst du generieren und diese gesamten YouTuber haben ja sozusagen auch im Prinzip jetzt dieses Modell übernommen, indem sie sozusagen über Spendenplattform äh durch ihre Fans sich refinanzieren,
Natürlich auch Werbung machen, aber die ähm dieses ganze Refinanzierungsmodell durch ähm äh durch die Fans ähm wird zunehmend dominanter und die YouTuber steigen zunehmend um von diesen Werbedeals weg, hin zu meine meine Zuschauer finanzieren mich, weil das so.
Lustig, ne? So im Prinzip übernehmen sie das Podcast.
Total, aber ähm mit mit.
Zukunft schon von.
Äh tausend oder zehntausendfacher Reichweite von dir. So, aber so äh nichtsdestotrotz äh ich finde das alles ähm total legitim. Man kann auch andere Meinungen haben, aber ich wollte mal erklären, wie ich das hier.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Quatsch machen würde, dann weiß ich auch, dass ich mehr Leute ansprechen würde.
Es hat nichts mit Quatsch zu tun. Es geht um die Plattform, nicht um den Inhalt.
Ja wieso? Ich meine die äh die ambitionierten Youtuber mit guten äh ordentlichen Inhalten, die haben jetzt auch nicht die Reichweite.
Guckt ihr zum Beispiel mal ähm wie heißt das hier? Der Kanal äh in der an. Das sind Münchener, die machen halt so kleine Erklärvideos
Die haben irgendwie vier, fünf Millionen Abonnenten weltweit und und äh halt jedes von denen Videos für zwanzig, 30 Millionen mal geschaut. Das ist der totale
Erfolg und es gibt ganz viele tolle auch seriöse Angebote auf Facebook Entschuldigung
und nicht nur Quatschcontent. Natürlich sind das keine fünfstündigen Laber-Podcasts
Aber äh auch der kann auf YouTube gut funktionieren. Also selbst das würde ich sogar äh sagen.
Aber wie soll der auf YouTube funktionieren, wenn du auf YouTube noch nicht mal herunterladen kannst.
Willst gar nicht runterladen. Du erstellst auf YouTube Playlisten und junge Menschen ähm haben das als Radio im Hintergrund laufen.
Es kommt halt immer sehr auf den Content drauf an. Also ich was ich über YouTube äh zum Beispiel mir anschaue oder auch nur manchmal nebenbei höre, will ich gar nicht runterladen. Also Podcast ist halt definitiv,
anderes und ich finde halt auch so ein Podcast kann nicht unbedingt auf YouTube funktionieren. Also ich nutze.
Ja, ich wollte dich nie unterbrechen.
Nutze YouTube halt echt grad nur für,
bisschen Recherche, weil ich grad ähm Women in Computing so ein bisschen recherchiere und da gucke, ob's kurze, spannende äh Filmsequenzen einfach zu verschiedenen Frauen gibt, die einfach eine Menge geilen Scheiß gemacht haben in der Geschichte,
und um Sport zu machen. Ich habe halt mal irgendwie jeden Tag Yoga und ich habe halt einen Yoga-Channel, den ich.
Von da.
Ist ja auch alles in Ordnung. Ich konsumiere ja auch Content auf YouTube.
Deswegen verstehe ich halt komplett, dass das Tim da überhaupt nicht hin will, weil das so.
Vor allem dieses im du hast ja auch ein Schlüsselwort gesagt, ne? Die lassen das im Hintergrund im äh als Radio laufen. So viel zu diesen Abrufzahlen, die für mich einfach
Watte pur sind, ja? Millionen Leute schauen sich das Video an fuck me, wer denn,
In Deutschland mit 80 Millionen Leuten mit all diese ganzen YouTuber Filme, all diese ganzen Zahlen mal zusammen. Das ist einfach Background neu. So viele Menschen gibt es überhaupt gar nicht,
überhaupt nicht so viel Zeit. Nein, es läuft auf Computern ab.
Es sind schon also eine ist eine ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das die aber unter anderem, was ich äh wodurch ich habe mich auch gewundert, was passierte, wie kann wir können das wir können
Kinder und Jugendliche so viel Zeit mit diesen
Streams und und Gaming und so weiter. Und eines der Dinge ist eben, dass sie eben quasi so, da haben halt äh meistens so einen Rechner, an dem sie irgendwie gerade die Hausaufgaben machen und im Hintergrund haben wir entweder ein iPad oder äh ein iPhone, wo sozusagen ihre YouTube-Playlist meistens eine automatisierte alle meine Abos,
hintereinander und die laufen so wie so ein Radio, so wie wir früher Radio gehört haben und jetzt.
Wie Leute beim beim Abendessen im Fernseher laufen lassen, da willst du mir noch nicht erzählen, dass hier nur noch irgendwas von mitkriegen.
Ich meine, darüber kann man diskutieren. Ich meine, das Radio begründet so äh Reichweite, aber ich ich nicht alles wird davon gehört, aber ich finde es auch nicht schlechter als ein Radio im Hintergrund zu laufen. Also.
Ja gut, aber dadurch relativieren sich natürlich diese Zahlen auch enorm. So ich meine, ich kann davon ausgehen, dass äh ich könnte ich würde auch niemals sagen, alle von mir gezählten Downloads, wobei die zehn Methode ja auch nochmal äh diskussionsfähig ist. Ähm,
sind jetzt 1:1 in Menschen, die das komplett gehört haben, zu übersetzen. Ist es nicht, ja. Was der Faktor ist, keine Ahnung. Ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal, weil für mich ja äh was ganz anderes zählt. Für mich zählt ja wie viel Engagement,
Und wie viel Wohlwollen,
kann ich erzeugen, die sozusagen zurückkommen. Wie gut kommt das an? Und äh dieses Feedback ist für mich einfach entscheidend, dass ich halt einfach Sachen mache, die für die Leute, die es erreicht, genau passt, weil die Bindung
Zwischen Podcast-Hörern und Podcastern. Lass mir nicht erzählen, dass irgendein YouTuber da rankommt.
Und zwar massiv weiter. Nicht nur, dass sie daran kommen, sondern dass sie übersteigt weit bei weitem was du leistest ähm,
Weil diese Plattform inzwischen sogar optimiert darauf sind diese Bindung nämlich herzustellen. Also es gibt ja jetzt diese ganzen neuen Features von YouTube live, ne, also Livestreams auf YouTube ist ja nix Neues, äh aber.
Ob du dasselbe Bindung meinst wie ich gerade.
Und dort wird während die Leute zocken, also ist eines der ganz großen Dinger ist ja dieses Gaming. Man denkt jetzt immer bei Gaming, vor allen Dingen da dran, dass dass es um das Spiel geht. Es geht aber nicht um das Spiel
Es geht um die Charakter und die Typen, so wie's bei euch jetzt auch in diesem Setting, ihr seid ja sympathische Typen mit all euren Charakteren und man man liebt euch in Anführungszeichen, weil ihr bestimmte Typen darstellt oder seid
Man hasst oder liebt euch so, ne? Und genauso hast oder liebt man Youtuber. So
Die zocken dann miteinander teilweise auch Crossover über verschiedene Channels zusammen und unterhalten sich dabei und die unterhalten sich über exakt die gleichen Themen wie ihr das hier tut,
ja? Äh nur dass sie dabei zocken. Manchmal zocken sie noch nicht mal mehr, also manchmal quatschen sie nur noch und lassen irgendeinen äh ähm Videospiel dabei ablaufen. Und ähm unterhalten sich über, keine Ahnung, die Schule, Liebe, Politik,
Alles, es ist total faszinierend und ich ich finde ähm auch, dass es total unterschätzt wird, was da an an.
Kommunikation abläuft, es ist faszinierend und dann gibt es eben diese ähm da ist ja bei bei YouTube und auch bei Twitch, was übrigens fast noch inzwischen der wichtigere Kanal ist, wenn man für Livestream spricht. Äh Twitch ist gerade der,
größte Konkurrent für YouTube und meiner Meinung nach, wenn die Typen nicht aufpasst, wird Twitch sogar YouTube ablösen. Ähm,
da ist sozusagen das Live-Feature und die ganzen Chats und die ganzen ähm sozusagen äh ähm Dinge, die man,
dort in den Chats interagieren kann, sind extrem ausgebaut. Wenn wir hier unseren Slack Kanal angucken
Es ist sozusagen ein ein trauriges Abbild von dem, was auf YouTube und da sind nicht äh irgendwie fünf oder zehn Leute drin. Es sind hunderte Leute, die sich gleichzeitig unterhalten und das übrigens immer noch so, dass es was bringt für die Leute, die da sich da unterhalten und das ist es ist super faszinierend,
behaupte noch nicht, dass ich bin sozusagen schon ein bisschen zu alt quast, um um das alles zu verstehen
Ich habe zumindestens gelernt, als sozusagen jemand, der sich mit dieser Kommunikation von diesen neuen Medien beschäftigt, dass ich da Respekt vor habe und nicht diese
Manchmal sozusagen äh so eine Ablehnung des ähm aber früher war alles besser sozusagen halt, sondern ich versuche erst mal zu verstehen, äh wie sich wie die das machen und wie die ihre Kommunikation machen und und ich erkenne da ähm
Überraschend oft, dass da sehr hochwertige ähm Diskurse auch stattfinden können und ähm,
das ist das würde ich gar nicht mal unterschätzen. Ihr könntet auf ihr könntet sofort einen Twitch-Kanal aufmachen mit äh äh mit mit der Freakshow. Der würde super laufen.
Aber was sollten wir denn da streamen.
Nein, Dennis und ich fangen einfach an zu switchen, wenn wir immer WOW zocken.
Also ähm.
Was jetzt so mal jetzt hier ein Kamera ins Studio.
Nein und ihr Missbrauch kein Bild, das Bild ist egal. Das Gespräch, was wir hier haben.
Ja, aber wieso sind das auf Video.
Twitch. Es geht das Video ist fast egal bei diesem Livestream. Es geht um das Gespräch,
Glaubst du nicht, dass die Kinder und Jugendlichen die ganze Zeit dazu gucken, wenn die Leute zocken? Die hören zu. Während sie ihre Hausaufgaben machen, während sie in der Küche kochen, während sie bügeln, während sie, was weiß ich, was die Kinder und Jugendliche heutzutage machen. Wenn sie sich Pornografie nebenbei angucken.
Aber unsere Sendung ist, glaube ich, eh nicht so für Jugendliche.
Pornografie, die man sich nicht anguckt. Ich verstehe diese Welt nicht mehr. Das ist nicht mehr meine Welt.
Nein, also das ist also da wird ganz viel gequatscht. Und Prinzip das Gleiche, was ihr macht und ihr habt einen super Content eigentlich für YouTube Live, für Twitch live und ähm ihr nutzt es nicht aus. Es ist ein bisschen schade und das ist eigentlich alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, ich meine, das ist jetzt dieser Slack-Chat jetzt hier äh kein populäres Einfallstor ist, ist mir schon äh klar, aber das ist.
Super komplex, weil auf YouTube guck mal, du gehst einfach auf YouTube auf den Kanal und sofort ist der Chat offen und ich kann sofort mitquatschen.
Ich kann da nicht mit quatschen, weil dann müsste ich erst mal ein YouTube-Account anlegen, habe ich nicht, deswegen geht das schon mal.
Gut, also Kinder und Jugendliche haben alle oder also alle alle unter vierzig, alle unter 40 haben YouTube-Kanal und haben einen Google-Account und können da mitmachen.
Letti? Ja? Hast du einen YouTube-Account.
Ja weil ich intensiv YouTube.
Uh
Auch einen YouTube-Account. Ich habe auch einen YouTube-Kanal. Ich habe, glaube ich, sogar schon drei Videos veröffentlicht.
Nein, also.
Kanal habe ich nicht, aber man hat ja einen Google-Account und damals ist.
So und damit ist es,
Ich ich weiß so, äh Tim, ich bin jetzt ich will gar nicht dich vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Mach, nein, weil weil.
Warum denn nicht? Nein, weil jetzt doch nicht so Feigheit vor dem Feind hier, da sind wir schon wieder bei dem Timer.
Wahrheit. Es gibt einfach nur es gibt es Potenzial. Es.
Lass mich ja auch gerne überzeugen, wenn mal jemand mal Argumente bringt, die auch belastbar sind. Ja, das finde ich ja auch gut. So, deswegen habe ich dich ja auch eingeladen, verdammte Axt, ja.
Hier sagen ja viele im Chat, dass wir so so was YouTube Vorurteile hätten und so, dass äh ich sehe das ja nicht so, weil ich habe jetzt zwar keinen YouTube-Account, weil ich da ich habe
einfach keinen Bock auf Account, aber ich gucke natürlich auch, YouTube, Videos ohne Ende. Haben wir ja auch, also ich meine, wenn wir von Videos reden, dann ist es ja meistens ein Video auf YouTube, oder? Also wir gucken ja YouTube-Videos
aber ich sehe jetzt auch nicht, was was,
Unsere Sendung, ich sage jetzt mal unsere Eis ist ja dein Ding hier, ne? Aber was diese Sendung hier, was was die bei YouTube verloren hätte oder bei irgendeinem anderen Ding. Also ich du hast diese Webseite, das funktioniert. Man kann da klicken. Es ist nicht schwer und klar könnte man bestimmt bei Facebook, YouTube oder sonstwo
noch mehr Leute erreichen irgendwie, aber ich glaube, wenn man ein gutes Format hat mit gutem Inhalt und auch schon wir haben ja schon eine Menge Leute, die zuhören, dann wenn das gut ist, verteilt sich das von alleine,
dauert's ein bisschen länger, aber wir haben dann sozusagen auch Qualitätshörer, die's auch wirklich hören wollen und nicht nur weil weil sie bei bei YouTube mit mit den Seitenvorschlägen von uns genervt werden oder so einfach nur vorgeschlagen werden, sondern weil's halt.
Der Punkt.
Reale realer Vorschlag war.
Vorher schon machen wollte ist sozusagen, dass mit den Versuchen sich hineinzubesitzen in andere Lebenswelten, ne? Das Ding ist doch äh zum Beispiel eines der Erfolgsmodelle wie wie Microsoft Office wieder relevant wurde, ist
weil sie Deal gemacht haben mit Samsung, das Microsoft Office vorinstalliert ist auf Samsung Handys,
weil es, ne, man könnte ja sagen, ja aber wenn die Leute Microsoft Office nutzen wollen, dann werden sie das doch wohl in den App Store finden. Ist aber nicht so. Die Leute nutzen.
Das ein bisschen entforcen kann ist schon schon klar.
Die vorinstalliert sind, werden genutzt. So, das ist erstmal die Lebensrealität von diesen achtzig, 90 Prozent, von denen ich immer spreche und wenn ihr die erreichen wollt, müsst ihr auf die Apps gehen, auf die Kanäle, auf die Palattform, die für die vorinstalliert sind. Da gehört YouTube dazu, da gehört Facebook dazu, et cetera d,
iPhone ja aber auf Android ist kein Android.
Ist ja auch scheiße Dreck.
Okay. Das ist der Moment, wo ich glaube ich gehen muss, oder? Nein.
So. Ist doch alles total sortiert. Aber ich meine äh
Könne ich Google jetzt an, dass ihr irgendwie Podcasts supporten wollt? Das ist jetzt glaube ich das zweite Jahr hintereinander. Ich warte noch drauf. Sollen sie einfach mal eine Podcast-App drauf werfen, fertig ist Tina. Sie hatten ja schon mal eine
war schlecht und dann haben sie sie wieder weggenommen. Das ist überhaupt das Problem mit diesem Laden, dass hier irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwas ankündigen. Ja und dann ein Jahr später machen sie was anderes.
Ja da bin ich, ich will nicht Google verteidigen jetzt.
Wievielte messen? Ja, aber den wievielten Messenger? Ja, du hast doch sogar diesen Messenger, jetzt irgendwie jetzt.
Das stimmt.
Letztes Jahr war das Alu, wie hieß.
Hallo hallo.
Wie wie hieß er da vor? Ich komme überhaupt nicht mehr mit, wie viel, wie viele Produkte ich schon angekündigt.
Bin ich jetzt in dieser Rolle Google verteidigen zu sollen, das will ich überhaupt.
Hast das in diese Liste.
Sollt die Kanäle bedienen, die erfolgreich sind und dazu gehört auch YouTube, dazu gehört Twitch, dazu gehört so, wenn man also das zumindest.
Ja, die erfolgreich sind und die vorinstalliert sind. So gut. Kann man natürlich machen, dass man sagt, okay äh Android-Telefone haben jetzt keine ordentliche
App vorinstalliert, deswegen muss ich jetzt das,
einstellen ist nicht so ganz mein Ansatz. So und deswegen irgendwie gleich auf YouTube zu marschieren, heißt natürlich auch extra Arbeit, extra Kanal
Neue Juristin, mit der du dich rumschlagen musst, mit Regeln, mit Stress, Kommentarkultur musst du bedienen. Mir ist ja auch klar, dass wenn ich auf so einem Kanal rumhänge, dass ich nicht nur einfach
posten muss
Instagram nur so ein Seitenhieb, weil äh ich bin natürlich nicht Instagram, weil ich lese nicht Instagram, ich atme nicht Instagram, ich verstehe Instagram nicht. Ich komme auch mit Fotos generell nicht klar,
da nichts zu suchen, das ist für mich einfach nur ehrlich. Twitter passt bei mir wie Arsch auf Eimer, deswegen bin ich da von Anfang an dabei
bin da auch immer noch, auch wenn ich diesen Laden hasse und äh
Facebook sorry Komplexität, ich sehe das irgendwie, sie haben irgendwie Mail und diese ganzen anderen Internetkatastrophen ordentlich gekapselt, aber leider das Ding ist in sich eine Komplexität, wo ich jedes Mal wieder äh davor stehe, wie ein Pferd vom irgendwie keine Ahnung habe, was äh Sache ist, nicht weil ich blöd bin, sondern weil ich wahrscheinlich doch blöd bin.
Ähm also sagen wir erstmal so, wenn du das angehen willst das Thema, dann musst du natürlich ein bisschen out of the box denken und mal ein bisschen auf deinen kleinen Dimension deines deines deines Single-Daseins als als Unternehmer,
zu sagen ein Youtuber der in gewisser Weise in diese Größen vorstößt, ne? Der hat dann natürlich, der ist versteht sich als Unternehmer und hat natürlich auch Mitarbeiter
sozusagen das geht los mit der stellt sich ein Cutter ein, dann fängt er irgendwann an Community Manager zu haben und so weiter und dann entwickelt es sich und es gibt YouTuber die haben 120 Mitarbeiter und äh haben halt natürlich äh die haben dann eben diese berühmt berüchtigten Werbeeinnahmen, die du
ja auch aus ideologischen Gründen, was ich sehr gut sympathisch finde. Ähm verweigerst und so weiter, aber,
sozusagen, man kann das als Unternehmen begreifen und man kann sozusagen Kontentproduktion ist eigentlich immer schon, ne, deswegen gibt's ja Zeitungen und deswegen bezahlt man sie. Ist eigentlich immer eine unternehmerische Tätigkeit. Du hast es eben, kommst ja eher aus,
Gesehen als sozusagen, ich mache das halt nebenbei adhoppi und äh die Youtuber haben eben dann aber dadurch, dass sie relativ schnell mit Geld zugeschüttet wurden, verstanden, dass sie,
oh das ging mir ja Geld und dann hat sozusagen das Einstellen von von Menschen, die ihnen helfen, die eben sozusagen entweder zum Beispiel Community Management machen oder die Wendung äh dieses Ganze verteilen und die verschiedenen Kanäle ist wirklich Arbeit. Ich meine das ist mein Beruf,
das ist genau das, was ich für meine Kunden mache. Jetzt zwar im politischen Bereich, ne, aber dieses verdammte Einstellen, alle möglichen Kanälen, alle Ka.
Vielleicht ist es ja genau das, was man nicht will, dass es sich am Ende anfühlt wie Arbeit, wenn du 20 angestellt hast. Ich denke mal, das was du machst, ist ja schon dein Job. Du hast ja gesagt, das ist, du hast das zu deinem Beruf gemacht oder irgendwie so, ne? Aber wahrscheinlich fühlt sich's nicht so richtig wie Arbeit an, oder.
Wenn es anfängt, sich wie Arbeit anzufühlen, dann muss ich ganz schnell was anderes machen.
Das ist ja die Sache. Guck mal, deswegen habe ich versuche ich auch mehrfach zu betonen, dass er das alles so wie er das macht, genauso richtig ist und ich ihm überhaupt nichts auflabern will. Nur eben, er hat mich gefragt, was wäre denn, was gibt's denn für Chancen, was wären denn für Möglichkeiten und ich sage.
Möglichkeiten, das ist schon klar.
Er hat halt genialen Content eigentlich, ne? Nachlechzen sich die Leute, deswegen schicken sie mir diese ganzen E-Mails, weil der Content eigentlich voll genial ist und weil der,
Sicht freuen würden, seinen Content zu vermarkten. Ja, also ich würde Tim sofort einen Deal bieten
X 1000 Euro und sagen, ich vermarkte deinen Content und ich kriege dafür die Gewinne. So, ja und sofort gebe ich ihm, meine Ahnung, XY 1000 Euro und Tim gibt mir den Conamy. Ich verteile das auf die Kanäle, kassiere die ich verdiene mehr als Tim,
Ende. Ich mache einen Mehrwert, weil ich sozusagen dann diese so und das ist das, was die Plattform.
Aber kannst du da nicht auch Zweitvermarkter werden.
Nicht, wenn Tim mir nicht die Rechte einräumt. So, ne, also das das ist ja das, weswegen er es ablehnt auf gewisse Pla.
Du brauchst auch keine Explosivrechte.
Nein, er ist ja sehr ein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Produkt, das damit darf er nichts anfangen, außer er gibt mir die Rechte, also.
Aber du brauchst hier nicht exklusive. Das heißt, Tim könnte das ja so weitermachen.
Ja genau, nee, das sage ich. Er soll oh Gottes Willen, der soll doch sein, in dieser Podcast nicht anstehen. Ich sage nur, genau. Aber noch mehr Gewinn macht er natürlich, wenn er das selbst alles vermarktet und er denen einfach nur Leute einsteck.
Probier das doch mal ein Jahr. Da ist ein bisschen Lange, ne? Für einfach mal so so.
Liebe Hörer ähm würdet ihr gerne das würde ich gerne euch das Gesicht zeigen von Tim das sieht so das sieht so aus als wäre gerade seine Mutter vom Auto überfahren worden.
Ehrlich gesagt fand ich Tims Gesicht vorhin bei der gesamten Diskussion über das Bildungswesen noch schlimmer. Da hat er noch verzweifelter geguckt, muss man mal dazu sagen.
Ja, gut. Aber ist schon recht also so also ich würde mindestens sagen so.
Jetzt alle reininterpretiert. Mal gut, dass hier kein Videostream gibt,
Es ist nicht so, dass ich mir nicht auch die ganze Zeit Gedanken darüber mache, ja? Also ich bin jetzt nicht auf so einer Position von
das haben wir ja noch nie gemacht. Äh wo kommen wir denn da hin? Und äh ne wir müssen ja ewig die neunziger Jahre feiern, weil früher war ja alles besser
Das ist eh nicht mein Film so. Äh andererseits
erwarte ich natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr als dass ich mich gleich äh auf jedes Pferd schwinge, was mal eben vorbei galopp,
kommt, weil das halt auch potenziell so auch Nachteile haben kann. Die sehe ich halt auch. Da gibt's Dinge, die ich etwas anders gewichte als vielleicht andere Leute. Was auch damit zu tun hat, dass bei mir Quantität alleine halt keinen Wert darstellt,
Ja, also ich habe sehr viel mehr davon äh in einem qualitativen Verhältnis zu,
der Hörerschaft zu stehen als in einem quantitativen Verhältnis. Für mich wird das nicht alles besser dadurch, dass mich mehr Leute hören, sondern das muss auch ein gutes Hören sein,
äh ich finde auch, dass diese,
nicht sehr niedrigschwellige Geschichte zum Podcast zu kommen, hat auch was für sich, weil Leute, die auf diesem Weg einsteigen in der Regel aber auch.
Länger hängenbleiben,
also oder überhaupt auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise hängen bleiben. Das könnte ich jetzt noch weiter ausführen. Ich glaube jeder, der äh in dieser Situation ist, wird in etwa wissen, was ich meine. Ich habe da schon so viele Storys in dieser Richtung gehört und das ist irgendwie ein gutes Verhältnis,
Wenn man so auf so äh Marktschreierischen
äh Plattformen ist, wie YouTube Nummer 1 ist, wo du so reingedengelt wirst und dann landest du auf irgendwelchen Argumenten eine Homepage. Leute klicken drauf, hören sich das 20 Minuten an und dann kriegst du halt wieder gleich so ein Kommentar um die Ohren geschmissen so,
überhaupt keine ganze Kontext, die Geschichte, alles ist irgendwie nicht äh klar. Das sind alles schon mal so Aspekte, die mich ein bisschen äh.
Und vor allem wenn erstmal das Werbevideo vorne am Anfang kommen würde, ich glaube da hätten wir auch schon eine Menge höher verloren bei der ich glaube die finden das gut, dass bei uns das nicht.
Keine Matratzen oder.
Keine Matratzen.
Keine Matratzen, keine Webseiten.
Wie gesagt ähm alles legitim und man kann sich für einen der zwei Wege entscheiden. Du hast eine Entscheidung gemacht und ich finde die total gut und ich persönlich nicht als Hörer profitiere ja auch davon, dass es eben so ist und nicht anders
aber eben, wenn man gerade ich meine, ob jetzt die Freakshow eine große Reichweite hat oder nicht, ist dahingestellt. Bei anderen Formaten von Tim
manchmal schade, weil ich mir denke irgendwie verdammt nochmal diesen Podcast muss einfach jeder Mensch in Deutschland hören, nur sonst so können wir unsere Netzpolitik mal verändern oder
Vorschläge ist auch ein toller, ne.
Jetzt pass mal auf. Angenommen du.
Genau das das Gefühl, dass es halt nur als Podcast funktioniert. Also du kannst halt nicht unterwegs in der U-Bahn YouTube machen,
Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es mit Spotify ist, das habe ich nicht, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass du halt auch in einer Berliner U-Bahn, wo du äh nur hast, halt auch kein Spotify machen kannst. Aber mit einem mit einem
Podcatcher mit einem normalen, der dir den Kram runterlädt, der lokal auf deinem Device liegt, den du anhören kannst, wann du willst
äh weil er einfach da ist, ist das halt was ganz anderes, den du jederzeit unterbrechen kannst, dann kannst du was anderes hören.
Ist der eine Vorteil tatsächlich den ähm äh den den sozusagen Podcast auf jeden Fall hat als einen Kanal, aber ich habe ja noch nicht mal nur von YouTube gesprochen oder von Twitch, sondern ich spreche davon
grundsätzlich alle Kanäle zu bespielen und ich würde auch Tim insgesamt mehr als Personality äh branden und sozusagen ihnen,
insgesamt als Person nach vorne stellen, was er ja auch nicht so richtig tut und man noch sehr verliegen tut sozusagen und ähm.
Bedeuten.
Na, das bedeutet, dass du dich stärker inszenierst, dass du sozusagen ähm,
in in Erscheinung trittst, auch auf anderen Kanälen noch verstärkt, dass du versuchst, nicht nur mal auf eine eine Radioanfrage zu antworten, wenn irgendjemand mal wieder ein Interview haben will zum Thema Podcast, sondern dass du dich auch anbietest gegenüber den Medien, dass du vielleicht,
Medienberater hast, der dir sozusagen, der dich platziert in bestimmten Wendungsformaten, dass du sozusagen Talks gibst, dass du versuchst, dich sozusagen insgesamt zu promoten und sozusagen nach vorne zu bringen, als.
Wer macht dann unsere Sendung.
Na er weiterhin, aber nee, nee, also müsste er natürlich das sozusagen, das ist schon.
Von Tim.
Guck mal, Tim, Tim Tim beschäftigt sich ja zu mit 60Prozent oder 80 Prozent seiner Zeit damit,
IT-Setup hier zu machen. Weißt du, für sowas hätte normalerweise alle Menschen, die irgendwie ökonomisch denken, würden sagen, ich stelle mir halt einen Typen ein, der der mir mein Setup baut und
meine Qualität, sagen Unique Selling Point ist das Radio machen, das Sprechen, das erklären, ja? Und er muss doch nicht sein eigenes Studio einrichten
und so weiter und so weiter. Also warum macht er all das? Es ist alles Liebe, es sei das Hobby und das finde ich.
Nein, es ist Forschung.
Auch Forschung und äh bietet ja auch Mehrwert, weil du da immer schön drüber berichtest. Aber auf der anderen Seite äh ist es eben äh ökonomisch gesehen, ähm würde nimmst du dir die Zeit, um um sozusagen äh deine Hauptstärken sozusagen nach vorne zu.
Ich wünschte, ich könnte da so viel Zeit reinstecken, dass das wirklich ein Problem wäre. Äh dem ist halt äh mitnichten so. Hier habe ich äh mehr Stabilität in diesem Setup, als es mir selber lieb ist.
Glaube ich auch, wenn man hier sich das machen lassen würde. Das wäre ja vielleicht erstmal ganz toll und vielleicht funktioniert's ja dann auch eine Weile, aber es wurde auch nur davon sorgen
von der eigentlichen Technik immer weiter entfernt. Vielleicht geht's die ersten ein, 2 Jahre gut, aber irgendwann ist man dann so raus, dass man sagt, ja keine Ahnung, macht das wieder geht und wahrscheinlich will man da gar nicht hinkommen. Du willst schon deinen Shit da irgendwie selber irgendwie haben und du bringst das ja auch vorwärts oder ist ja
also da passiert ja auch was und an deiner Software und Podcast wie du das alles verbreitest, da passiert ja auch was, ist ja nicht fertig, sondern das ist ja andauernd in einer ewigen Weiterentwicklung oder nicht.
Tim will einfach die Macht über alles hier in der Metaebene behalten.
Also muss ja schon sagen, Tim ist auch halt ein bisschen Control-Freak, oder.
Man kann sich ja amerikanische ähm Podcaster anschauen, die eben genau dieses sozusagen, die eben anders denken, ne und die eben sozusagen inzwischen halt,
Ein ganzes Podcast-Netzwerk sich aufgebaut haben mit,
Co-Moderatoren mit sozusagen verschiedenen also in gewisser Weise ist mir die Metaebene das ja auch, nur eben du behältst die ganze After-Produktion und sozusagen die Medien-Weiterverwertung, alles noch in deiner Hand und du
jemand, der äh so wie ich übrigens auch, sehr stark versucht ähm
selber alles zu machen und äh hast eventuell Schwierigkeiten ähm äh Kontrolle abzugeben an an und dich auf andere zu verlassen
mit deinem Charakter zu tun hat sozusagen, vielleicht hast du eine negative Kindheitserfahrung gemacht. Aber ähm das weiß ich nicht. Ähm ähm aber.
Eigentlich eher negative Erwachsenen.
Okay.
Und auch dieses Ganze sich irgendwie rumreichen lassen und so weiter in Medien, ich habe schon vor so viel Kameras gesteckt, ich bin über Messen getingelt, ich habe irgendwie äh Leuten gequatscht, ich war irgendwie bei n-tv und Pipapo in all diesen ganzen Kanälen und es ist so
ein dummes Gequatsche da draußen,
und das macht mich fertig. Also es ist auch so ein muss sagen gehört auch so ein bisschen zur Lebensqualität sowas nicht zu machen,
Das ist so ein Stück weit kann man das machen so.
Und da bist du ja dann sozusagen aus den äh Nullerjahren und so und noch äh sozusagen da schmerzt es noch nicht ganz so
Aber das der Schmerz wird größer, das kann ich dir sagen. Also man man erträgt irgendwann auch vieles nicht mehr und ähm das ist dann sozusagen auch Teil,
der Lebensqualität das nicht zu machen. So oder Dinge halt auch selber zu machen, weil's natürlich für mich auch wenn es fünfzig,
Nicht alt, bin jetzt nicht jung, bin irgendwie so dazwischen oder so, keine Ahnung, was ich bin. Ich fühle mich auf jeden Fall nicht unbedingt so wie das, was normalerweise 50 so zugeschrieben wird und ähm.
Ich will zumindest so halbwegs, soweit es möglich ist, auch einerseits erstmal top top of the game sein, ich will irgendwie genau wissen, was ich tue, so warum ich's auch mache,
Solange es noch argumentieren kann, finde ich's okay, ne. Wenn ich an allem zweifel, dann dann kann ich's ja auch wieder ändern und ähm das Lernen ist oft wichtig,
Also ich habe nicht viel Spaß an der Tätigkeit, in der ich nicht was lerne. Also wenn's Lernen aufhört, ist es für mich uninteressant,
mache ich was anderes oder gar nichts, aber nur sowas betreiben, um Geld zu erzeugen,
ist für mich kein Wert. Das ist äh dieses reine äh Bemessen an ich kann ja mehr Geld verdienen. Ja klar kann ich mehr Geld verdienen. Aber was mache ich denn,
In dieser Situation, in der ich in so
ähm Hamsterrad von, oh Gott, jetzt beschäftige ich Leute, jetzt muss ich mein Business developpen, damit ich irgendwie mehr äh Aufträge habe, damit dann diese Leute und so weiter auch noch miternährt werden,
und äh man muss sich die ganze Zeit mit diesem Sozialsystem äh rumschlagen und du hast dann auf einmal Montag bis Freitag und äh machst führst einfach dieses Nine-to-five-Leben, was ich einfach, okay, ich akzeptiere, dass Leute damit klarkommen, aber es ist nicht für mich.
Ich äh kann dich vollkommen verstehen. Ähm zum einen habe ich einen guten Kumpel mal gehabt, der auch ein sehr toller äh sozusagen so Politikberater ist, nämlich auch mal gefragt irgendwie
Warum willst du denn nicht mal jemanden einschauen, der sagt oh zu sagen, der hat irgendwie mehr 30 Mitarbeiter in seiner Beratungsfirma und er meinte halt, die
ändert sich eben deine Rolle, ne? Du bist dann eben nicht mehr derjenige, der wirklich rausgeht und die Leute berät, sondern du bist plötzlich der Chef und du musst dich plötzlich um die äh die Sorgen machen, wenn der nicht,
Der nächste große Auftrag reinkommt, musst du XY und Z entlassen und musst dessen Frau äh irgendwie und dessen Kinder, musst dir Sorgen machen wie,
also du hast plötzlich ganz viele Sorgen, die du vorher nicht hattest und dein dir das, was dir Spaß gemacht hat, ist ist eigentlich dann weg. Und du hast plötzlich mehr so eine Art Management äh Rolle und und bist gar nicht mehr so der creative
Personal und deswegen äh ist das eine total legitime Position, wo du
Kannst mich nochmal verteidigen. Was gefragt, was was könnte man tun? Das wäre die Perspektive und da gibt's auch gute Gründe, das nicht zu tun.
Ich baue ja grad diesen acht Bitcomputer von diesem Ben Eather, der auch bei YouTube das so vorführt, ne, 30 Videos. Und dann fragen auch Leute, warum machst du das eigentlich? Dann sage ich immer auch Spaß. Und dann fragen die immer, ja aber irgendwie
um irgendwas zu lernen oder für einen Job oder irgendwie so, also warum du brauchst du dann den Computer? Die sagen, nee, ich brauche den nicht. Ich mache das aus Spaß. Und das verstehen viele nicht,
Und es kann das wiederum nicht verstehen. Also ich meine, was machen die denn in ihrer Freizeit? Sachen, die in keinen Spaß machen oder was.
Es sind die anderen Dennis und die gibt es halt auch so und das ist so.
Aber die machen doch auch, also gibt's Leute, die machen Kreuzworträtsel, das ist auch Rätsel lösen. Ich löse halt Rätsel beim Computerbauen, weil da musst du auch Rätsel lösen, halt andere Rätsel. Aber am Ende ist alles Rätsel lösen.
Nicht so richtig so sicher, ob das mit dem Kreuzworträtsel wirklich so viel mit Spaß zu tun hat.
Beschäftigungstherapie.
Ja
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es eine gewisse Genugtuung dass man die entwickelt, wenn man so ein Kreuzworträtsel gelöst hat. Also ich meine, das kann ja auch.
Das habe ich früher auch häufig in der Schule gemacht.
Kann ja auch anspruchsvoll anspruchsvoll sein, äh da die Dinge heraus.
Aber immer das Gleiche.
Ja wenn erstmal alle Flüsse in Italien kennst und alle.
Ist immer das Gleiche. Wir hatten vorhin die Diskussion um Spiele und gewisse Spiele sind für mich nix, weil ab einem bestimmten Punkt sind sie immer das Gleiche. Wahrscheinlich fände ich World of Warcraft nach mehreren Stunden langweilig.
Aber zum Beispiel bei dem Thema Kreuzworträtsel. Also man war ja früher auch kreativ in der Schule, wenn uns langweilig war, hat man sich halt gegenseitig irgendwelche Rätsel geschrieben,
Und dann hast du halt auch wieder was zu tun gehabt. Also Kreuzworträtsel waren äh war ein Internet, hat eher so es hing in der Schule, wenn's langweilig war.
Ich meine es gibt ja keinen keinen Wettbewerb zwischen sozusagen einem Privatleben und einem ökonomischen Leben und äh man braucht beides.
Aber das ich glaube das ist ja wahrscheinlich genau der Punkt, dass das, was Tim hier macht, ist halt eben beides so ein bisschen und aus Tim Sicht wahrscheinlich doch noch mehr privat als halt äh Business und,
äh du siehst das glaube ich ganz krass von Business-Seite und deine Tipps werden bestimmt auch alle total super, wenn da halt jetzt hier so
voll hinter der Kohle hinterher wäre oder hinter also am Ende geht's ja um Geld. Also Verbreitung und mehr Hörer und so weiter, außer wir hatten jetzt hier den pädagogischen Anspruch.
Ja, auf der einen Seite schon, auf der anderen Seite, nicht nur. Also ich finde halt auch tatsächlich, wenn ich sendungsbewusst bin, will ich natürlich auch möglichst viele Menschen erreichen und mich dann sozusagen selbst zu kastrieren, indem ich nur auf sozusagen einen Kanal se.
Aufbiegen und brechen, meinst du nicht, die kommen von alleine.
Jein, also ich bin sogar der Ansicht, du hast recht. Guter Content zieht die Lese an, egal, auf welchem Kanal du ihn anbietest. Auf der anderen Seite ist das
deshalb problematisch, weil äh sozusagen, wenn ihr jetzt die Argumentation über Twitch oder YouTube würde ich sagen, dann ist es egal, weil dann sozusagen, da finden die Leute dich schon. Aber wenn du auf einem Kanal bist, der sozusagen von so einer kleinen Zielgruppe nur erreicht wird, dann ist es halt
als würdest du dich absichtlich verstecken und den Zugang zu dir erschweren, also ähm das ist halt
aber auch einfach nur ähm das kann man sozusagen aus dieser ideologischen äh man kann das aus dieser privaten Sicht sehen, ne? Also da würde ich sie einfach argumentieren wenn ich sozusagen richtig äh meine Botschaft rauskriegen will, würde ich versuchen auch auf allen Plattformen zu tun. Äh also Journalist will ich ja, dass ich,
überall gelesen werden kann und nicht nur auf 'ner Website sondern eben auch irgendwie auf Facebook und ich möchte auch auf Twitter sein und ich möchte auch auf Instagram sein und ich möchte eben alle Plattformen bespielen mit meinem Content, muss mich eben anpassen, aber wenn man natürlich sagt, hey ich mach das hier als Hobby
Und es ist mir gar nicht so wichtig, dass ich äh sozusagen äh Anführungszeichen alle erreiche und kommerzielle Ziele habe ich auch nicht, dann ist es auch total legitim
Wollte nur sagen, es gibt eben diese ökonomische Perspektive ist genauso legitim wie eine private Perspektive und ich finde, die stehen sich gegeneinander oder so, sondern
jeder hat seine totale Berechtigung und man muss nicht irgendwie das ausschlachten bis zum und so was weiß ich finde das auch alles so schön wie es ist aber es wäre halt noch Potential nach oben.
Meine, das ist ja schon so spät und wir haben immer noch nicht über Buchhaltung geredet.
Kurz was einwerfen? Weil wir hatten die sechsstündige Abiprüfung ja grad. Tim, es wird dich erfreuen in meiner weiß ich wie viele Stündigen wahrscheinlich auch sechsstündigen Abiprüfungen. Hatte ich auch Buchhaltung.
Du bist ja eh ein Buchhaltungsbrot, das haben wir doch schon gehört, aus dem Autohaus und.
Ach Scheiße, das weißt du ja immer noch.
Na ja, das war sogar schon mein Sendungstitel.
Echt? Ah.
Ja ja, das hat sehr.
Bisschen.
Übrigens nochmal.
Für alle mal.
Kopf gegenüber dieses was du gesagt hast, das ist sozusagen so dieses wenn du Buchhaltest, also wenn du diese Zuordnung machst, dass das so was,
wie so 'ne mantraähnliche Erfahrung ist dass du da so sitzt und einfach so vor dich hin so Dinge abarbeitest und dass das so 'ne schöne entspannte Wirkung, das kann ich total bestätigen wenn man weil es so befriedigend ist Dinge einfach so wie so ein wie ein Puzzle lösen ja und so dann.
Wahrscheinlich.
Kreuzworträtsel. Das ist halt so dieses ah ja etwas ich mache etwas fertig, ich ich wohne dem Kunstwerk malen oder so, das ist so dieses man ist in sich und man kann diese.
Ordnung in etwas rein will. Wo vorher Chaos war, macht man für sich eine Ordnung rein und eventuell sogar für andere.
Das ist sehr sehr sehr entruhigend.
Wir hatten das Thema auch schon mal äh erst so wieder über Interhemd und Versand von von zum Beispiel Merchandise geredet hast. Ich glaube, ich fänd's auch einfach geil, mal so einen Tag lang irgendwelche Bestellungen zusammenzupacken
schön irgendwie so eine Sache vom einen Stapel zum nächsten Stapel so.
Ist toll.
Tag lang echt denken, geil.
Mein Schlafzimmer war schon mal für zwei, drei Jahre ein T-Shirtlager. Das habe ich jetzt auch schon durch irgendwie.
Hausnummer dreiundzwanzig.
Haus Nummer dreiundzwanzig.
Ja
Ja, aber äh können wir trotzdem nochmal kurz das Steuer äh Thema ansprechen.
Welches der Steuer oder des Buchhaltungs? Alles.
Alle. Ja, weiß nicht, äh was hast du denn hier noch ähm.
Ich könnte erzählen, wie ich Buchhalter mache. Ich weiß nicht, ob's total spannend ist.
Du und Tim, ihr hättet da auf jeden Fall eine sehr gute Grundlage.
Weil wir in einem Podcast aufmachen, müssen wir die Hörerin nicht nerven.
Ja, nehmt euch meine eigene Sendung.
Anonyme Buchhalter.
Geht im Podcast youtube.
Das Einzige, was ich erzählen will ist, was ich sehr befriedigend finde,
Software einzusetzen, um Buchhaltung zu machen, also vor allem, ich bin so ein Fan von Cloud-Software, du hast ja mehr so den lokalen Ansatz,
Und es macht mir einfach total Freude, weil ich das Schöne an dieser Claus-Software-Lösung für Buchhaltung ist, dass alles in der Wolke bleibt,
Also ich habe quasi eine Software, äh die heißt Get My Invoys ist, kann ich sie empfehlen. Die sammelt von allen verschiedenen also von O2 sammelt sie meine Rechnung ein, direkt sozusagen aus dem O2 Portal.
Das heißt, du gibst denen deine deine Zugangs. Ja. Das ist ja ist ja wie das ist ja wie sofort überweisen.
Ich bin raus, ich weiß.
Spaqueria plus also das ist echt.
Hardcore. Ich bin also ich habe allen Postwörter gegeben so, ne einmal get all und dann also Get My Invoises sammelt sozusagen auf allen Portalen im Internet.
Ich finde ja, das müsste man müsste das verbieten. Nee, dass die das.
Eine Rechnung ein? Soll ich noch zu Ende reden, oder.
Nochmal erzählen, das ist.
Für manche Menschen. Ähm und ähm unter anderem auch meine Amazon-Rechnung und meine Facebook-Rechnung und so weiter, ne, was echt super spannend ist, weil ich irgendwie im Monat halt fünfzig Facebook-Rechnungen habe.
Rum. Wie hat man denn Facebook-Rechnung? Weil du Werbung schaltest.
Weil ich halt das beruflich mache. Weil ich Werbung schalte und die machen eine ganz schreckliche und die schicken die Einzelrechnungen und das ist ätzend und du willst das automatisieren sozusagen.
Du meinst, Facebook hat auch seine Buchhaltung nicht im Griff.
Äh Facebook hatte einiges nicht im Griff, aber haben genau Rechner.
Amerikanische Unternehmen sind mit Rechnungsschreiben ganz furchtbar.
Du willst das nicht manuell runterladen und dann wieder irgendwie ein. Also, sammelt, gebt mal Invois, dass alle meine Rechnung ein und schickt das dann zu. Das ist meine Onlinebuchhaltung
sozusagen alle reingespült werden in meine Rechnung und dann wird es äh von der hatte so eine automatische Erkennung und erkennt sozusagen, macht so eine Art,
Scan des Dokuments und erkennt wer ist der Absender, also welcher welche Lieferant bei mir ist das? Äh wie ist die Rechnungssumme? Wieviel ist der Mehrwertsteueranteil? Und ich muss dann nur noch äh einmal drüber gucken und bestätigen sozusagen. Das reduziert,
Arbeit, die ich habe sozusagen ganz massiv,
Also das ist eine eine sehr schöne Lösung und da gibt's jetzt auch 1000 andere Anbieter. Ich muss, das muss nicht der sein, aber ähm ich ich es hat eine unglaublich schönere, innere Logik ähm sozusagen alles in der in der Wolke zu lassen, ohne dass man diesen Prozess hat. Ich muss erst,
Die Rechnungen downloaden und dann muss ich sie wieder irgendwo hinladen und ach so und das das schöne Ende ist auch noch, dass dieses Seft ist für mich dann auch noch gleich die Umsatzsteuervoranmeldung macht,
Nachdem ich alle meine Einnahmen und Ausgaben dort äh erfasst habe, äh macht die Software dann auch gleich noch ähm am Monatsende die die Meldung ans Finanzamt direkt aus der Software sozusagen, das ist das, was du jetzt abführen musst,
Und das ist so eine einmal die Gesamtlösung sozusagen, aber ja, es läuft ja alles in der Cloud und ich bin verdammt, weil's irgendwann mal jemand.
Aber ich meine, wenn du so viel Business-Zeugs machst, will man dann nicht jeden Steuerberater haben.
Habe ich so zusätzlich noch Muster auch haben. Also ähm.
Du sammelst da schon mal vor, dass du das dann nur noch.
Der Steuer äh Berater lädt sich am Ende des Jahres na ja okay muss man nicht haben, wenn man.
Macht aber Sinn.
Sinn, wenn du auch gewisse Richtsicherheit haben willst. Ähm.
Hast du da keine.
Überhaupt nicht.
Nee, also im Sinne von du willst nicht deine banalen Fehler dazu führen, dass du einen Strafprozess vom Finanzamt hast, sondern du möchtest, dass dir.
Steuerberater die Fehler macht, für die du dann trotzdem haften musst.
Aber du hoffst natürlich auch dein Steuerberat.
Die Chance ist, dass schon, dass er weniger Fehler.
Er weniger Fehler macht, dass du mal.
Und dass du noch vor Gericht wenigstens sagen kannst, dass es nicht dein eigener war. Wenigstens für die fürs eigene Gewissen. Ich weiß, aber.
Aber das fand ich das fand ich einfach so eine Gesamtschönheitslösung für mich, aber klar, wenn man.
Also das ist natürlich ganz interessant. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt sozusagen dadurch, dass ich jetzt mal so Buchhaltung so ein bisschen äh verinnerlicht habe und mittlerweile bin ich auch an so einem Punkt, wo ich irgendwie alle Features meines Programms kann. Jetzt wird's schon wieder langweilig. Ist total in,
Schlimmer noch.
Ausgespielt.
Stößt sozusagen die ganze Zeit auf Limitierung und Begrenzung und so
Und ähm das ist eigentlich insofern auch ein ganz interessanter Run, als dass äh hier mal wieder auf eine ganz neue Art und Weise auch so dieses Cloud-Versus Deshalb äh Apps ausgespielt wird, ne. Äh man muss ja sagen, dass diese ganze Desktop-App-Programmierung doch ähm
äh schwierig zu sein scheint ähm wenn man sich so die Qualität der User-Interfaces anschaut, da sind also teilweise Webseiten
schon äh weiter durch Vereinfachung, durch äh äh klarere Modularisierung natürlich, weil sie halt auch einfacher umstellen können et cetera. Du hast natürlich auch Nachteile, ne, es gibt bestimmte Dinge, die äh nicht so gut. Das ist immer so Tipp for Ted, aber im Prinzip ist es ein offenes Rennen,
und ähm gerade jetzt so bei Buchhaltung, ich meine, wenn wir mal grob das Featureset äh jetzt hier anschauen von Septest, was du äh ähm,
äh erwähnt hast, also Mark glaube ich noch ein paar Programme geben, die zumindest unter Windows äh äh das ähnlich machen,
Zum Beispiel so dieses Belege mit reinwerfen scheint noch ein echtes Problem zu sein, ne? So die klassischen Buchhaltungsprogramme, die können irgendwie ganz ordentlich buchen so, aber so dieses Konzept mit der Beleg ist dabei, was man ja eigentlich echt will, weil wichtig und Bezug und so
ist er überhaupt nicht mit drin und derzeit habe ich das zum Beispiel so auf meinem äh manuellen lokalen äh System, alles separat und getrennt,
und ähm klar, wir hatten natürlich jetzt so ein gewisses Vertrauen rein, ne, was ist, wenn die Bude sich morgen irgendwie ihren Datenbestand wegkurbelt.
Na ja, dann bin ich der der der das kleinste Problem hat, die anderen Firmen sind größer und wichtiger und.
Aber das ist ja jetzt nicht ganz unproblematisch, wenn das sozusagen dein dein einziger Storage ist oder da, wo sich alles sammelt, ne.
Aber da da gehe ich halt davon aus, dass die wissen, dass die ihre zwanzig, 40.0000 Kunden, die sie haben, dass die nicht nur
die Firma dann im Ruin ist, sondern dass sie sozusagen sich für den Rest ihres Lebens nirgendwo, also die haben alles doppelt und dreifach abgesichert, also das sichern sie auch zu, sie sichern über über das eben einer fragt ihr gerade im Chat, warum warum muss alles in der Cloud sein
der großen Vorteile bei der Buchhaltung ist ja, dass du eben das noch finanzsicher für die nächsten zehn Jahre archivieren musst, damit das Finanzamt immer drauf zugreifen kann,
Und ähm es ist halt eben.
Nicht davon ausgehen, dass dieses Unternehmen noch zehn Jahre lebt.
Also die sagen sogar, wenn Sie pleite gehen, dass Sie sozusagen trotzdem die Sicherheit und dafür bezahlst du, genau für diesen Service. Das sichern Sie.
Sagen Sie.
Die Pleite sind die Pleite.
Die pleite sind, dann gibt's die nicht mehr und dann.
Also sie haben auch jetzt schon einen Download Belege äh Export, ne? Also das ist ja das, was so worauf's ankommt.
Das ist wichtig und das wiederum bei Buchhaltung muss man sagen, lässt sich verhältnismäßig gut formalisieren so, ne. Da gibt's irgendwie paar abgehangene Datenformate, die nicht alle unproblematisch sind, aber zumindest so kann man halt sagen
Ist irgendwie in DATEV rein und das müsste eigentlich alle gelesen bekommen.
Ne? Wo wo wo was weil mein mein Misstrauen ist sozusagen mein eigener PC also zwar ich meine ich bin zwar schon ein erfahrener Nutzer und und äh
benutze schon einen Mac, was ja halbwegs sicheres System ist und so weiter,
aber ja äh keine Ahnung, wie mache ich wirklich sichere, also mit einem Rechner kann man einfach keine sichere Verwahrung über zehn Jahre machen. Das geht einfach nicht. Dann kann man externe Festplatten nutzen, muss man aber eigentlich auch mindestens zwei haben, da musst du blablabla das irgendwie vorrätig halten, dann nicht alles in einer Wohnung liegen, denn wenn einem
einbricht, dann ist ja auch alles.
Was halt ein Cloud-Backup.
Ja gut, dann ist es aber dann die Frage, wo ist der Vorwurf gegenüber in der Cloud Buchhaltungssystem? Wenn du eh dein Backup in der Cloud machst, dann hast du genauso verloren wie ich, wenn wenn man sich in meine Cloud einbricht. Das ist dann ja am Ende.
Nee, weil du ja lokal verschlüsselst, bevor du's hinschickst.
Es geht jetzt, wenn die Firma nicht mehr da ist, die das klaut macht.
Das Problem ist aber auch mit deinem Cloud-Anbieter für dein Logo für deinen Online-Story. Also ich ich persönlich finde halt große also mir macht's halt Spaß, weil ich eben mich nicht mehr lokal um meine Sicherheit kümmern oder sie nicht mehr so stark kümmern muss und nicht mehr so viel Angst habe,
Sozusagen das Gefühl habe, dass so ein Anbieter, der sich nur mit diesem einen Problem beschäftigt, das besser kann als ich, der irgendwie mit meinem Rechner noch Computerspiele,
erotische Filme anschaue und sonstige Dinge mache, die sich hier nicht.
Ja, aber der äh Tacker kann ja auf den Anbieter wieder hunderttausend User hat, der kriegt der auch hunderttausend Daten und nicht nur die von dir. Das heißt, die müssten ja, wenn wir das mal umrechnet, hunderttausendmal sicherer sein als du und das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber kann man in dieser Online-Buchhaltung auch so richtig buchen.
Übrigens das Allerschönste, du gibst eben nicht nur einen jetzt Buchungskonto eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sondern du schreibst einfach Benzin und er weiß, was der richtige Konto ist.
Aber kann ich auch einfach.
Du kannst auch einfach hart auf Konten buchen. Es geht beides. Kann sogar eigene Konten anlegen.
Hart buchen.
Die haben natürlich dann auch so ähm wie sagt man so äh schöne Features wie zum Beispiel äh bei der ähm wie sagt man, hier so ein Geschäftsessen, was wir vorhin hatten mit den Pizzen, ne,
belegen äh da weißt du ja genau, es ist SKR null drei, richtig. Ähm,
Du bist nur vier. Ja. Ähm bei der Bewirtung zum Beispiel darfst du ja nur 30 Prozent ansetzen, wenn es mit,
70 Prozent einsetzen, wenn es mit Geschäftspartnern ist, außer das sind deine eigenen Mitarbeiter, dass du 100 Prozent aber auch nur unter Bestimmung,
So was wird zum Beispiel von dieser Software einfach automatisiert mit berücksichtigt, dass er dann sozusagen das macht und die äh updaten natürlich das System permanent und passen es auch ständig an an die aktuell Gesetze. Das machen die Local-Software natürlich,
Aber es ist in der Cloud äh meinem Gefühl nach deutlich sympathischer die gesamte ähm das gesamte User-Interface und ähm die,
die Geschwindigkeit, also die machen halt monatliche Updates, monatliche Feature Updates und die ganze Integration mit allen möglichen Cloud-Diensten ist halt wunderschön gemacht und es gibt tausend Plugins, dann kannst du sagen, okay ich will Reise äh Abbuchung machen, ne, dann bieten verlinken sie dich einfach ähm zu einem,
Reisekostenabrechner auch in der Cloud.
Der jetzt, wo ich bin, heißt Selftess. Es gibt aber so drei, vier verschiedene, die wir auch ganz gut sind, also Lexoffice zum Beispiel ist auch eine ganz, ganz okayer äh Anbieter,
ähm also einfach online Buchhaltung mal eingeben in die verschiedenen Suchmaschinen, da kommt tauchen dann die die großen Anbieter auf. Also ich glaube in Deutschland gibt's insgesamt so dreißig, 40 verschiedene für für kleine und mittlere Unternehmen,
Und ähm diese Anbindung auch äh ähm in diese ganze ähm,
sonstige Buchhaltungswelt, ne? Also wenn du zum Beispiel äh der eine hat zum Beispiel das Problem, man muss Fahrtkosten ständig abrechnen und da gibt's halt einen Spezialanbieter, der nur Fahrtkosten äh sozusagen dafür ein Interface gebaut hat und den kannst du dann integrieren, kannst du einfach in dein System reinpumpen oder eben Reisekosten ein,
oder du hast meinetwegen einen Onlinestore und verkaufst ständig T-Shirts, ja dann gibt's einfach ein Interface für deinen Onlinestore und deine ganzen Rechnungen, die du verschickst an deine Kunden werden automatisch in deinen,
und so weiter und dieses ganze Zusammenbinden von Dienstleistungen in der Cloud ist natürlich viel einfacher, als wenn du das alles vorher lokal realisieren willst. Das ist immer sozusagen ähm,
schwieriger. Und ähm jetzt gerade wo diese ganze Fintech äh Geschichte abgeht ist natürlich auch, da öffnet sich gerade erst wir fangen gerade also wir jetzt, also diese Welt fängt grade an.
Ein Universum zu werden, an Möglichkeiten äh von Inter Vernetzung, von von Banken, Buchhaltung, Steuererklärung ähm und so weiter und auch zum Beispiel meine komplette Lohnabrechnung für meine Mitarbeiter mache ich in der Cloud,
Ähm ist auch wunderschön gelöst, äh super einfach diese Cloud-Software.
Ist das legal.
Cloudsoftware macht für mich auch die Anmeldung äh an die sozial also ich bin wirklich als Nutzer, ich bin echt ein ich habe ja nee ich bin eigentlich Einzelselbstständige,
Und äh total unerfahren. Ich habe noch nie einen Personen beschäftigt, aber du meldest dich da an, gibst einfach nur ein, wer du bist, was du machst und wie wie Geld du deinem Mitarbeiter geben willst und den ganzen Rest, also die Anmeldung bei Sozialkasten, die Anwendung bei der Rentenkasse,
äh Knappschaftsanmeldungen, die Meldung ans Arbeitsamt. Das macht alles diese Software für dich automatisiert und nimmt dir einen riesen Berg an Arbeit ab.
Kostet das.
Auch KSK.
Künstlersozial.
Haben die auch im Angebot? Ja klar, können sie auch machen. Ähm und das kostet äh 5 Euro neunzig pro Mitarbeiter. Das ist unschlagbar günstig ist. Also,
Monat, ja? Aber zum Beispiel mein Steuerberater, wo ich's früher drüber gemacht hatte, meine äh Mitarbeiterbuchhaltung, der hat halt immer 19 Euro genommen, was auch schon sehr günstig war. Ne, also sozusagen als Pauschale pro Monat,
Und jetzt ähm aber klar, jeder der eine Software programmiert, um ein Problem zu lösen, ist natürlich immer günstiger, als wenn ich eine Person damit beschäftige, die das alles manuell macht, ne, weil,
einmal eine Software, jetzt muss ich euch nicht erzählen. Also deswegen, ich finde, ich finde gerade diese Cloud ähm Buchhaltungs ist es halt so, das beglückt mich so richtig, ja? Das macht mir so richtig so Spaß irgendwie, weil es wieder so ein
gesagt hast, Tim, ne, man hat wieder so ein, aber endlich mal wieder ein schönes Problem, was man wieder lösen kann, wo man für eine harmonische Lösung finden kann,
sage nicht, dass das da ist alles irgendwie ausgelöst, ist dort schon, aber ähm es ist unglaublich spannend, was da an Möglichkeiten ist und.
Noch noch getestet außer Lexoffice und äh Sef Tesk.
Ich habe mir eigentlich alle Buchhaltungssysteme angeschaut, aber ganz viele Buchhaltungssysteme scheitern eben da dran für mich aus meiner Perspektive, dass die Buchhaltung schlecht ist, also dass der Buchhaltungsteil so ganz viele, es gibt ganz viele Anbieter, die machen nur den Rechnungsteil, also sowas wie Fast Bill,
Easy, easy Bill heißt der andere noch und.
Also um selber Rechnungen zu.
Die machen halt nur den Rechnungsteil und die haben so eine ganz rudimentäre Buchhaltung, aber die ist nicht kompatibel mit einer echten Finanzbuchhaltung sozusagen, die du dann auch halbwegs seriös äh dem Finanzamt schicken kannst. Ähm,
Also das ist tatsächlich ähm da muss man sich ähm auf die Dienstleister gehen, die auch sozusagen eine eine Umsatzsteuervoranmeldung mit anbieten, weil nur diese Dienstleister haben sich ausreichend damit beschäftigt, dass du auch eine halbwegs,
legitime Umsatzsteuervoranmeldung machst. Da merkst du, dass.
Die machen letzten Endes hinter den Kulissen natürlich alle auch richtige doppelte Buchhaltung mit Stahlkontenrahmen, Pipapo, den kann man auch anpassen und so. Okay.
Nicht alle, aber manchen. Ja bei bei Sefa zum Beispiel kann man's anpassen. Bei Lexoffice kann man's nicht anpassen. Da ist äh da ist das begrenzt,
ist einfach nur schön und ich hatte, ich meine vor allem grade, also jetzt an alle Hörer mal da draußen, die,
Sozusagen irgendwas machen. Es gibt ja ganz viele Leute, die irgendwie selbstständig sind so als eine Person, ne und man und man hat die meisten haben ja dann ein
Steuerberater einfach nur da draußen und kümmern sich um nix. Also ne, schicken denen die die Rechnung
Das ist halt das wirklich Schöne, dass du sozusagen das erstmals das Gefühl bekommst, diesen Teil deines Geschäftes, wenn du sozusagen selbständig bist und das ist völlig egal, wie klein du bist, ne? Selbst wenn du nur irgendwie bei DaWanda ein paar äh Stricksocken im Monat verkaufst
dieses Gefühl zu haben, das zu verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert und wieder das Gefühl zu bekommen, irgendwie, ah, ich weiß, was meine Einnahmen, ich weiß meine Ausländer und wie das funktioniert und warum ich
bestimmte welche Steuersätze so und und ähm,
kommt auch plötzlich ein Gefühl dafür ähm dass man in gewisser Weise, weil man versteht, wie das Steuersystem funktioniert, dann auch seine unternehmerische Entscheidung ähm sozusagen mehr in Griff kriegt und und weiß,
gewisse Vor- und Nachteile, sondern da kann man dann mitdenken im Hinterkopf, wenn man bestimmt unternehmerisch, also zum Beispiel, wann kaufe ich mir was, ja? Wann im Jahr macht das Sinn? Äh.
Aber die Software kann nicht so gut bescheißen, wie mein Steuerberater.
Äh na ja, das würde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen sogar, weil die äh die Software ist schon so, dass sie, du kannst letztlich alles sagen.
Du kannst alles eingeben.
Alles eingeben. Wenn du falsche Sachen eingibst, bescheißt du trotzdem, ne? Du musst kannst dir sagen, also ob du sozusagen einen Laptop, den du für dich selbst gekauft hast, als Unternehmensausgabe oder,
Ausgabe, das ist dir überlassen. Der Betrug ist eher in dem Bereich möglich und das ist leider.
Dieses Bull, äh die Jungs hier, die Whiso-Truppe, äh die haben auch noch so einen Web-Ding. Hast du dir das mal angeschaut.
Nicht so richtig, weil ich glaube, die sind mir so im Nachhinein online gegangen. Die kommen eben eigentlich aus dieser lokalen Software und ähm das sind tendenziell nicht so die erfolgreicheren
immer versuchen ihre lokale Software dann im online im Internet abzubilden und die Startups die oder die Unternehmen Startups ist der falsche Begriff, die sind teilweise schon seit zehn Jahren am Markt, die von Anfang an das als reines Web-App,
haben, halte ich für etwas erfolgreicher, weil die äh mit einer ganz anderen Denke rangehen, ne.
Ja nee ist äh verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich glaube es ist auch nur diese Einkommenssteuergeschichte ne, aber die machen auch schon so ein bisschen an die für Selbstständigen haben sie och, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie weit das geht. Muss sagen, diese Viso äh Tools selber wiederum finde ich ganz
gut für Einkommenssteuer, also die funktionieren äh ordentlich. Ach so, äh will mal wieder das Mikrofon anhaben, Entschuldigung.
Ja ich nutze die auch, die wie so für wenn ich ähm also ich mache auch immer noch nebenbei Freelancing und es ist großartig. Einfach mal nix vergessen, dass du da einfach gefragt wirst einfach schon und Hinweise. Das finde ich ist ganz gut auf jeden Fall.
Machen denn irgendwelche von diesen Online-Tools auch an Kuschelerklärung.
Ja, aber davon würde ich tendenziell abraten
ähm weil ich also es kommt auf die Komplexität an. Wenn du äh keine Ahnung zwanzig Rechnungen im Jahr schreibst oder so ja und irgendwie 100 Belege hast als Eingang, dann
Wenn du keine transeuropäischen Rechnungen stellst, also die außerhalb Deutschlands sind oder wenn du keine
Spezialfälle hast, dann kannst du das auch mit den Online-Tools tatsächlich machen. Die bieten dann sogar von aus, gibt's sozusagen wiederum,
Schnittstellen zu anderen, die dann die für dich die komplette Einkommenssteuererklärung machen oder die komplette,
Das geht wirklich, wirklich, wirklich nur, wenn man ähm simplere Unternehmen und das wirklich mehr so im Nebenberuf macht und man macht dann irgendwie drei.
Die Einkommensteuererklärung nichts zu tun. Also ich meine ist ja nur dann.
Einkommenssteuer also als Selbstständiger am Ende nur die Einkommensteuer.
Gut, aber das einzige, was von deiner normalen Buchhaltung da drin landet, ist dein zu versteuerndes Einkommen und das war's und der Rest ist ja der ganze andere Klimper mit Krankenversicherung und so.
Zum Beispiel habe Vorträge, die ich im Ausland halte und dann muss ich halt die Reverse äh Steuer Mehrwertsteuergeschichte machen.
Gut, aber es ist ja Teil der Umsatzsteuer.
Richtig gut, richtig, aber das,
Ich ich möchte nur sagen, dass es eben Aspekte gibt von der Einkommenssteuererklärung, aber auch ähm ja die die sind etwas komplexer, aber auch zum Beispiel, dass man natürlich Spenden hat, dass du ähm Reisekosten mit abrechnen musst,
Du das alles kannst und wenn du alle in diesen allen Aspekten so sicher bist, kannst du das auf jeden Fall über die Onlinetools machen. Ich persönlich fühle mich da noch nicht so sicher, dass ich diese komplette Einkommensteuer selbst machen würde,
Bin da relativ happy, dass ich dann auch eine Steuerberaterin habe und die ist auch, hat man auch schon gute Hinweise gegeben und ja, das lohnt schon nochmal, da am Ende.
Große Verschwörung mit diesen Steuerberatern.
Ah ja, das stimmt, allerdings ist es ja nicht zufällig, sondern es hängt halt damit zusammen, dass wir das Steuer komplizierteste Steuersystem der Welt haben. Du weißt.
Ja und das Steuerberater, der geschützteste Beruf in Deutschland ist überhaupt.
Ja und die Hälfte der gesamten äh Weltliteratur über Steuern ist ein deutscher Schienen.
Ja, kein Wunder. Also da und das das ist nämlich genau der Punkt, ne? Wir haben so ein mega kompliziertes Steuersystem, was eigentlich,
Na ja, das ist eigentlich nicht total kompliziert. Es ist nur übersät mit Ausnahmen und Sonderregelungen. Das ist das eigentliche Problem,
So, weil,
An sich ist das Ganze ja verhältnismäßig einfach. Das ist so eine Erkenntnis, die man halt so gewinnt, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt. Also die die Grundstruktur ist ist ein bisschen wie mit dem Programmieren im Übrigen, ja? Es ist sozusagen im Prinzip ist das erstmal ganz einfach. Äh
Danach wird's dann äh etwas diverser und ich sehe schon den Trend, dass jetzt insbesondere durch diese webbasierte äh Buchhaltungsgeschichte.
Wie die Sache langsam so sehr in Griff kriegen und dass jetzt hier sozusagen auch so ein Empowerment stattfindet und das das das äh kann ich eigentlich nur begrüßen und vermutlich geht das auch nur übers Web,
Da macht's irgendwie auch Sinn, ne? Also auch dieses Belegevorhalten und so weiter, das ist äh schon so ein bisschen edel. Ich kann mir das jetzt irgendwie leisten und finde meinen Workflow,
auch erstmal äh ganz gut etwas besser integrierter hätte ich es auch gern, aber ich will auch irgendwie na ja weiß ja ne also ich will halt irgendwie in Control sein und so Cloud-Dienste sind halt immer so,
Nee, du kannst nicht überall ran. Natürlich lässt mir jetzt meine Buchhaltungssoftware mich auch nicht überall ran, das finde ich auch schon äh schlimm genug. Aber äh ist ja nochmal eine andere Geschichte, wenn du überhaupt gar keinen äh direkten Zugang hast. Also ich werde das auf jeden Fall mal beobachten. Mich interessiert das
total und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man damit auch noch eine ganze Menge schmerzende Seelen äh aus ihren Depressionen befreien kann,
Wie viele Leute das irgendwie in die in die in die Creme spült, das ist einfach nicht okay.
Beispiel einfach diese reine Tatsache, dass ich online meine meine Rechnung schreibe, sie online direkt auf der Software versende
sozusagen automatisch die Software mich nach drei Wochen ändert. Der Kunde hat jetzt noch nicht gezahlt, weil ich habe auch meine meine Bankkonten fließen ja in diese Online-Software, also ne, Dennis wird gleich wieder schreien, aber bei mir ist sowieso das mit dem Datenschutz ist halt alles äh kein das ist äh verlorene Liebesmüh bei mir
Das fließt da halt rein und der mein mein Software weiß, dass eine Rechnung noch nicht bezahlt ist und verschickt automatisiert sozusagen die Ermahnung
hey sie haben seit drei Wochen noch nicht die und die Rechnung bezahlt
letzte Mahnung und so weiter und informiert mich dann wiederum da drüber sozusagen über noch ausstehende Buchhaltung. Informiert mich auch da drüber, welche Belege noch finden. Ich kriege ja immer einen Krampf, hattest du auch mal erzählt, Tim,
diese ganzen Amazonrechnungen, die einem nicht geschickt werden, ne und meine Buchhaltungssoftware zeigt mir einfach hey hier das sind ein.
Buchung ohne Beleg.
Buchung und Beleg und brauchst dann noch eine Rechnung und dann ähm mein Get My Invois ist ja das ist ja die andere Software, die ich nutze, schickt automatisiert dann alle,
ähm Einkäufe die ich mache gehen automatisch diese bescheuerte schicken sie verdammt nochmal eine Rechnung ja das kann das.
Echt? Ja, das kann. Oh Gott, für Amazon richtig mir das auch ein.
Ist es der Hammer. Es ist so ja endlich, jemand hat das Problem gelöst und ähm ähm,
ruft auch automatisch diese in diesen E-Mail in diesem schrecklichen Amazon E-Mail-Postfach hinterlegten Rechnung auch automatisch ab, die man ja sonst so immer so wo ich immer nicht weiß, wo muss ich klicken, um in den scheiß Amazon Posteingang reinzukommen,
ruft das alles ab und da wo die Rechnung noch fehlen verschickt's automatisch die E-Mail, also
Es ist einfach so ein Traum, weil so viele Probleme einfach für schön gelöst werden können über dieses Internet. Also dieses Internet ist, glaube ich, wird sich durchsetzen.
Ein prophetischer Ausklang. Oh Mann, jetzt haben wir noch irgendwie genug Themen auf unserer Liste für noch zwei, drei äh Sendungen, aber ich glaube, wir müssen langsam mal äh.
Bahn fährt gleich.
Die letzte Bahn fährt gleich, genau. Hier wird schon das große T an die Wand gemalt. Tee, für Time-out.
Das war aber eine ziemliche Tim out, ja. Es war eine ziemliche Luftwand hier.
Okay.
Dazu.
Ja. Äh vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Äh das war so erhellend und äh bereichernd wie es erwartet hatte,
ähm alle anderen sagen auch tschüss. Ne? Wir setzen das fort, Sebastian.
Eure Steuern alle.
Macht eure Steuern. In der Cloud oder nicht. Okay, macht's gut, bis bald, tschüss.